THERE WAS A RESOUNDING GOOD
MORNING FROM EVERYONE SO LET ME
SAY IT AGAIN GOOD MORNING
[inaudible]
MORNIN.
WELCOME TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE THIS IS A
COMMITTEES FIRST HEARING THE
SESSION AT WHICH WE WERE HERE --
YOU OUT REQUESTS WE LOOK FORWARD
TO A PRODUCTIVE HEARING TODAY AS
WELL AS PRODUCTIVE SESSION FOR
THE COMMITTEE.
AT THIS TIME I'D LIKE TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM SO SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS PRESENT
[inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH [inaudible]
DEEP YOUR PATTERSON [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible]
CENTER ROTH [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
DORADO [inaudible]
HERTZBERG MONNING [inaudible]
MOORLACH [inaudible]
WIENER.
OKAY A QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED.
AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO TAKE UP
BEFORE WE TAKE UP ANY OTHER
ITEMS ARE A COUPLE OF
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS WE MUST TAKE
CARE OF THE FIRST WE HAVE TO
ELECT THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
AND ADOPT COMMITTEE RULES FOR
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY SESSION.
SO FIRST COMMITTEE SELECTED
CHAIR THE SIX MAJORITY VOTE OF
THE J. LACK MEMBERS IS THERE A
MOTION.
ON THAT.
SOME.
SO MOVED BY MISTER HERTZBERG
SECOND BY MISTER MINING.
A SECRETARY PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
MOTION TO ELECT THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SALAS HI.
SALAS AYE OR BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I DEEP I I
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WOULD [inaudible]
CENTER ROTH. FOR JUST.
BORDERS I DORADO.
DORADO AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE MINING.
MONNING AYE MOORLACH.
MORE LIKE I WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
THE MOTION CARRIES THANK YOU
MEMBERS --
SECONDLY WE WILL NEED TO ADOPT
THE COMMITTEE RULES FOR THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
LEGISLATIVE SESSION I SUPPORT OF
OUR PLACE WHERE HE COMES I WANT
TO WAIT TILL.
THE VICE CHAIRMAN CAME UP WITH
RESPECT TO THE ADOPTION OF THE
RULES SO HE'S HERE SO.
WE HAVE SOME QUESTIONS.
WELCOME MISTER ROSS.
WE ARE NOW AT THE PART OF THE
AGENDA TO ADOPT THE COMMITTEE
RULES FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY LEGISLATIVE
SESSION.
COPY OF THE PROPOSED RULES WAS
PROVIDED TO YOU BEFORE THE
HEARING TODAY.
THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY IDENTICAL
TO THE AUDIT COMMITTEES RULES --
FOR TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I HAVE SPOKEN TO MR
VICE CHAIRMAN AND TO SEVERAL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
WITH THAT I WILL NEED A MOTION
BUT I BELIEVE MISTER ROTH YOU
HAVE A COMMENT TO MAKE FIRST
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
I'M CLEAR.
THAT THE AND THERE'S SOME.
WHAT APPEARED CHANGES TO THE
RULES AND THAT'S FINE I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT IN?
ADOPTING THESE CHANGES.
OF THAT THERE IS NO CHANGE TO
THIS AND THAT IS THAT SHOULD A
HONOR REQUEST COME FORWARD FROM
A MEMBER [inaudible]
THE CHAIR.
DOES NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY
UNDER THESE CHANGES TO HOLD THAT
REQUEST BUT INSTEAD MUST BRING
THE REQUEST TO THIS COMMITTEE
FOR REVIEW IS THAT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING.
THAT'S CORRECT THE RULES ARE
BASICALLY IDENTICAL TO THE AUDIT
COMMITTEE RULES FROM THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SESSION.
AS STATED IN JOINT ROLE MEETING
NUMBER TWENTY THE CHAIR SHALL
SET THE HEARING OF AUDIT REQUEST
AND ARRANGE THE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS.
NOTICE OF HEARING ABOUT A
REQUEST WILL BE GIVEN TO THEIR
QUESTOR AND SUCH OTHER
APPROPRIATE PERSONS REQUIRING
NOTICE.
ON A REQUEST WILL NOT BE
CONSIDERED IN THE ABSENCE OF THE
REQUESTED WITHOUT HIS OR HER
CONSENT HOWEVER I REQUEST MAY BE
PRESENTED BY THE REQUEST IS
REPRESENTATIVE AUTHORIZED IN
WRITING.
SO I BELIEVE THAT --
SETTLED THAT ISSUE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
YES QUESTION YOUR QUESTION SIR.
YES JUST FOR COMPLETE CLARITY SO.
SO.
THE UNDER THE RULES THAT WERE
ADOPTING.
CLOSING QUESTION OF THIS ON THE
RULES WERE ADOPTING.
ANY AUTO REQUEST THAT IS
SUBMITTED THE CHAIR.
SHALL SCHEDULE A NOTE AND
THERE'S NO DISCRETION FOR THE
CHAIR. TO THE CLIENT SCHEDULED
[inaudible]
CORRECT THAT.
SO THE ISSUE OF SHALL IN MAY.
WHICH IS ADOPTED IN THE SENATE
RULES AND THE DOCTORS IN THE
ASSEMBLY RULES WHERE THE CHAIR
OF EACH COMMITTEES AS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS YOU HAVE THAT
AUTHORITY UNDER THE JOINT RULES
THE FIRST SENTENCE OF JOINT RULE
TWENTY THE CHAIR SHALL IT'S A
SHALL.
SET THE HEARINGS OF ODD REQUESTS
AND ARRANGE THE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS.
SO THE CHAIR HAS TO SET
[inaudible]
YEAH.
HEY GUYS GONNA FURTHER
CLARIFICATION BASED ON OUR
DISCUSSIONS FOR THE RECORD.
AND THAT IS THAT UNLIKE OTHER.
COMMITTEES WILL THIS HAS A TWO
CHARACTERISTICS ARE DIFFERENT
THE OTHER COMMITTEES ONE IS THAT
IT HAS MEMBERS OF BOTH HOUSES.
ARM AND TO I AM THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE MEMBERS WILL
SUBMITTED AUDIT LETTER.
I WANT TO FIND MYSELF IN A
SITUATION WHERE SOMEBODY
SUBMITTED AUDIT LETTER AND IT
TURNS OUT THAT IT WASN'T SET OR
WOULD EVEN KNOW WITH EXISTED
BECAUSE STAFF AND FOR MY STAFF
THEY THOUGHT THAT WAS THE CASE
BUT THERE ARE INSTANCES I'M TOLD.
WORLD AUDIT LETTER WILL BE
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE AND
THEN IT'S WITHDRAWN.
IN THE CASES OF THE WITHDRAWAL
IT'S NOT NOTICE BECAUSE LIKE WE
HAVE ON THE HEARING TODAY
CERTAIN MEMBERS WHO ACTUALLY
JOINED TOGETHER IN THIS IN THE
IN AN ALTERNATIVE AUDIT LETTER
WHICH IS FINE BUT THE NOTION IS
IN THE BILL RULES OR VOTING ON
TODAY IS THAT.
EVERY SINGLE MEMBER OF EITHER
HOUSE OF EITHER PARTY WHO
SUBMITS AND WANTS TO PURSUE AN
AUDIT WHETHER WE CHOOSE TO
PURSUE IT OR NOT IS A SEPARATE
QUESTION IS COMMITTEE.
BUT THAT IT COMES BEFORE THE
FULL BODY THAT'S THE THING
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND I THINK.
AND THE ANSWER THAT QUESTION IS
YES CORRECT THE ANSWER THAT
QUESTION IS YES IT'S GOING TO BE
CARRIED THROUGH AS PREVIOUS
AUDIT COMMITTEE RULES --
THAT WE SEEN IN --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUT WE DO ALLOW THE AUTHOR OF
ANY AUDIT REQUEST TO PULL THEIR
REQUEST UPON --
THEY'RE PREPPY IF THEY IF THEY
SO CHOOSE TO DO SO.
BUT THAT SAID DEPENDENT ON THE
U. PROVIDED ONLINE ALLIANCE OF
WHICH YOU PUT YOU GIVE THAT
OPTION UP AND UP UNTIL WHICH AT
THAT TIME LINE BEFORE EACH
COMMITTEE.
THEY CAN'T PULL IT IS HEARD
BEFORE THE FULL COMMITTEE.
THOSE ARE THE COMMITTEE
DEADLINES CAREER LATER QUESTOR
NOT A REQUEST TO BE IN BY A
CERTAIN DATE SO THAT THE
COMMITTEE CAN DO ITS WORK.
THE AUDITOR CAN TO HER DUE
DILIGENCE ABOUT TRYING TO
ESTIMATE THE COST IN THE HOURS
THAT IT WOULD TAKE TO FULFILL
SUCH AUDIT.
BUT IT IS UP TO THE REQUESTED AT
THAT TIME WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WISH TO PURSUE.
THAT HONOR REQUEST TO BE HEARD
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
OR TO WITHDRAW THE REQUEST.
SO HOPEFULLY THAT BRINGS CLARITY
AND I'D LIKE TO OBVIOUSLY
WELCOME THE NEW MEMBERS TO J.
LACK AS WELL AS WELL AS MYSELF.
AND WITH THAT I'LL ASK FOR A
MOTION TO ADOPT THE RULES SO
MOVE.
RIGHT MOVE BY MISTER ROTH SECOND
BY MISTER BORDERS --
COMMITTEE SECTOR CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO ADOPT THE COMMITTEE
RULES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS AYE SALAS
AYE.
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I DEEP I DEEP I
PATTERSON.
PERSON I RUBIO [inaudible]
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WOULD [inaudible]
SENATOR ROTH.
ROTH AYE BARGES.
BORDERS I DORADO.
DORADO AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE MOORLACH
[inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
THE MOTION CARRIES THANK YOU
MEMBERS SO LOOK FORWARD TO A
VERY PRODUCTIVE.
SEASON IN THIS --
TWO YEAR SESSION. FOR FOR THE
JAIL AT COMMITTEE AND I
APPRECIATE EACH OF YOU GUYS YOUR
YOUR WORK IN.
BEING DILIGENT ABOUT.
THIS COMMITTEES WORKING ENSURING
THAT WERE.
LOOKING AFTER THE TAXPAYERS
DOLLAR.
AND THE WERE MAKING SURE THAT
OUR AGENCIES ARE ACCOUNTABLE AND
EFFICIENT.
AS MUCH AS THEY CAN BE --
WITH THAT NEXT MOVED TO AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS A
PRESENTATION BY THE STATE
AUDITOR.
AND WE WILL MOVE TO YOU MISS HOW.
AND YOU CAN MAKE A MEAN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU.
MY MY SON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS FOR THE RECORD MY NAME
IS ELAINE HALL AND THE STATE
AUDITOR --
AND I'D LIKE ALSO LIKE TO
WELCOME NEW MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND ALSO CERTAINLY
NEW MEMBERS OF THE AUDIT
COMMITTEE --
STATUS REPORT IS RELATIVELY.
BRIEF -- WE
CURRENTLY HAVE SIXTEEN AUDITS
UNDERWAY FIFTEEN OF THOSE ARE
AUDITS THAT.
ARE YOUR PREDECESSORS A JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE --
IN VARIOUS HEARINGS LAST YEAR
MOSTLY AT THE THE LAST HEARING
IN AUGUST IS WHERE WE GET.
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK THAT
CARRIES US THROUGH OUR MEMBERS
RETURNING TO SACRAMENTO HERE AND
IN BACK IN JANUARY SO WE HAVE
FIFTEEN J. LACKS ON AUDITS UNDER
WAY ONE STATUTORY AUDIT IT'S AN
AUDIT OF THE STATE BAR THAT WERE
RESPONSIBLE.
FOR CONDUCTING EVERY TWO YEARS --
WE ALSO HAVE A COUPLE OF OTHER
WHERE WE HAVE AUTHORITY TO HIGH
RISK AUDITS --
BASICALLY TO THE EXTENT WE HAVE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE IF WE'VE MET
ALL OF THE RESPONSIBILITIES
UNDER THE THEASSIGNMENTS THAT
THIS COMMITTEE HAS GIVEN TO MY
OFFICE AND ANY OTHER STATUTORY
WORK WE HAVE THE ABILITY CAN
TALK SOME HIGH RISK WORK.
I HAVE AN INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
TEAM.
IN MY OFFICE --
AND THEY ARE CURRENTLY
CONDUCTING AN AUDIT OF SECURITY
OVER -- DATA
AT SOME OF THE STATE AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA WE DID OR NOT IN A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO FOUND SOME
ISSUES THIS IS REALLY KIND OF
FOLLOWING UP WITH SOME OF THOSE
DEPARTMENT SO THAT SOME WORK
WE'RE DOING.
WE ALSO ARE CONDUCTING A FOLLOW
UP WORK ON AN AUDIT WE ISSUED A
FEW YEARS AGO SO --
HAVE A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
PROJECTS UNDER WAY WE DO HAVE
SOME STATUTORY WORK THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO START LATER
THIS YEAR PROBABLY AROUND JUNE
OR JULY --
WE ANNUALLY AUDIT EITHER
JUDICIAL ENTITIES SOME COURTS IN
THE STATE WITH RESPECT TO THEIR
PROCUREMENT PRACTICES.
IN THE OPPOSITE YEAR WERE ASKED
TO LOOK AT JUDICIAL COUNCIL SO
THIS YEAR WILL BE COMMENCING AN
AUDIT PROBABLY AROUND JULY
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO WAIT FOR THE
BUDGET TO BE APPROVED --
IT'S PART OF BUDGET --
LANGUAGE --
SO WE WILL COMMENCE THAT AUDIT
IN JULY THERE WERE A COUPLE OF
OTHER AUDITS THAT WERE.
PASSED IN INITIATIVES WERE
RESPONSE LATER TO PROP FIFTY
CALL TAX I AT ADMIN STE --
AND THE DETERMINATION OF THOSE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS BY VARIOUS
STATE ENTITIES.
THE OTHER STATUTORY WORK THAT WE
HAVE COME AND STE --
THAT WILL LAST FOR AT LEAST A
YEAR AND A HALF.
OR TWO YEARS IS WE HAVE STARTED
WORKING ON REDISTRICTING AS YOU
KNOW MY OFFICE WAS GIVEN THE
RESPONSIBILITY UNDER PROPER
ELEVEN BACK IN. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT TO CREATE A PROCESS TO
ESTABLISH A CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION.
HEY WE CONDUCTED THAT WORK
ESTABLISH THE COMMISSION BACK IN
TWENTY TEN IT IT DID ITS JOB AS
FAR AS DRAWING MAPS.
TIME HAS FLOWN AND HERE WE ARE
AGAIN SO WE HAVE COMMENCED THE
OUTREACH PROCESS WE WENT THROUGH
A COMPETITIVE PROCESS SELECTED A
VENDOR THAT'S CAN ASSIST US WITH
OUTREACH --
AS FAR AS PUBLIC RELATIONS
DEVELOPING A WEBSITE THOSE SORTS
OF THINGS IT'S IN THE EARLY
STAGES WE HAD A TOWN HALL
MEETING.
ALL LAST FRIDAY IN MY OFFICE WE
CONDUCTED A WEAPON ARE TO ALLOW
VARIOUS INTEREST GROUPS ANY
ENTITIES THAT ARE INTERESTED IN
THIS PROCESS --
TO PARTICIPATE JUST TO LET THEM
KNOW HE WORK WE'RE JUST STARTING
OUT.
HERE ARE IDEAS DO YOU HAVE SOME
SUGGESTIONS SO THE APPLE ACTUAL
APPLICATION PROCESS FOR THE
COMMISSION WILL NOT START UNTIL
JUNE -- BUT
THERE'S ONLY A FEW MONTHS AWAY
SO BETWEEN NOW AND JUNE WE WILL
BE.
TRAVELING ABOUT THE STATE
TALKING TO VERY ABOUT THE
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF OF THE WORK THAT
THAT COMMISSION WILL DO I JUST
WANTED TO TO MENTION THAT TO THE
COMMITTEE I TALK.
TO ABOUT IT A LITTLE BIT YEAH IN
AUGUST OF LAST YEAR THAT IT
WOULD BE COMING UP AND WE NOW
HAVE BASICALLY KICK STARTED THAT
CAMPAIGN.
SO BEFORE YOU TODAY MEMBERS YOU
HAVE EIGHT AUDIT REQUESTS --
AND WE HAVE RESOURCES OVER THE
COURSE OF THE NEXT TWO TO THREE
MONTHS TO START SEVEN AUDITS.
ARE WE WILL BE ABLE TO START
MOST OF THOSE AUDITS IN MARCH
AND APRIL --
THIS MONTH AND NEXT MONTH AS WE
HAVE STAFF CYCLING OFF OF AUDITS --
THAT ARE WILL BE COMPLETED WILL
BE PUBLISHING IN MARCH AND APRIL
SO -- OF THE
ARTISTS THAT YOU CONSIDER TODAY --
WE CAN START SEVEN RELATIVELY
SOON -- IF
THE COMMITTEE CHOOSES TO PROVE
ALL EIGHT THEN AS SOON AS
ANOTHER STE --
TEAM COMPLETE TO NOT IT WILL
ROTATE THAT TEAM ONTO THE THE
ADDITIONAL AUDIT THAT IS
APPROVED --
WITH THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN I CAN
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS MEMBERS MAY
HAVE ABOUT OUR WORK IN PROGRESS --
OUR WORK IS CONFIDENTIAL UNTIL
WE ISSUE IT PUBLICLY BUT I COULD
CERTAINLY IF MEMBERS ARE
INTERESTED AND THE AUDITS WERE
WORKING ON TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE SCOPE IF NECESSARY
PRESENTATION --
BEFORE WE MOVE INTO QUESTIONS
SINCE WE HAVE ALL THE MEMBERS
HERE I'D LIKE TO ADOPT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
BEFORE WE LOSE --
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS TO OTHER
COMMITTEES THAT ARE ALSO
HAPPENING CONCURRENTLY --
WITH THAT MEMBERS --
THERE'S AGREEMENT BETWEEN BOTH
HOUSES WE HAVE A SAVAGE PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR OF TWO ITEMS.
ITEM NUMBER ONE TWO ZERO ONE
NINE DASH ONE ZERO THREE COUNTY
EMERGENCY PLANS EVACUATION OF
THE ELDERLY AND DISABLED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY WHO'S IN
THE AUDIENCE --
NUMBER TWO TWO ZERO ONE NINE
DASH ONE ZERO FIVE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH MANAGEMENT OF
BLOOD LEAD TEST.
AND SERVICES BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES AND MYSELF ARE WE STILL IN
AGREEMENT SO MOVED [inaudible]
YES.
I APPRECIATE THAT BUT FIRST
BEFORE WE ADOPT THAT IN CONSENT
WE MUST WAVE WE MUST SUSPEND J.
LIKE RULES NUMBER THIRTEEN AND
NUMBER.
FIFTEEN WHICH WILL ALLOW THE
STATE AUDITOR'S KNOWS TO BE
PUBLICLY RELEASED WHICH IS WILL.
THIRTEEN RULE FIFTEEN WILL ALLOW
THE COMMITTEE TO WAIVE
DISCUSSION ABOUT IT REQUESTS AND
ANALYSIS AND TAKE ACTION. TO
HAVE A MOTION ON SUSPENDING ROLE
THIRTEEN AND FIFTEEN FIRST.
ALL RIGHT MOVE BY --
BORDER **** BATH SECOND BY.
MISTER DEEP.
A SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO SPEND SUSPEND RULES
THIRTEEN AND FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS.
SOUTH AYE BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I DEEP I DEEP I
PATTERSON.
PERSON I RUBIO [inaudible]
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WOULD [inaudible]
SENATOR ROTH [inaudible]
I ORDERS. FOR JUST I DORADO.
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HI MONNING.
MONNING AYE MOORLACH.
MOORLACH I WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
THE MOTION CARRIES I BELIEVE WE
HAD A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WAS MOVED BY MISTER
ROGERS.
IN SECOND AND BY.
HI MISTER DEEP --
MISTER CALDERON.
MOTION IS TO APPROVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AUDIT NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ONE OH THREE EVACUATION
OF THE ALR ELDERLY AND DISABLED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY.
AUDIT NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ONE OF FIVE DEPARTMENTS
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
PUBLIC HEALTH.
MANAGEMENT OF BLOOD LEAD TASKS
AND SERVICES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAY AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS HI.
SALAS HI BOERNER HORVATH HI.
BOERNER HORVATH I DEEP I DEEP I
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I RUBIO.
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WOULD [inaudible]
SENATOR ROTH.
ROTH AYE BARGES.
OR JUST I DORADO.
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE MOORLACH.
MOORLACH I WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
THE MOTION CARRIES ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
AND WE WILL RETURN BACK TO
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER TWO
PRESENTATION BY THE STATE
DAUGHTER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION I WILL NOW OPEN IT
UP FOR QUESTIONS IF THERE'S
QUESTIONS MR HERTZBERG PLEASE.
HOW MANY HAVE TEASED YOU HAVE AN
OFFICE?
HOW MANY F. TO EASE WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY I THINK A? HUNDRED
NINE HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE STAFF
AND IS THAT BEEN CONSISTENT THE
LAST TEN YEARS.
LAST TEN YEARS IT DID NOT HAS
NOT BEEN THAT CONSISTENT WE'VE
GROWN A LITTLE BIT IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS SO IT WE WERE SMALLER.
PROBABLY SIX OR EIGHT YEARS AGO.
I HAVE ASKED THE CHAIR THIS AND
I'M JUST GOING TO ISSUE SPOTTED
FOR THE COMMITTEE.
OUR AND I KNOW THAT THE TALKS
POKEY TOLD ME TO A SPOKE TO THE
VICE CHAIR ON THIS COMMITTEE I'M
INTERESTED IN IN YOUR ESTIMATES.
AND HOW SUCCESSFUL YOU'VE BEEN
YOU COME IN AND WE WERE MAKING
DECISIONS BASED UPON ESTIMATES --
BUT THE QUESTION I'M ASKING IS
IN THE EVENT THAT THE ESTIMATE
IS.
UP UNDER IS OKAY BUT IF IT'S
OVER YOU COME BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE TO ASK FOR FURTHER FOR
FURTHER APPROVAL OF THE AMOUNT
OF A PROBATION.
WE DO NOT COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE IF AN AUDIT ENDS UP
GOING IT ENDS UP COSTING MORE
THAN WHAT.
THE ESTIMATES ARE IN THE IN THE
ANALYSIS --
IN LOOKING AT OUR WORK --
WE IT SOME THAT COME IN UNDER
BUDGET THERE ARE SOME THE END UP
GOING OVER BUDGET THE REASON IS
A LOT OF TIMES WE END UP GOING
OVER BUDGET IS THIS IS OUR BEST
GUESS WE HAVEN'T HAD THE UP TO
TALK TO THE DEPARTMENTS.
SOMETIMES WE RUN INTO ACCESS
ISSUES SOMETIMES IT'S ISSUES
WITH THE DATA --
BUT IN IN THEY ANALYSIS THAT
WE'VE DONE AND IT'S AT LEAST A
YEAR AND A HALF OLD TO BE FULL
DISCLOSURE.
MOSTLY THE AUDITS ARE WITHIN
10215% OF THE ESTIMATE OF WHAT
NOW WE PRESENT --
I PRESENT TO THE COMMITTEE.
BUT THE REASON REIMBURSEMENT
FROM THE DEPARTMENTS OR AND OR
THE AGENCIES AND OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE JUNIATA FROM.
WELL THE AUDITS ARE --
PRO RATED BASICALLY OUT TO
DIFFERENT STATE AGENCIES THERE'S
A PROCESS WE USE THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO WE HAVE
TO PRESENT THAT INFORMATION TO
FINANCE AS FAR AS HOW MUCH EACH
OF THE AUDITS HOW MUCH TIME YOU
TO THE OUT ITS.
TO HOW MUCH IT COST AND THEN
THAT SPREAD AMONG THE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS THAT WE OUGHT IT AND
WHAT ABOUT OF THE LOCAL MANDATE
RULE WITH RESPECT TO SOME OF
THESE AUDITS AND REQUIRING OTHER.
NON STATE JURISDICTIONS TO BE
ADDED --
THERE ARE SPECIFIC RULES RELATED
TO LOCAL.
I DON'T REMEMBER [inaudible]
THAT.
THE FORMER QUE.
PLEASE APPROACH MY LAST QUESTION.
IT IS OPTIONAL YEAH BOB PULLED
OFF CHEAP EVERY STEP DAUGHTER.
CENTER HERTZBERG THAT THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE TAKES ALL OF
OUR INFORMATION INCLUDING THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARTISTS THAT
WE DO AND TO THEIR PROCESS
THROUGH A PRO RATA PROCESS STATE.
THE BILL BACK TO YOU THE STATE
AGENCY OR THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCY.
THEY DO IT IS NOT A LOCAL
MANDATE IN TERMS OF THE STATE A
WRITTEN QUESTION AUDIT AND THEN.
THERE'S THE CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE
OF REIMBURSEMENTS AND OFFICER
ASKING LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD OR
SOMETHING TO TAKE MONEY OUT OF
THEIR BUDGETS THAT.
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO PAY FOR
THE ON AS FAR AS AS FAR AS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS NOT A LOCAL IT
IS NOT A REIMBURSABLE STATEMENT.
THANK YOU.
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE DíAS.
OKAY HEARING AND SEEING NONE WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER THREE THE OUT ITS FOR THE
J. LACK CONSIDERATION --
WE DISPENSE WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDARS ITEMS NUMBER ONE AND
TWO WE WILL MOVE TO THE REGULAR
CALENDAR AND WE WILL BEGIN WE
ARE AND SIGN IN ORDER SO WE WILL
BEGIN WITH --
AGENDA I'D TWO ZERO ONE NINE
DASH ONE ZERO FOUR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES SUPPORT OF HOMELESS
STUDENTS.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS CHIU --
MISTER RAMOS AND MISS REAVIS
THEY'VE ALSO ASKED THE COMMITTEE
TO DISPLAY.
A POSTER BOARD.
OF THE ISSUE THEY WILL PRESENT.
ON THIS MORNING.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
AND ALSO THE WORK OF THE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE ON THIS REQUEST
AND THIS IS MY FIRST ORDER
REQUEST MY FOUR PLUS YEARS.
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE.
THE CONTEXT OF THIS AUDIT
REQUEST.
IS RELATED TO THE FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA IS EXPERIENCING THE
MOST INTENSE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
INTERSTATES HISTORY AND THIS
PARTICULARLY IMPACTS STUDENTS.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT OVER A
QUARTER MILLION CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA ARE HOMELESS THIS IS
A STUDENT HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
DRIVEN BY A LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
SKYROCKETING INEQUALITY IN
EXTREMELY HIGH CHILD POVERTY
RATES.
THE CRUX OF THIS REQUEST IS
BASED ON TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
DATA COLLECTED BY LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES COMPILED BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
WHICH SAYS THAT OVER A QUARTER
OF ALL CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS ALMOST
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS AND FOUR HUNDRED
DISTRICTS HAVE REPORTED EXACTLY
ZERO HOMELESS STUDENTS.
THAT DOES NOT MAKE SENSE GIVEN
THE HOMELESSNESS WE ARE ALL SEEN
IN OUR COMMUNITIES WE THINK IT'S
HIGHLY UNLIKELY THAT THERE ARE
EXACTLY ZERO HOMELESS STUDENTS
AND A QUARTER OF K. THROUGH
TWELVE SCHOOLS IN OUR STATE.
THROUGH THIS AUDIT WE HOPE TO
UNDERSTAND WHY STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS IS GOING UNDER
REPORTED WHAT BARRIERS ARE
FACING SCHOOLS AND IDENTIFIED
THE STUDENTS AND WAS BACK WHAT
BEST PRACTICES EXIST. FOR
DISTRICTS IN PROVIDING THE
SUPPORT THE STUDENTS NAY.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS WELL AS
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE REQUIRED
UNDER FEDERAL STATE LAW TO
IDENTIFY THE STUDENTS AND
PROVIDE THEM SERVICES.
IF THEY'RE NOT BEING COUNTED
THEY'RE NOT GETTING THE CRITICAL
SERVICES THEY NEED FROM HEAD
START TO PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES SCHOOL
NUTRITION PROGRAMS ETCETERA.
THE STUDENTS IN YOUR BASS THE
DIFFERENCE AND THEY NEED
SERVICES TO SUCCEED.
THIS IS A PROBLEM THAT'S NOT
GOING TO GO AWAY SIMPLY BECAUSE
WE IGNORE IT.
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND I WANT TO THANK OUR CORE
QUAESTORS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
REAVIS AND ROSS FOR THEIR
PARTNERSHIP AND COMMITMENT TO
THIS ISSUE I'M GOING TO TURN
OVER TO MR THIS [inaudible]
ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR CONSIDERING THIS
PROPOSAL --
I WANNA THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU FOR LEADING THIS AUDIT
REQUEST AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS FOR HIS PASSION TO HELP
HOMELESS YOUTH --
AT MY OLD ELEMENTARY SCHOOL --
IN LOS ANGELES UNIFIED 24% OF
THE CHILDREN ARE CONSIDERED
HOMELESS.
UNFORTUNATELY AS YOU CAN SEE
FROM THIS MAP OF THIS IS A STATE
WIDE ISSUE FROM YOUR RICA TO
SALLY NICE TO SAN DIEGO YOU KNOW
WHERE THE RED SPOTS INDICATE --
THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF
CHILDREN THAT ARE ARE CLASSIFIED
AS HOMELESS AT OUR SCHOOLS --
I'VE EXPERIENCED THIS ISSUE
FIRST HAND AND HOW HOMELESSNESS
AFFECTS OUR CHILDREN.
I FOUNDED A NON PROFIT THAT
WORKS WITH YOUNG GIRLS TO GET
THEM INTERESTED IN STEM.
AT ONE OF THE SCHOOLS IN MY
DISTRICT STUDENTS WASN'T SHOWING
UP TO OUR PROGRAM AND I ASSUME
THAT IT WAS BECAUSE SHE WAS AN
INTEREST IN STEM ANYMORE.
BUT IN REALITY SHE WAS HOMELESS.
AND WASN'T THINKING ABOUT STEM
SHE WAS WORRIED ABOUT WHERE SHE
WAS GOING TO SLEEP THAT NIGHT
AND WHAT SHE WAS GOING TO EAT
BECAUSE SHE WAS SLEEPING IN THE
CAR WITH HER MOM.
THIS IS SADLY SOMETHING CHILDREN
IN MY DISTRICT FACE EVERY DAY
AND UNFORTUNATELY CHILDREN
STATEWIDE ARE ALSO FACING.
CALIFORNIA HAS OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOMELESS SCHOOL
CHILDREN YET OVER FOUR HUNDRED
DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE NOT
IDENTIFIED EVEN A SINGLE
HOMELESS STUDENTS WERE FAILING
THESE CHILDREN.
THE STATE NEEDS TO KNOW WHERE
OUR FAILURES ARE TAKING PLACE SO
THAT EVERY STUDENT HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUCCEED.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING THIS
REQUEST --
AND NEXT ALL HIGH HANDED OVER TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROMMEL'S.
DRAMAS PLEASE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS --
CHIU IN REVERSE FOR MOVING THIS
FORWARD AND SUPPORTING OUR
HOMELESS YOUTH IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AS MY COLLEAGUES STATED WE ARE
CONCERNED ON THE NUMBER OF
SCHOOLS WHICH REPORT LOW TO NO
HOMELESS STUDENTS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. FOR THE
FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
THIS AUDIT WILL EXAMINE A LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCY ANSWER MARINO
COUNTY. TO GAIN VALUABLE
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW OUR
SCHOOLS ARE PROVIDING AND
REFERRING SERVICES TO OUR
HOMELESS YOUTH.
WELL I SAT ON ASSEMBLY --
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WE
WORK TO IDENTIFY HOMELESS YOUTH
WITHIN THE COUNTY INFORMED A
HOMELESS YOUTH TASK FORCE WITH A
CO CHAIR BRENDA DOWDY FROM THE
COUNTY SCHOOLS.
IN THE AREA THAT'S THERE.
I THINK IT'S IMPERATIVE TO
REVIEW THE DATA AND PRACTICES
AND LEARN ON AREAS THAT CAN BE
IMPROVED.
AND WITH THIS AUDIT WE WILL
PROVIDE OUR LOCAL SCHOOLS THE
CRITICAL TOOLS THAT WILL LEAD TO
SOLUTIONS TO REDUCE THE RISK OF
HOMELESS YOUTH BECOMING HOMELESS
ADULTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY NEXT WILL MOVE TO THE STATE
AUDITOR PRESENTATION ON THIS I
REQUEST.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AS THE
MEMBERS INDICATED THIS IS AN
AUDIT AND HOMELESS HOMELESS
YOUTH AND SCHOOLS SO WE WOULD
START THE FIRST OBJECTIVES
THEY'VE ASKED US TO ACCOMPLISH
IS.
AT THE STATE LEVEL LOOKING AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
WHAT ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES
DO THEY HAVE IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING PART OF EDUCATION
HAS A LOT OF THE DATA SO WILL
SPEND.
SOME TIME WITH THEM CERTAINLY
TRYING TO CAPTURE THAT DATA AND
DOING ANALYSIS OF THE DATA ALSO
LOOKING TO SEE WHAT KIND OF
GUIDANCE DOES THE STATE LEVEL
PARTICULAR DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
BUT ALSO THE BOARD.
PROVIDE TO ELLIE ETS AND HELPING
THEM IDENTIFY HOMELESS YOUTH AND
CERTAINLY IDENTIFY SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THE TO THE KIDS IN
THEIR PARTICULAR DISTRICTS --
ALSO ASKING US TO LOOK AT HOW
COLLABORATION IS WORKING --
BETWEEN THE STATE LEVEL AND
LOCAL LEVEL CERTAINLY THE
ELEAZAR THE DISTRICT LEVEL AND
THE SCHOOLS --
THEY'VE ASKED US TO LOOK AT A
THREE YEAR WINDOW THREE FISCAL
YEARS TO TRY TO CAPTURE THE DATA
TO LOOK FOR TRENDS SO AGAIN I'M.
IT'S OUR BELIEF THAT THAT WILL
BE INFORMATION THAT WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AS I INDICATED MY
OPENING COMMENTS WE HAVE IT
AUDITOR'S WHO HELP US DO DATA
ANALYTICS.
SO WE WILL CERTAINLY DO --
WORK IN THAT PARTICULAR AREA AND
TRY TO CATEGORIZE --
THE HOMELESS YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA
AND RURAL ETCETERA THOSE ARE THE
TYPES OF THINGS THE MEMBERS HAVE
ASKED US TO LOOK AT THEN THEY
HAVE CPAS PACIFIED.
THEY WANT US TO LOOK AT LEAST
ONE CHARTER SCHOOL.
AND THREE TO FIVE DAILY ACE THE
BUDGET PROVIDED TO YOU TODAY IS
ON THE HIGH END SO WE WANTED TO
ESTIMATE IF WE GO TO A CHARTER
SCHOOL AND FIVE ELLIE ACE.
AND AS MISTER RAMOS INDICATED
THEY SPECIFIED AT LEAST ONE IN
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY ONE OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA AND ONE
ACTUALLY THAT IS DOING A GOOD
JOB OF IDENTIFYING HOMELESS
YOUTH AND PROVIDING SERVICES.
UP TO HOMELESS YOUTH SO THEY
HAVE HELPED US WITH SOME OF THE
SELECTION OF THOSE ELLIE ACE.
AT EACH OF THE ALLEY A THEY'VE
ASKED US TO LOOK AT WHAT METHODS
ARE THOSE EARLY AGE USING TO
IDENTIFY THE YOUTH WHAT TYPE OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ARE THEY
RECEIVING --
AND WORKING WITH HOME HOMELESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS --
ARE THERE SPECIFIC LIAISONS AT
THE DISTRICT LEVEL WHO ARE
ASSISTING THE SCHOOLS IN
IDENTIFYING THESE YOUTH.
AGAIN LOOKING AT COLLABORATION
IS THEY'RE SHARING OF DATA AMONG
SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
DO THE ELLIE ETS --
PURSUE ANY FEDERAL MONEY TO
ASSIST THEM IN IDENTIFYING THESE
YOUTH AND HOPEFULLY PROVIDING
SERVICES TO THE YOUTH SO A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
EACH OF THE ALLEY ACE.
AND THEN ANOTHER OBJECTIVE
SIMILAR TO THAT IS LOOKING FOR
BEST PRACTICES ARE THEIR TRENDS
OUT THERE ARE THEIR BEST
PRACTICES THAT WE'RE SEEING AT
SOME OF THE EARLY EIGHTIES --
THAT OTHER ELEAZAR OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD BENEFIT FROM SO
WE WILL GO THROUGH THOSE SAME.
QUESTIONS LOOKING AT MESSAGE
FRIDAY SOUNDS COLLABORATION AT
CETERA AS FAR AS IDENTIFYING
BEST PRACTICES AND THEN THE LAST
QUESTION THEY'VE ASKED US TO
ANSWER IS.
LOOK AT NATIONAL INFORMATION IS
THERE --
INFORMATION THAT OTHER STATES
ARE ARE PRACTICES THAT OTHER
STATES ARE USING THAT PERHAPS
CALIFORNIA WOULD BENEFIT FROM.
SO THE AUDITS THIRTY NINE
HUNDRED HOURS AS I SAID IT IS ON
THE HIGH END WE WE DECIDED TO
ESTIMATED BASED ON FIVE ELEAZAR.
THE CHARTER SCHOOL AND THEN THE
WORK WE WOULD HAVE TO DO AT THE
STATE LEVEL BOTH AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND AT
THE BOARD.
AN AUDIT OF THAT SIZE WILL TAKE
QUITE A BIT OF TIME BUT ONE THIS
IS AN AUDIT THAT --
IS CERTAINLY ARE A GOOD
CANDIDATE FOR A SIGNING A COUPLE
OF AUDIT TEAMS TO IT.
SO TO THE EXTENT I HAVE STAFF
ROLLING OFF I CAN ADD A TEAM TO
THIS AUDIT SO THAT INSTEAD OF
ONE TEAM GOING OUT TO SIX
LOCATION I'VE GOT TWO TEAMS.
AND AND THEY'RE OUT CONDUCTING
AUDIT WORK SIMULTANEOUSLY THAT
WILL ALLOW US TO GET THIS
PROJECT DONE MORE QUICKLY AND
GET THE INFORMATION TO THE
MEMBERS --
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE SO WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU I
THINK AT THIS TIME WE TYPICALLY
MOVE TO THE AFFECTED AGENCIES
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE TO QUESTIONS
AND ANSWERS FROM THE DíAS.
SO LET ME AT THIS TIME AND RIGHT
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
AFFECTED AGENCIES TO THE TO GIVE
TESTIMONY IF THEY SO.
THEY WISH TO DO SO [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY IF YOU COULD PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD
PRETTY GOOD GOOD MORNING --
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE AND
STAFF MY NAME IS KIND JACKSON
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT.
TONY THURMOND BOTTOM LINE UP
FRONT IS IF THIS AUDIT WERE TO
TAKE PLACE.
IT COULD POTENTIALLY EDUCATE AND
INFORM THE STATE IN REGARDS TO
EDUCATION HOMELESS CHILDREN AND
YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA.
THE STATE COULD GAIN A SHARED
UNDERSTANDING OF MOST OF THE
FEDERAL --
MCKINNEY VENTO THE MINUTE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIANS SERVERS
CLOSE TO THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
HOMELESS CHILDREN AND YOUTH THAT
OUR ROLE IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE UP FOR
YOU THE LANDS UPON WHICH I VIEW
THIS.
AS A FORMER HOMELESS STUDENT IN
JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL.
AS A SON OF A SINGLE CAFETERIA
WORKER WHO IN THE MID NINETEEN
EIGHTIES BECAUSE OF OUR HOMELESS
DISLOCATION REQUIRED ME TO TAKE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION IN SOUTH
CENTRAL LA JUST TO GET. TO
SCHOOL.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION BELIEVE THAT ELEAZAR
IDENTIFYING HOMELESS CHILDREN
AND YOUTH TO THE BEST OF THEIR
ABILITY WITH THE RESOURCES AND
CAPACITY THAT THEY HAVE.
ELLIE AGE RECEIVE SUPPORT AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION A
VARIETY OF WAYS.
THIS AUDIT WERE TO HAPPEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION BELIEVES
THAT THE OUTCOME COULD
DEMONSTRATE AN ISSUE OTHER THAN
IDENTIFICATION.
IT COULD ILLUMINATE BARRIERS
THAT ELLIE ETS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION FACES
AND ALL AREAS OF IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE MCKINNEY VENTO ACT --
ONE OF WHICH IS LIAISONS DO NOT
HAVE ADEQUATE CAPACITY AND SLACK.
BASED ON THE DATA THAT WAS
PROVIDED FROM DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION'S --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO EIGHTEEN
APPLICATION PROCESS. FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE ELEAZAR
REPORTED.
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT FTE EASE OF
LESS THAN POINT 5% WITH NINETY
THREE OF THEM REPORTING LEDS
INDICATING ZERO F. T. E. WHICH
IS ALMOST THE HOMELESS LIAISON.
THAT SAID WHILE I CANNOT SPEAK
TO ALL ELEAZAR HAVE REACHED OUT
TO DISTRICTS SO THAT I HAD A
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT'S GOING ON
AT THE GROUND LEVEL. FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN SAN DIEGO UNIFIED THEY HAVE
VERY STRONG WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR AGE
PARTNER AGENCIES AND THE COUNTY.
ARE THEY HAVE SCHOOLS I AND ONE
PARTICULAR CASE PERKINS
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL WITH THE
HOMELESS POPULATION OF OVER 30%.
THAT SAID.
VERY SHE WAS NOT IDENTIFICATION
BUT AS THE COMMITTEE TRIES TO
GET I SUSPECT THERE DISTRICTS
AROUND THE STATE THAT DO HAVE
IDENTIFICATION ISSUES.
SO I I WOULD SAY ARE UNDER THE
EVERY STUDENT SUCCEEDS ACT THE
HOMELESS PROGRAM WAS REQUIRED TO
DEVELOP ASSA HOMELESS EDUCATION
PLAN AND I WOULD NOTE THAT THERE
IS.
ONE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
CONSULTANT TO SERVICE FOURTEEN
HUNDRED HOMELESS LIAISONS AND
THE STATE AND SHE'S HERE WITH US
TODAY SHOULD YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT I APPRECIATE
YOU KEEPING YOUR COMMENTS UNDER
TWO MINUTES MOVE ALONG THROUGH
THE AGENDA.
AT THIS TIME --
I KNOW I HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU
BUT STATE AGENCIES THAT WOULD
LIKE -- TO
PROVIDE COMMENT AT THIS TIME ON
THIS ITEM.
OKAY HEARING AND SEEING NONE WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO QUESTIONS FROM
THE DíAS AND IF I COULD JUST
ASK ONE SINCE WE HAVE THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HERE --
YOU KNOW IN YOUR TESTIMONY HAD
STATED ZERO F. TEASE A WE HAVE
AN IDENTIFIED SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE NOT IDENTIFIED
ANY HOMELESS STUDENTS OR WITHIN
THE POINT 5% WHAT IS THE
DEPARTMENT DONE --
TO REACH OUT TO THOSE SCHOOLS TO
FIND OUT WHY THEY'RE NOT
REPORTING ANY OR DO THEY TRULY
NOT HAVE ANY HOMELESS STUDENTS.
I JUST WANNA UNDERSTAND A LITTLE
BIT WITH THE DEPARTMENT'S DONE
WHAT ACTIONS OF DEPARTMENT HAS
TAKEN THE SUPERINTENDENT IS
TAKEN TO HELP ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES.
IS A GOOD QUESTION ONE OF OUR
BEST PRACTICES IS WHEN WE
RECOGNIZE THAT SOME DISTRICTS
PROVIDE A REPORT ZERO HOMELESS
YOU STUDENTS ARE LIAISON DOES
PROACTIVELY REACH OUT. TO THAT
DISTRICT TO VALIDATE AND OR
VERIFY IF THAT IS TRULY THE CASE
TO INQUIRE ABOUT THEIR STANDARD
OPERATING PROCEDURES --
FOR FOREIGN ROMAN AND REPORTING
TRICKS.
AND HOW MANY DISTRICTS ARE NOT
REPORTING.
I HAVE OUR TECHNICAL EXPERT HERE
WITH ME WHO COULD --
A SUCCESS WITH WITH ONCE I HAVE
SOME DATA HERE MAYBE THIS CAN
HELP SAYS AS OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THIS WAS IN THE AUDIT LETTER
THAT.
WE WORKED WITH MR CHIU IN THE
AUTHORS ON OVER A QUARTER OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS ABOUT TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED OUT OF TEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED SCHOOLS
REPORTED THAT THEY HAD
IDENTIFIED NO HOMELESS STUDENTS
AT ALL.
SO MAYBE THAT.
THAT HELPS BUT THAT NUMBER HAVE
YOU REACHED OUT.
TO THOSE TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
SCHOOLS IS THAT WHAT.
YOUR TESTIMONY AS INDICATING.
THE CALIFORNIA PLEASE COME TO
THE MIKE.
I'M LIANE WHEELER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION I AM THE CONSULTANT
THAT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR HELPING
THE LIAISONS AND THEIR LIAISE TO
IMPLEMENT THIS LAW --
TYPICALLY IN THE PAST I BELIEVE
I DON'T WORK AT THE SCHOOL LEVEL
I WORK MORE AT THE L. THE A
LEVEL BECAUSE THERE'S ONE OF ME
AND FOURTEEN HUNDRED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
AND SO WHEN I I THINK THE LAST
DATA THAT WE RECEIVED WAS ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
ELEAZAR THAT REPORTS WERE.
WERE IMPORTING ZERO HOMELESS
STUDENTS.
AND TYPICALLY WHAT I HAVE SEEN
AS AS I REACH OUT TO THEM AND
GIVE THEM THEY PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT IN THE TECHNICAL
SENSE.
A LOT OF TIMES THEY REPORT BACK
AND SAY WELL WE ONLY HAVE THIRTY
STUDENTS ON OUR TOTAL POPULATION
WE HAVE A LOT OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE ONE SCHOOL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THAT REPORT THIS AND THEY KNOW
WHERE ALL THEIR HOMELESS STUDENT
STUDENTS ARE.
AND OR OR WHERE ALL THEIR
CHILDREN OR STUDENTS ARE PERIOD
AND SO THAT IS THE PRIMARY THING
THAT WE DO.
HAVE OUR OUR HOMELESS POPULATION.
SO THEY'RE IDENTIFIED IN THEIR
REACHED OUT.
TO EVERY DISTRICT WIDE --
DISTRICTS STATEWIDE SCHOOL.
OKAY FANTASTIC THANK YOU LET ME
I KNOW SENATOR MINING.
AS A QUESTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
LET ME START BY THANKING THE
REQUEST YEARS OF THIS ON IT --
IN MY AREA THE SALINAS SCHOOL
DISTRICT REPORTS OVER 30%
HOMELESS.
THE THRUST OF A LOT OF THIS ON
IT IS BETTER MONITORING BUT I
KNOW PART OF IT IS ALSO TO
IDENTIFY BEST PRACTICES --
EITHER THE AUDITOR OR OR
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
I THINK THE DEFINITION OF
HOMELESSNESS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T MEAN KIDS ARE
NECESSARILY LIVING ON THE STREET
IN SALINAS THEY MIGHT BE.
SHARING A GARAGE WITH MULTIPLE
FAMILIES WITHOUT.
FACILITIES WITHOUT BATHROOMS
ETCETERA.
COULD ONE OF YOU SHARE FOR THE
COMMITTEE WHAT WHAT CONSTITUTES
HOMELESSNESS FOR SCHOOL STUDENT.
YES SIR AND BROADLY BROADLY
SPEAKING CHILDREN AND YOUTH WHO
ARE SHARING HOUSING DUE TO A
LOSS OF HOUSING ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP OR SIMILAR REASON.
LIVING IN MOTELS HOTELS TRAILER
PARKS OR CRACK CAMPGROUNDS DUE
TO A LACK OF ALTERNATIVE
ACCOMMODATIONS LIVING IN
EMERGENCY OR TRANSITION SHELTERS
OR ABANDONED AND HOSPITALS.
CHILDREN AND YOUTH WHOSE PRIMARY
NIGHT TIME READ OR OR NEARLY
USED AS A REGULAR SLEEPING
ACCOMMODATION FOR YOU FOR HUMANS.
CHILDREN AND YOUTH LIVING IN
CARS PARKS PUBLIC SPACES
ABANDONED BUILDINGS SUB STANDARD
HOUSING BUS OR TRAIN STATIONS
ARE SIMILAR SETTINGS MIGRATORY
CHILDREN AND YOUTH LIVING IN ANY
OF THE ABOVE.
SITUATIONS THANK YOU AND I THINK
THAT'S HELPFUL TO SHOW.
THE SCOPE OF THIS --
WHEN WE HEAR 30% IN SALINAS THAT
JUST SOUNDS STAGGERING IN BUT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE FACTORS
THAT?
THE CONSTANT HOMELESSNESS AND
THEN A QUESTION I THINK FOR THE
FOR THE AUDITOR.
IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT BEST
PRACTICES IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S
A SOCIAL SERVICES SIDE TO THIS
OF HOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WORK WAS SOCIAL SERVICES TO TRY.
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THE FAMILY AND TO MOBILIZE
SUPPORT.
RIGHT AND THEN THERE'S A
CLASSROOM SIDE OF HOW THIS HOW
HOMELESS STUDENT PRESENTS.
LEARNING CHALLENGES TEACHING
CHALLENGES IN THE CLASSROOM
WE'LL YEAR ON IT LOOK AT THOSE
DIFFERENT ARENAS SOME MAYBE
SHARE A LITTLE BIT HOW.
HOW THE ON IT?
DETERMINES BEST PRACTICES TO BE
SHARED -- AS
PART OF THIS ON IT.
I THINK BEST PRACTICES WOULD BE
IN THE EVENT WE WE SEE --
SITUATIONS WHERE.
A STABLE ELEAZAR HAVE IDENTIFIED
HOMELESS YOUTH AND HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO PARTNER WITH PROVIDERS
IN THE COMMUNITY TO GET SERVICES
TO THOSE CHILDREN AND CERTAINLY
LOOKING AT ANY NATIONAL.
STUDIES THAT ARE OUT THERE
RELATED TO HOMELESSNESS --
WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE INFORMATION
IN TWO DIFFERENT OBJECTIVES
RELATED --
TO IDENTIFICATION OF HOMELESS
YOUTH BUT WORKING WITH PROVIDERS
AND THAT WOULD BE IN MY VIEW THE
SOCIAL SERVICES SIDE HOW ARE THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WORKING WITH IN
THE COMMUNITY.
WE CONDUCTED AN AUDIT LAST YEAR
LOOKED AT IT FROM THAT COMMUNITY
SIDE OF IDENTIFYING HOMELESS.
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA NOT JUST
USE UNACCOMPANIED YOUTH IN
PARTICULAR --
BUT THESE CONTINUUM OF CARE THAT
ARE OUT IN EACH OF THE
COMMUNITIES AND HOW THEY'RE
IDENTIFYING TYPES OF SERVICES TO
PROVIDE.
A HOME TO HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
SO THE OBJECTIVE WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO SPECIFIC ELLIE ACE
GOING TO A CHARTER SCHOOL WE
LOOK AT IT THERE AND THEN ALSO
IN THE OBJECTIVE --
THAT THE MEMBERS HAVE ASKED US
TO LOOK AT TRENDS AND OR BEST
PRACTICES WE WILL ALSO BE
LOOKING AT THE SOCIAL SERVICES
SIDE AND LIAISONS AND YOU KNOW
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS WORKING
WITH --
COMMUNITY NOW PROVIDERS THANK
YOU AND IF I MIGHT MISTER CHAIR
JUST KIND OF A FINAL COMMENT
[inaudible]
OR QUESTION.
MY GUESS IS THERE'S SOME OVERLAP
WITH TRUANCY FIGURES --
ARE FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL
KAMALA HARRIS --
WE HAD A NUMBER OF BILLS TRYING
TO DECRIMINALIZE TRUANCY AND
REALLY FOCUS ON FAMILY DYNAMICS
SCHOOL DYNAMICS AND SUPPORTING
STUDENTS WERE THERE WAS CHRONIC.
TRUANCY --
UNFORTUNATELY OUR FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL SPACE I THINK
SOME MISINFORMATION IN THE MEDIA
SUGGESTING THAT SHE SOUGHT TO
CRIMINALIZE TRUANCY WHEN IN FACT
IT WAS JUST THE OPPOSITE.
WE WORK TO TO UNDERSTAND BUT I
WOULD THINK THERE'S GONNA BE
SOME OVERLAP.
IN.
STUDENT HOMELESSNESS.
ENTRANCE HE TRANS AND IF THAT'S
AN APPROPRIATE --
TO ADD TO YEAR INDICATORS I
THINK THAT MIGHT BE HELPFUL.
ALSO FOR FOLLOW UP FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. TO UNDERSTAND THAT
BEHIND THAT STUDENT.
IF WE FIND HOMELESSNESS HAD WE
MOBILIZE SUPPORT RIGHT AT AND
THAT'S AN EXCELLENT POINT
SENATOR --
THAT CERTAINLY IS SOMETHING THAT
WILL WILL TALK TO THE DEPARTMENT
ABOUT AND AND ABSOLUTELY TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION BECAUSE I
THINK YOUR OBSERVATION IS.
A 100% CORRECT.
OR WE JUST FOLLOWED DOES THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAVE
THOSE NUMBERS FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE REPORT ZERO
HOMELESS STUDENTS BUT HIGH
TRUANCY RATES.
THAT'S SOMETHING YOU GUYS CAN
PROVIDER.
MAYBE HELP ASSIST THE AUDITOR
WITH.
OTHER AT LEAST GO I JUST MAKE
ONE MORE COMMENT TO DOVETAIL.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ALSO LOOK AT
DIFFERENT AND INNOVATIVE WAYS TO
TAP IN AND HELP THE STUDENTS FOR
EXAMPLE THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
HAD RECEIVED A FEDERAL GROUND
GRANT OUTSIDE OF THE MCKINNEY
VENTO GRANT.
OF EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS OF
WHICH A MINIMUM OF ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION IS TARGETED AT
EDUCATION AGENCIES. FOR HOMELESS
YOUTH AT RISK USE AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ENCOURAGE DISTRICTS
TO ARM.
IT YOU KNOW MAKE THESE
NONSTANDARD PARK PARTNERSHIPS.
WITH CITIES FOR EXAMPLE AND THEN
THE LAST COMMENT I I WOULD JUST
MAKE IS AS WE APPROACH THIS.
IT I BELIEVE IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
TO LOOK AT THE RESOURCES THAT
DISTRICTS AND THE DEPARTMENT
RECEIVED TO ACTUALLY CARRY OUT
THE WORK ONCE AGAIN WE HAVE --
ONE LIAISON TO SERVE --
FOURTEEN HUNDRED ELLIE ACE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU AND I BELIEVE --
CENTER WIENER HAS THREE I
REQUEST IS FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT AUTO REQUEST TO US IN
A A FULLY SUPPORT IT.
ON I I THINK.
THE NUMBERS THAT I'VE SEEN IN
MAY PERHAPS ARE IT'S AN
UNDERCOUNT BUT EVEN WITHOUT.
PROBABLE UNDER CAL I'VE SEEN
STATEWIDE.
WE HAVE 5% OF STUDENTS ABOUT
STATEWIDE THE NUMBERS THAT I'VE
SEEN ARE HOMELESS.
WHICH EVEN 5% IF IT EVEN IF IT'S
NOT HIGHER THAT'S IT'S
OUTRAGEOUS ARE PARTICULARLY
OUTRAGEOUS AND CENTER MINING'S
DISTRICT AND SALINAS AREA --
OUT BUT IT'S JUST IT'S SOME IT'S
A IT'S A MORAL FAILING --
BY OUR STATE.
BUT I THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
I HOPE THAT THIS IS HELPS LAY
GROUNDWORK FOR OTHER FORMS OF
CHANGE ONE MORE DATA POINT
IMPORTANT DATA POINT --
AND THERE'S TWO THINGS I WANT TO
POINT OUT THE FIRST IS THAT I
THINK THAT THERE IS A PERCEPTION
WITH THE HOMELESSNESS.
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
HOMELESSNESS IS A IT IS SIMPLY
ABOUT --
MENTAL ILLNESS AND ADDICTION AND
ALTHOUGH WE OF COURSE AND ARE
HOMELESS POPULATION OF SIX
SIGNIFICANT MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDICTION CHALLENGES ABSOLUTELY --
SO MANY HOME HUGE OF PORTION OF
OUR HOME SUBDIVISION ARE NOT.
MENTALLY ILL ARE NOT ADDICTED
THEY SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD HOUSING --
AND TO ME WHEN YOU HAVE.
THEY'RE THEY'RE LIVING IN A
SHELTER OR A CAR OR GOING FROM
THE CHARTER MOTEL AND THERE'S
SOME HELL ABLE TO HOLD IT
TOGETHER TO GET THEIR KID TO
SCHOOL IN THE MORNING TO GET TO
WORK TO DO WITH THE NEW THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY AMAZING TO ME IT
SHOWS HOW RESILIENT.
PEOPLE ARE UP WE HAVE TO DO MORE
TO HELP --
THESE FOLKS AND IT'S NOT IT WE
CAN'T JUST FOCUS ONLY ON MENTAL
HEALTH AND ADDICTION IS A POOR
AND THAT IS.
IT'S ABOUT HELPING THEM.
AND THAT GETS TO THE DEEPER
ISSUE OF WHY ARE WE DRIVING
FAMILIES IN THE HOMELESSNESS AND
LET'S BE CLEAR IT'S NOT TO IT
DOESN'T JUST RANDOMLY HAPPEN.
WE AS A STATE DUE TO POLICY
CHOICES AROUND HOUSING OR
DRIVING FAMILIES IN THE
HOMELESSNESS OR DRIVING FAMILIES
IN THE POVERTY OR DRIVING
CHILDREN IN THE HOME WITH US.
BECAUSE WE REFUSE TO CREATE AN
OF HOUSING IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA AT ALL INCOME LEVELS
AND WE HAVE ALLOWED COMMUNITIES
TO OPT OUT.
THE BUILDING HOUSING WE HAVE
ALLOWED COMMUNITIES --
TWO IS AFFECTIVELY PROHIBIT
APARTMENT BUILDINGS ARE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES --
AND DOT IS DRIVING PEOPLE IN THE
HOMELESSNESS AND SO WE NEED
FUNDAMENTAL REFORM --
INVESTMENTS AND SUPPORT FOR
THESE FAMILIES BUT IT IS A
BROADER POLICY QUESTIONS SO
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS TO US.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
WE KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK
AHEAD OF US TO FULFILL THE
HOUSING NEED WE'VE STARTED ON
THAT JOURNEY.
THE LAST FEW SESSIONS AND WILL
CONTINUE REDUCE YES THIS IS A
FAN HOWEVER PLEASE BOERNER
HORVATH WARNER.
WE'LL GET IT --
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BRING THIS
ISSUE IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND I THINK I'VE SPOKEN TO
SOME OF YOU.
AND MY DISTRICT WHILE IT'S THAT
COAST IS GENTLY --
AFFLUENT WE DO HAVE A POCKET OF
POVERTY INVESTOR THE MCKINNEY
VENTO NUMBERS ABOUT 10% OF THIS
TO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
CHILDREN.
ARE HOMELESS.
AND I AGREE WITH SENATOR WE KNOW
THAT THIS IS ABOUT.
IT'S A MORAL FAILURE ON US THAT
WE'RE NOT PROVIDING THE KIDS
WITH THE ADVANTAGE THAT I HAVE
GOING FOR IT.
I WOULD I WOULD ARGUE THAT IT'S
NOT ONLY HOUSING ITS HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE NEED TO BE
REALLY WORKING ON I WOULD --
ARE ALSO SUGGESTED THIS UNIFIED
IS A GREAT EXAMPLE THAT HAS A
VERY BROAD AND VERY DEEP
MEASUREMENT OF MCKINNEY VENTO
WHERE AS I THINK SOME OF THE
OTHER CITIES IN MY DISTRICT I
DON'T THINK HAVE AS BROAD AS IN
DEEP SO.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT I MAYBE ONE
WITH BEST PRACTICE THAT MIGHT BE
A SUGGESTION --
TO CONSIDER THAT --
ONE AND THE OTHER THING I WANT
TO ASK IS WE'VE PUT YOU KNOW I I
KNOW WHEN I WAS ON THE CITY
COUNCIL WE AT ACTIVE PROGRAMS TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS.
AND I KNOW EVERY CITY OF MY
DISTRICT DOES IN LAST YEAR'S
MONEY FOR HOMELESSNESS OF THE
COUNTIES SO HOW ARE THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CORNING WITH THE
COUNTIES. TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
MONEY THAT WAS ALLOCATED THE
COUNTIES ACTUALLY GET TO SERVE
THESE HOMELESS KIDS.
CAN YOU ASSIST WITH THAT.
GOING BACK TO THE DEFINITION
COUPLE THINGS I WANT TO GIVE YOU
A LITTLE BACKGROUND THERE'S A
DEFINITION DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
HOUSING UNDER HOOD.
AND EDUCATION SO A LOT OF OUR
FAMILIES THAT ARE --
POSSIBLY IDENTIFIED AS HOMELESS
IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT MIGHT NOT
ACTUALLY QUALIFY FOR HAD
SERVICES AND THERE'S A
DISCONNECT THERE BUT AGAIN GOING
BACK -- TO
MY COLLEAGUES DISCUSSION
LIAISONS DON'T NECESSARILY
ALWAYS HAVE THE CAPACITY. TO
MAKE THOSE COLLABORATION
COORDINATION THEY'RE WEARING TWO
THREE SOMETIMES FOUR FIVE HATS --
WITHIN THEIR SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
SO WE I LEAN ON THE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION --
LIAISONS TO TRY TO BRING THOSE
RESOURCES TO THEIR LIAISONS --
TO GET NO THE WHERE THOSE
HOUSING PROGRAMS ARE WHAT
SERVICES ARE THERE --
BUT IT IS A CAPACITY ISSUE.
AND I WOULD JUST HOPE THAT WHEN
WE DO THIS AUDIT WILL WE LOOK
SPECIFICALLY AT WHAT OPTIONS.
ARE WHEN WE LOOK AT THE BEST
PRACTICE OF SCHOOL TO DRESSING
CHILD HOMELESSNESS --
AND USE HOMELESSNESS THAT WE ARE
LOOKING TO HOW THEY DO CREATE
THOSE BEST PRACTICES IN
COORDINATION WITH THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES BECAUSE HOPEFULLY WE'RE
ALL WORKING ON OUT TOWARDS THE
SAME GOAL OF REDUCING CHILD.
AND YOUTH HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FOR MEMBERS ON THE DíAS HEARING
AND SEEING THAT AT THIS TIME
WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
WE COULD LIVE IT LIMIT PUBLIC
COMMENTS --
TO TWO MINUTES PER SPEAKER THAT
WOULD BE MUCH APPRECIATED.
AT THIS TIME WHEN WE ASK IF
THERE IS ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS AGENDA ITEM.
HEARING AND SEEING NINE HIGH
WILL TURN IT BACK TO MEMBERS ON
THE DíAS FOR A MOTION TO
APPROVE [inaudible]
SOME OF WITH TERMINATE SO MOVED
BUT OF A SUBURB OF EXCUSE ME.
I WAS CHAIRMAN I THOUGHT ONE
QUICK QUESTION FOR THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT OR THE OTHER WHEN WAS
THE LAST TIME THE THE LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL.
AGENCY OR THIS PROCESS HAS BEEN
HONORED BY --
BY THE STATE.
OKAY MAYBE IT'S A QUESTION FOR
THE AUDITOR.
AND HAVE BEEN THE AUDITOR FOR
NINETEEN YEARS THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME THAT AN AUDIT SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO HOMELESS YOUTH AND
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA HAS COME.
UP BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
WAS A SATISFACTORY HISTORY OKAY
AT THIS TIME THEN LET ME ASK YOU
SIR CLOSING COMMENTS FOR MANY OF
THE AUTHORS.
I WANT TO JUST APPRECIATE OF THE
GOOD CONVERSATION OF THE
COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK --
THE PART OF EDUCATION AND I KNOW
YOUR COMMITMENT AND HELPING US.
GET TO THE ANSWER HERE --
LET ME JUST ALSO ECHO SOMETHING
THAT WAS SAID BY SENATOR WIENER --
OFTENTIMES THE FACE OF ABOUT
STUDENTS AND WE THINK ABOUT
WHERE STUDENTS ARE HOMELESS --
OFTENTIMES THEY ARE HIDDEN --
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT CHILDREN WHO
WERE SLEEPING IN A TENT UNDER
FREEWAY OR IN A FIELD BUT IT'S
STUDENTS WHO ARE LIVING IN THERE.
IN A CAR ON A ON A COUCH WITH
THEIR FAMILY DOUBLE OR TRIPLE
DUB -- IN A
MOTEL A CAMPGROUND A HOTEL.
IN THAT CREATES UNIQUE
CHALLENGES --
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS TRYING TO
IDENTIFY THIS --
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION I KNOW
WAS ALLUDED TO THAT MANY OF THE
SCHOOLS LISTED ARE SMALL SCHOOLS
THAT IS TRUE.
BUT I ALSO HAVE A LIST OF
HUNDREDS OF THE SCHOOLS THAT ARE
VERY LARGE SCHOOLS --
FACT OF GOD PAGES OF SCHOOLS
THAT ARE BETWEEN EIGHT HUNDRED
STUDENTS AND OVER FOUR THOUSAND
STUDENTS AND IN MANY THE SCHOOLS
THEY HAVE HUNDREDS IF NOT OVER A
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR FREE AND
REDUCED MEAL PROGRAMS AND YET
THEY'RE REPORTING EXACTLY ZERO
HOMELESS STUDENTS AND SO THAT'S
REALLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING --
TO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS
HERE AGAIN APPRECIATE --
ALL THE WORK THAT I ONCE YOU'RE
ON THIS AND IF ANYTHING THE ONE
AND THANK YOU HEARING THIS
REQUEST -- A
LOT OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP I THINK HAVE TO DO
WITH THE CAPACITY THAT OUR
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
ON LIKE WE ONLY HAVE ONE
HOMELESS COORDINATOR FOR THE
WHOLE STATE AND AS YOU CAN SEE
ON THIS IS --
THE STATE WIDE ISSUE THE THAT
NEEDS MORE RESOURCES AND I HOPE
THAT.
ON THROUGH THIS AUDIT AND OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT WE START --
WE CAN BEGIN TO ADDRESS THIS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN IN
CLOSING THANK YOU FOR THE THE
DIALOGUE THAT HAS GONE AROUND
I'M HERE TODAY AT AROUND THIS
DíAS --
DEALING WITH THE HOMELESS YOUTH
IN THE HOMELESS YOUTH POPULATION
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ALL
THE DIFFERENT FACTORS THAT ARE
THERE 30% IN SALINAS.
SAN MARINO COUNTY WE HAVE OVER
THIRTY THOUSAND HOMELESS
STUDENTS --
IN SAN BENITO COUNTY ITSELF SO
WE SEE IT AS AN AREA THAT
CONTINUES TO START TO NEED
DIALOGUE IN MOVING THIS ISSUE
FORWARD THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST
STEP IN IDENTIFYING.
RESOURCES THAT ARE OUT THERE ARE
BARRIERS THAT MIGHT NEED TO BE --
TALKED ABOUT SO THAT WE CAN IN
IDENTIFYING HELPING ARE HOMELESS
YOUTH SO THAT THEY DON'T END UP
BECOMING A DAHLE HOMELESS --
IN OUR COMMUNITIES I THINK THIS
IS A PROACTIVE WAY TO LOOK AT
THAT WE CONTINUE TO OPEN UP THE
DIALOGUE AROUND THE HOMELESS
YOUTH AND WITH THIS --
THE OTHER ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HERE
SOME WOMEN CHAO AND AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REVA SO WE CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT THE HOMELESSNESS IN
GENERAL BUT I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN THIS ITEM.
RIGHT THANK YOU APPRECIATE THOSE
COMMENTS APPRECIATE --
THE AUTHORS WORKING WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF IN CRAFTING --
THE LETTER IN THE SCOPE SO WE
CAN NOW MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
IDENTIFYING THE STUDENTS AND
GETTING THEM THE RESOURCES AND
THE HELPFUL FULLY --
THEY NEED THE WHICH WILL BE A
IDENTIFIED IN THE AUDIT WITH
THAT LET ME ASK FOR A MOTION --
ONCE MORE AS SO MOVED BY THIS
RUBIO.
AND SECULAR BY MISS FOR HIGH.
BURNER FOR BATH ALL RIGHT I WILL
GET IT RIGHT SO USED TO CALL YOU
BY YOUR FIRST NAME.
YOU'RE WELCOME TO SAY SOMETHING
MEMBER TASHA SEN THERE YOU GO.
ALL RIGHT SO WITH THAT THAT'S
THE FIRST OF THE SECOND
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO APPROVE AUDIT
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
DASH.
ONE OH FOUR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES SUPPORT OF HOMELESS
STUDENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS HI.
SALAS HI BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I DEEP.
I I PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WOULD.
SENATOR ROTH HI.
ROTH I'D BORDERS. FOR JUST I'D
DORADO.
DORADO AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE MINING.
MONNING AYE MOORLACH.
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
OKAY THAT MOTION CARRIES WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THAT ON THANK
YOU THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
AT THIS TIME WE WILL MOVE TO
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER. THREE TWO
ZERO ONE NINE DASH IS ONE ZERO
ONE SCHOOL DISTRICTS LOCAL
CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
AND QUIRK SILVA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHATEVER WHEN YOU ARE READY TO
BEGIN.
THANK YOU --
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE --
SOME OF YOU MAY REALIZE THAT SIX
YEARS AGO --
THE STATE DRASTICALLY CHANGED
ITS METHOD FOR FUNDING OF
SCHOOLS --
IN THE K. TWELVE EDUCATION
SYSTEM REPLACING OF THE A
COMPLEX FUNDING METHOD THAT USE
A LOT OF CATEGORICAL.
OF THAT IT HAD IN PLACE FOR
FORTY YEARS WITH WHAT WE CALL
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA ALSO KNOWN AS EL CFF.
SB FF REQUIRES VARIOUS METHODS
AND ACTIONS BY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
INCLUDING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLANS.
WITHIN A DISTRICT EL CAP IS
REQUIRED TO ADDRESS EIGHT
DIFFERENT POP PRIORITIES
INCLUDING STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT
AND PUPIL ENGAGEMENT.
A DISTRICT IS ALSO REQUIRED TO
DESCRIBE ITS NEEDS SET GOALS AND
PERFORM AND ALICE'S. TO DATE NO
DETAIL REVIEW HAS TAKEN PLACE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER FUNDS UNDER LC
FF TOTALING MORE THAN FIFTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS.
BUT THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
SCHOOL YEAR BEEN SPENT
APPROPRIATELY --
AND I NEED TO EMPHASIZE THE FACT
THAT WHEN THIS BILL WAS
ORIGINALLY PASSED OUR THIS
PROCESS WAS WE WE SHOULD THERE
WOULD BE SOME --
ONGOING ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY WITH REGARDS TO THE
MONEY THAT WAS THE YEAR --
WE HAVE TRIED EACH YEAR TO
ACQUIRE THAT INFORMATION AND
HAVE YET TO HAVE FAILED TO DO SO
SOME OF YOU HAVE BEEN HERE FOR
ANY TIME KNOW THAT WE HAVE --
PUT TWO OR THREE PIECES OF
LEGISLATION ON THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK OFTEN WITH EIGHTY MEMBERS
IN THE ASSEMBLY FORTY IN THE
SENATE ASKING FOR THIS AND AND
BEING VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR WHO
FELT IT WAS TOO EARLY. TO
ACTUALLY BEGIN TO EXAMINE WHAT
WE HAD DONE.
IT IS MY HOPE THAT THE STATE
OUGHT TO FIND TO THEY'LL SEE IF
THE FUNDS ARE BEING ALLOCATED
PROPERLY TO HELP STUDENTS
ACHIEVE ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
HOWEVER TEST SCORES AND NOT
IMPROVING FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS AND OTHERS WERE
ROUTINELY DIGNIFIED AS THE
LOWEST PERFORMING STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA K. TWELVE SYSTEM.
I BELIEVE IT IS TIME TO CONDUCT
A REVIEW OF BILL C. F. F. TO
DETERMINE WHETHER DISTRICT
EXPENDITURES ON LCF HAVE BEEN
APPROPRIATE AND OF LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLANTS ARE
MEETING THE GOALS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE IMPROVED EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES. FOR STUDENTS WERE
CHRONICALLY LOW ACHIEVEMENT.
AT THE BUDGET LEVEL WE ARE A
COSTLY AND BEING PREPARED --
TO TO ADD MORE MONEY TO ELSE IF
IF IT IS NOW CURRENTLY FULLY
FUNDED.
AND OUR GOAL IS TO CONTINUE TO
TRY TO DO SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WITH IT THE QUESTION
BECOMES IS THIS THE MOST
APPROPRIATE METHOD TO DO THE
KIND OF FUNDING THAT WE WANT TO
SEE WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES TO ELSE EFF OVER THE
LAST FIVE OR SIX YEARS.
AND IS NOW HERE WE THAT DOWN
THERE WAS A POCKET A SIGNIFICANT
POCKET OF STUDENTS WHO ARE BEING
AND WOULD BE UNSERVED AND LCF IN
SOME OF YOU MAY REMEMBER THAT IN
AS A RESULT A TO READ AND IT
RESULTED IN THREE HUNDRED
MILLION ADDITIONAL DOLLARS GOING
TO THOSE.
SPECIFIC STUDENTS WE MADE SOME
ASSUMPTIONS WHEN WE STARTED THIS
LC FF AND I WAS INTRICATELY
INVOLVED IN IT --
THAT THERE WERE CERTAIN THINGS
THAT THAT COSTS CHILDREN TO NOT
TO DO WELL AND WE HAVE DONE A
FIVE THOSE ISSUES ONLY TO
DISCOVER THAT MAYBE THOSE WERE
NOT THE REAL ISSUES THAT
AFFECTED THE ACHIEVEMENT OF
STUDENTS.
WE ALSO MADE SOME ASSUMPTIONS
THAT WE WOULD NOT USE MONEY FOR
CERTAIN PURPOSES LIKE SALARY
INCREASES WE KNOW THAT THAT WAS
CHANGED --
NOT BY THE LEGISLATURE BUT BY
THE SUPERINTENDENT AT THAT TIME
THAT THOSE MONIES CAN GO THERE
THERE'S ALSO SUPPOSED TO BE SOME
TRANSPARENCY THAT THE PARENTS
UNDERSTAND THE PLANS THAT HAVE
BEEN PUT IN PLACE TO ADDRESS THE
PERFORMANCE OF THESE CATEGORICAL
STUDENTS THAT ARE.
EITHER LOW INCOME STUDENTS WHO
HAVE LANGUAGE ISSUES ARE STE ALL
WHO ARE FOSTER CARE THOSE ARE
THE CATEGORIES WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED IN TO SEE IF THAT
MONEY IS ACTUALLY GOING IN THAT
DIRECTION.
SO WE'RE REQUESTING AN AUDIT FOR
AT LEAST THREE LARGE
GEOGRAPHICALLY DIVERSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT CONTAIN A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF STUDENTS
WHO ARE CONSIDERED LOW INCOME
ENGLISH LEARNERS ACOSTA STUDENTS.
THE STATE AUDITOR'S TO USE HER
DISCRETION AND SELECT THE THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND PERFORM THE
FOLLOWING WE HOLD.
A DIGNIFIED EXCESS EACH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS GOLD CONTAINED WITHIN
THE EL CAP AND ELSEWHERE THAT
AIM TO RAISING STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT ESPECIALLY GOES INTO
THE TO BENEFIT LOW INCOME
ENGLISH LEARNERS AND FOSTER KIDS.
DETERMINE WHETHER DISH NO GOALS
COULD BE HELPFUL TO EACH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN ASSURING THE SUCCESS
OF THE STUDENTS.
WATER DIGNIFIED EVALUATE ANY
MEASUREMENT IN MEASUREMENT TOOLS
USED BY THE SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
ASSESS SUCCESS IN EDUCATING
STUDENTS INCLUDING STUDENTS ARE
CATEGORIZE IT IN THOSE
CATEGORIES.
DETERMINE EXTENT TO WHICH THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SPENDS FUNDS
TOTAL FUND AND SPENT ON WIDE AS
WELL AS A SCHOOL WIDE BASIS.
AGAIN A FIVE EXPENDITURES AT
SCHOOLS BY CATEGORIES AND
DETERMINE WHETHER THE
EXPENDITURES ARE BEING SPENT
APPROPRIATELY.
FURTHER TO IDENTIFY THE FUNDING
TO RECEIVE AN EXPANDED ON EACH
SCHOOL BY CATEGORIES INCLUDING
FUNDING CATEGORIES IDENTIFIED
AND YOU'LL SEE A FAIR. TO EXTENT
PRACTICAL REVIEW MULTIPLE SCHOOL
YEARS AND HELP PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE MEANINGFUL
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT FUNDING AND
EXPENDITURES OF CHAINS AND ELSIE
FF.
IDENTIFYING CAM AND EVALUATED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS METHODOLOGY FOR
DISTRIBUTING AND SPENDING FUNDS
ON ITS STUDENTS OR IS VERY
SCHOOLS.
AND REVIEW AND ASSESS WHETHER
EACH SCHOOL DISTRICT THE MOST
RECENT L. CUP COMPLIES WITH THE
SPIRIT AND LEGAL REQUIREMENTS
ASSOCIATED WITH AL CATS.
ESPECIALLY REQUIREMENTS
ASSOCIATED WITH ACHIEVING
MEASUREMENTS AND HELPING
STUDENTS WHO ARE MEMBERS OF
GROUPS ASSOCIATED WITH
CHRONICALLY LOW ACHIEVEMENT --
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT MAKE ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING THE EL
CAP THAT MAY HELP IMPROVE THESE
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENTS.
MOST OF YOU HAVE SEEN.
THE THE CHANGES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED OVER THE LAST SIX YEARS
IN TERMS OF FUNDING THE VARIOUS
WAYS OF METHODS OF PRESENTING
INFORMATION AND SUPPOSEDLY
SHARING WITH PARENTS AND TERMS
OF WITH.
SOME SENSE OF TRANSPARENCY WE
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TO TALK ABOUT CONTINUING
FUNDING THAT WE SHOULD MAKE SURE
THAT THIS IS THE MET THAT THAT'S
MOST APPROPRIATE. TO GET TO THE
GOALS WE SET FUNDING OUR SCHOOLS
MAKING SURE THAT WE CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP WAS ONE OF THE
MAJOR GOALS OF THE LCS.
LC FF AND ON THE GOVERNOR BROWN
SO AS A RESULT OF THAT WE'RE
REQUESTING AN AUDIT --
AS WE CAN.
BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
ADDITIONAL FUNDING OF THIS --
INCREASING LC FF.
THANK YOU MISS WEBER APPRECIATE
THAT I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WORKING
ON THIS --
ITEM FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS AND I
MY UNDERSTAND YOUR PASSION I
APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS BEFORE
US -- LET'S
HAVE A PRESENTATION BY THE STATE
AUDITOR ON THIS REQUEST.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I
WILL MAKE THIS BRIEF IS DOCTOR
WEBER DID AN EXCELLENT JOB OF
LAYING OUT WHAT SHE'S ASKED US
TO DO AND WE HAVE ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION IN THE ANALYSIS SO
WE WILL DEFINITELY LOOK AT THREE
LARGE.
GEOGRAPHICALLY DISPERSED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS --
AS SHE INDICATED SHE WANTS TO IF
I DISTRICTS THAT HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF STUDENTS
WHO ARE CONSIDERED LOW INCOME
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
FOSTER YOUTH.
AND AND LOOKING AT THE LCF THE
FORMULA AND AS AS SHE INDICATED
THE EACH SCHOOL DISTRICT
EVALUATING THEIR METHODOLOGY FOR
DISTRIBUTING AND SPENDING THOSE
FUNDS DISTRICT WIDE AND AT THE
VERY SCHOOLS WITHIN THAT
PARTICULAR DISTRICT.
SHE IS ALSO INTERESTED IN US
LOOKING AT A THREE YEAR WINDOW
SO WE WILL LOOK AT THREE FISCAL
YEARS.
AND AND LOOK AT THE EXPENDITURES
AND THE FUNDING PROVIDED OVER
THOSE THREE YEARS HOW HAS THAT
FUNDING CHANGED HAS IT CHANGED
AS FAR AS THE VARIOUS CATEGORIES
THAT ARE BEING FUNDED ETCETERA.
AND THEN.
DETERMINE. FOR EACH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN A SELECTION OF
SCHOOLS WITHIN THOSE DISTRICTS --
ARE THEY EXPENDITURES
APPROPRIATE AND AGAIN IN WHICH
CATEGORIES ARE THOSE
EXPENDITURES BEING INCURRED AND
IS THAT THE APPROPRIATE BEST USE
OF THOSE FUNDS.
AS SHE ALSO INDICATED WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT THE ACCOUNTABILITY
PLANS A LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS LOOKING AT
THE GOALS AT EACH OF THE ELLIE
AIDS HAS ESTABLISHED --
AND DO THOSE GOALS TIED TO
RAISING STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT
AGAIN PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT
TO STUDENTS.
WHO ARE LOW INCOME --
AGAIN.
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
FOSTER YOUTH --
ALSO ASKING US TO LOOK AT THOSE
TO EDUCATED COMPLIANCE WITH
REQUIREMENTS BUT ALSO THE SPIRIT
AND INTENT OF L. C. F. F. --
IN IN ASSISTING CHRONICALLY LOW
ACHIEVING STUDENTS.
IMPROVE THEIR THEIR ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT AND THEN AS SHE ALSO
TALKED ABOUT LOOKING AT
MEASUREMENTS --
ARE THERE ANY PARTICULAR
MEASUREMENTS OF SUCCESS THAT.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE USING OUT
WHAT TOOLS DO THEY USE AT EACH
SCHOOL TO IDENTIFY AND ASSESS
THE SUCCESS OF STUDENTS ARE
THERE ADDITIONAL TOOLS THAT.
BOTH THE SCHOOLS AND THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN USE OCT TO AGAIN
TRY TO ADDRESS --
LOW ACHIEVING STUDENTS AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE L. C. F. F.
MONEY IS BEING USED FOR THE
HIGHEST AND BEST USE IN THOSE
PARTICULAR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THE BUDGET IS ABOUT THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED HOURS THE REASON FOR
THAT IS AGAIN WE'RE GONNA BE
GOING TO THREE DIFFERENT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THEN ULTIMATELY IN
SOME LOCATIONS DRILLING DOWN.
TO INDIVIDUAL SCHOOLS AND HOW
THEY ARE USING LC FF MONEY.
WITH THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN I'LL
DO MY BEST TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION OF THIS TIME LET ME
ASK IF THERE ARE ANY AFFECTED
AGENCIES I WOULD LIKE.
TO GIVE COMMENT AND WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT IF YOU KEEP THIS
COMES TO TWO MINUTES.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE WE WILL
RETURN BACK TO MEMBERS ON THE
DíAS FOR QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS --
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO PLEASE
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU DOCTOR
WHATEVER --
FOR BRINGS UP I WAS A SCHOOL
TEACHER AND ONE OF THE
FRUSTRATIONS --
THAT I HAD I WAS A REDWOOD
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL CASEY OF
UNFUNDED DISTRICT TO GO ON IT
YET -- BY --
BUT WITH THAT MY SCHOOL IN
PARTICULAR WAS A 100% --
OF REDUCED --
LUNCH AND MY FRUSTRATION WAS
THAT THE THE KIDS IN MY SCHOOL
WERE THE ONES THAT QUALIFIED FOR
THE ADDITIONAL FINES.
AND WHEN WE KEPT ASKING WHERE
THE MONEY WAS COMING OF WHERE
THE MONEY WAS GOING THEY SAID
ALL WE HAVE TO BE --
EQUITABLE AND GAVE AROUND THE
WHOLE SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH WAS.
ALWAYS MY AT MY FIGHT IF THE
KIDS IN MY SCHOOL WERE THE ONES
A QUALIFIED FOR FOR THE EXTRA
FUNDING THAN THE KIDS IN THAT
SCHOOL SHOULD HAVE RECEIVED THE
MONEY.
AND SO --
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR FOR THE FOR
BRINGING THIS WAR AND THE OTHER
THING THAT I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
IS WHEN THE FILE THESE OUT OF
THE L. CAPS THEY AND THE PLANS
THAT THEY HAVE WHERE DO THEY GO
IT FEELS LIKE TO GO TO SOME
BLACK HOLE SOMEWHERE.
AND DO THEY GET AN APPROVAL DO
THEY GET --
I DON'T SOME KIND OF A
ACCOUNTABILITY OR YES R NO LIKE
OUR BUDGETS TO THE BUDGETS GO TO
THE TO THE TO THOSE THE COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND THEY
GET A EITHER A THUMBS UP OR
THUMBS DOWN.
DO IS THAT TRUE FOR THE EL CAP
AS WELL AND SO THAT'S ANOTHER --
IF YOU COULD PROVIDE AGAIN
DOCTOR WEBER THIS IS --
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN --
EATING AT ME FOR A LONG TIME AS
WELL AND I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
BRING THIS PART BECAUSE I THINK
A LOT OF OUR KIDS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE --
THESE CHALLENGES ARE NOT BEING
SERVICE AND I THINK WITH THIS WE
WILL MAKE SURE THAT DISTRICTS
ARE BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE MONEY THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
FOR THEM.
THANK YOU.
HI THANK YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS
WILL MOVE TO SENATOR ROTH AND
SENATOR DRAWS OF INSIDER MINING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR DR RONA
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
MATTER FORWARD I'VE BEEN.
INTERESTED IF NOT CONCERN FOR
SOME TIME ABOUT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE EL CAP
PROCESS AND THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE CONCENTRATION GRANT WITH ITS
FIFTY OVER 55% REQUIREMENT.
IN TERMS OF GETTING THE MONEY
DOWN WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE IN
ORDER TO TAKE CARE OF THE IN
PARTICULAR THE DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS IN OUR IN OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEM AS YOU WELL KNOW MUCH.
MORE THAN I YOU CAN HAVE TO
DISTRICTS --
IN A LINE DOWN THE MIDDLE.
AND ONE DISTRICTS CAN HAVE MORE
THAN THE 55% DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS THE OTHER DISTRICT HAS
LESS THAN 55% OF THE
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS --
REQUIREMENT.
YOU CAN HAVE SCHOOLS ON EITHER
SIDE OF THE LINE WITH THE SAME
PERCENTAGE OF ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH.
FOSTER KIDS AND ONE SCHOOL 50%
INCREASE IN THE CONCENTRATION
GRANT AND THE SCHOOL ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE LINE DOES NOT
GET THE 50% CONCENTRATION GRANT.
YET THEY'RE EDUCATING THE SAME
STUDENT POPULATION THE SAME
PERCENTAGE OF DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS.
AND THAT DOESN'T SEEM RIGHT TO
ME SO.
MADAM AUDITOR I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE RESULTS OF YOUR AUDIT AND
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR CONCLUSIONS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU LET'S MOVE THIS CENTER
DRAWS A THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
FOR MAKING THIS PROPOSAL OUT TO
COVER THE SCHOOLS ON THIS ISSUE --
ONE QUESTION IS.
UP.
THE THE CRITERIA FOR YOUR
SELECTION OF WHICH SCHOOLS.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT COULD FIT
PROBABLY.
I DON'T KNOW HUNDRED HUNT
HUNDREDS.
ALL OF THEM I MEAN MOST OF THEM
SO I GUESS I JUST WANT TO GET A
BETTER SENSE OF WHAT WOULD GO
INTO THE PROCESS THAT'S THAT'S
ONE AND IF IN THE PROCESS.
THERE WAS A WAY OF FIGURING OUT
THERE MAY BE SCHOOLS FOR PARENTS
OR COMMUNITY WERE DEEPLY
INVOLVED.
IN THE PROCESS OF EL CAP TO TRY
TO MAKE IT WORK AS MUCH AS A
POSSIBLE --
A WORK FOR THE RIGHT WAYS AND
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT MAYBE
SOMETIMES IT'S HARD TO LIST HERE
LIKE PARENT AND COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT IN THE PROCESS.
BUT HOW COULD WE GET TO THAT AS
WELL BIG.
A I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT ARE THE
MODELS FOR IT TO WORK GOOD AND
WHERE THE BAD MODELS OF NOT TO
FOLLOW AND THAT'S NOT ALWAYS
EXACTLY.
YOU KNOW BY NUMBERS THAT WE CAN
FIGURE THAT OUT THANK YOU THE OF
THE LAW THAT TALKS ABOUT L. C.
F. F. AS WELL AS EVEN THE L.
CAPS TALK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF PARENT ENGAGEMENT PARENT
INVOLVEMENT.
AND THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
THESE PLANS IS SUPPOSED TO BE
PRESENTED TO PARENTS.
AND APPROVED BY APPEARANCE AND
MOST DISTRICTS IF YOU GO TO BAY
PARENTS HAVE NO IDEA WHAT'S
GOING ON WELL EITHER WAY IT'S
FOR PRINT PRESENTED TO THEM IT'S
ALL DONE IN ITS HANDED FOR THEM
TO SAY OKAY --
AND MOST OF THEM THEY CAN'T
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE HECK IS
GOING ON AND IF YOU READ THE L.
CAPS AND OTHER THINGS THAT ON
THE INTERNET THAT IS SUPPOSED TO
BE DESIGNED FOR PARENTS ARE BUT
REALLY DESIGNED FOR IT.
I DON'T KNOW RESEARCHERS MAYBE
BECAUSE MOST PARENTS AND MOST OF
US CAN'T READ THEM CORRECTLY.
AND SO IT'S A IT'S A IT'S ONE OF
THOSE THINGS WHAT'S PARENTS AS
OPPOSED BE INVOLVED SO AS THEY
LOOK AT THE LAN SAY WHAT OKAY
WHAT WOULD THIS THING SUPPOSED
TO DO ONE OF THE PIECES WAS
PLANNING GAVE ME.
IT IS A LAYS SO WHAT YOU'LL
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO SEE IN THE
REPORT WHO WHO PUT THEIR PLANS
TOGETHER WHO USE PARENT
INVOLVEMENT.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT ENGAGE WITH
THAT SHOULD BE THERE AS A PART
OF IT AS SOMETIMES BEEN LOST.
AND OR EITHER DIMINISHED IN
TERMS OF PAN ROLE IN IT --
AND DOES SO AS A RESULT I'VE OF
PARENT ENGAGEMENT PARENT
INVOLVEMENT HOW THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE PLAN WAS AND I SAY WELL
YOU DISTRICT AS OPPOSED TO DO
THIS AND THEY SAID WELL THEY
DIDN'T ALL THEY CAME IN A
MEETING.
SLAP IT ON THE TABLE TOTAL THIS
IS WHAT IT WAS AND THEN IT WENT
ON TO SOMETHING ELSE AND SO SO
THAT'S SUPPOSED TO BE THERE AND
IF WE'RE LOOKING AT THE LAWN
WHAT THE LAW REQUIRES IT
REQUIRES A LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT.
SO WITH THAT WORK.
WOULD THAT BE PART OF THE
SELECTION PROCESS OR HOW HOW
COULD THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
AND AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE LEFT IT
UP TO OUR OUR AUDITOR TO PICK
THAT SCHOOLS WE HOPE THAT THERE
ARE LARGE ENOUGH SCHOOLS WHERE
THEY HAVE THE KIND OF DIVERSITY
OF PROGRAMS.
AND RESOURCES THAT ARE THERE BOB
AND WHICH WANTED SOMEONE DOING
BETTER THAN OTHERS --
SOME SCHOOLS ARE DOING BETTER
THAN OTHERS WITHIN A DISTRICT
ITSELF SO WE KIND OF LEFT IT TO
THE AUDITOR'S WE WOULDN'T.
WE WOULDN'T HAVE JUST A A KIND
OF A SPECIALTY SCHOOL WHERE IT
ONLY HAVE CERTAIN THINGS THAT
HAPPEN BUT BROUGHT ENOUGH IN
TERMS OF PROGRAMS AND STUDENTS
AND THE POPULATIONS IS THERE TO
MAKE A DISTINCTION.
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES WHAT WE
DISCOVER IF YOU'VE GOT A
DISTRICT WHERE.
THE WHOLE DISTRICT AND SO I
THINK THAT MAYBE ONE OF SAN
DIEGO WHERE EVERYBODY'S FREE AND
REDUCED LUNCH WITH THE MONEY
COMES IN AND MAKE IT COULD BE
DISPERSED ALL THE KIDS. TO PRINT
AND THEN YOU CAN LOOK AT THE
PROGRAMS BUT OFTENTIMES THE
CHALLENGE BECOMES IN THE LARGE
DISTRICT WHERE YOU HAVE THE
SOMETIMES A DIVISION BASED ON
ECONOMICS.
AND SO THE MONEY COMES IN ESOS
THE DISTRICT REALLY TAKEN THAT
EXTRA MONEY AND PUTTING IT INTO
THOSE SCHOOLS THAT REALLY NEEDED
ARE THEY ARE THEY DISTRIBUTING
IT A WIDELY AND BROADLY TO
EVERYBODY.
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT --
WHEN AND I GUESS MOST OF YOU
KNOW I WAS I WAS SO INVOLVED IN
THIS BECAUSE WHEN THE WHEN I
BECAME A MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY
THE GOVERNOR ASKED ME TO HELP
HIM GET THIS THROUGH?
AND THERE WERE TWO OF US WHO
REALLY WORKED HARD --
ONE DEMOCRAT MYSELF IN THE
REPUBLICAN.
AND PART OF THAT WAS THAT THEY
WOULD BE ACCOUNTABILITY.
THERE WOULD BE TRANSPARENCY I
SAID YOU CAN GIVE PEOPLE MONEY
AND THEN I TELL THEM WHAT TO DO
WITH IT BECAUSE I CAN GUARANTEE
IT WILL NOT GO WHERE YOU WANTED
TO GO.
SO WE WILL ENSURE THAT THERE
WOULD BE ACCOUNTABILITY THERE'D
BE TRANSPARENCY AND ALL THESE
WONDERFUL THINGS AND ALL OF US
WENT BACK TO OUR DISTRICTS AND
TOLD OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THAT ARE STRUGGLING YOU'RE GOING
TO GET 20% MORE FOR THESE KIDS
ISSUE AND THIS THE NEXT AND SO
FORTH AND SO ON AND WE AND IT
NEVER REALLY MATERIALIZE THAT
WAY IN MOST DISTRICTS.
SO -- SO WE
LOOKED AT IT AND AND IN MANY
WAYS -- SOME
OF THE MY CONCERN IT IT HAS TO
DO WITH MY OWN PERSONAL
INTEGRITY OF INSURING TO PEOPLE
THAT THIS WAS GOING TO HAPPEN I
WAS NUMBER.
ONE BUT NUMBER TWO THAT WE HAVE
DISTRICTS THAT MADE A CONSCIOUS
DECISION TO SUPPORT THIS EVEN
THOUGH THEY KNOW KNEW THAT THERE
DISTRICT WOULD NOT BENEFIT FROM
IT.
BUT THEY DID NOT HAVE ENOUGH OF
FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH KIDS IN
THAT HAVE NOTHING FALL SECURE
BUT THEY BELIEVE THAT WE WOULD
USE THE MONEY APPROPRIATELY. TO
HELP KIDS WITH STRUGGLING IN ALL
OF US WHO SIGNED ON TO IT
BELIEVE THAT EVEN IF WE HAD
DISTRICTS BUT CERTAIN DISTRICTS
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH STUDENTS.
THE COMMITMENT WAS AT THE STATE
LEVEL THEY AND AS A RESULT THOSE
AFFLUENT COMMUNITIES MIGHT
SUFFER QUOTE UNQUOTE BUT NOT
GIVING THIS ADDITIONAL MONEY.
THAT WOULD NORMALLY HAVE BEEN
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS THE DISTRICT
SO I FEEL SINCE IT AND I HOPE
EVERYBODY ELSE DOES IT WE HAVE
TO BE HAVE SOME INTEGRITY ABOUT
THIS.
THAT THOSE DISTRICTS TRUSTED US
TO ENSURE THAT IF WE TOOK MONEY
THAT WAS NOT DISTRIBUTED EQUALLY
ACROSS THE STATE.
THAT WE WOULD DO WOULD DUE
DILIGENCE MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
KIDS ARE STRUGGLING THE HEART IS
WOULD GET THE RESOURCES THAT WE
WOULD CLOSE THIS ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AND THIS WAS ONE OF THE WAYS OF
DOING SO WITHOUT SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY IN DISCUSSION IT
MAY IT'S NOT HAPPENING AND SO
THAT'S A THAT'S A PART OF IT.
THE THE WHOLE ISSUE OF WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO BUT WE'LL SEE IF
IF AND AS WE TALK ABOUT MOVING
FORWARD I DON'T WANT TO GET DOWN
TWENTY YEARS FROM NOW AS WE HAVE
WITH ALL THE CATEGORIES AND
DISCOVER WHAT YOU KNOW IT WAS A
BAD PLAN.
WE CITIZENS OF MALES WE COULD
LOOK AT IT A DIFFERENT WAY --
IT IS AFTER FIVE YEARS IT IS
TIME FOR US TO ASSESS WHAT THE
NOT GUILTY OF THIS IS WHAT WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO DO.
AND IS THIS WAY THAT WE FEEL WE
CAN FIND OUR SCHOOLS AND
ACTUALLY GET THE RESOURCES. TO
THE PEOPLE WHO NEED IT BUT MOST
IMPORTANT TO GET THE RESULTS WE
WANT ALL THE KIDS IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT AND
APPRECIATE YOUR DUE DILIGENCE ON
THAT I REMEMBER THAT DISCUSSIONS
IN THE FIGHTS WHEN WE'RE
DISCUSSING LC FF AND ENSURING
THAT WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN -- TO
ASSIST THOSE DEMOGRAPHICS THAT
REALLY NEED IT OKAY AT THAT TIME
SIR MUNNINGS QUESTION HAS BEEN
ANSWERED WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON.
THANK YOU JUST A COMMENT --
WANTED -- TO
ECHO THAT THE CONCERN THAT
SENATOR ROTH RAISED WITH RESPECT --
TO WE WE HAVE TO SCHOOL DISTRICT
ONE LARGER ONE SMALLER --
BASICALLY YOU CAN GO DOWN A
MAJOR ROAD IN FRESNO AND CLOVIS
AND ON ONE SIDE IT'S ONE ON THE
OTHER IT'S THE OTHER.
THE PERCENTAGES IN THE LARGER
SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE ARE
OBVIOUSLY --
A SIGNIFICANTLY LARGE BUT THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGES LAST
THEN OBVIOUSLY IN THE SMALLER
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET IN ONE
DISTRICT AS COMPARED TO ANOTHER
THE SAME CHILD WITH THE SAME
PATHOLOGIES IN THE SAME ISSUES.
IS GETTING HALF AS MUCH PER
PUPIL AS THE ONE SIMPLY ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE STREET.
THE SECOND AREA OF OF CONCERN IS
THAT THE SMALLER SCHOOL DISTRICT.
IS ACTUALLY SEEING A LARGE
INFLUX OF PARENTS REQUESTING.
AT THE MOVE FROM THE LARGER
SCHOOL DISTRICT WITH ALL THE LC
INVEST MONEY INTO A THE SMALLER
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND WHY IS THAT
[inaudible]
THE SUCCESS OF THE SMALLER
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
ACROSS THE STREET WITH ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND WITH
POVERTY CHILDREN IS ABSOLUTELY
REMARKABLE.
AND FAMILIES ARE BEGINNING TO
KIND OF FIGURE THAT OUT.
AND SO THERE IS A SENSE AT LEAST
IN OUR COMMUNITY THAT BIG GAPS
ARE THE FUNDING --
BUT SMALLER BUT SUCCESSFUL --
TO GET HALF AS MUCH SO THERE
SEEMS TO BE A DISPARITY THERE IF
REACHING.
FAMILIES AND KIDS IS IT ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND POVERTY
KIDS IS THE GOAL WE OUGHT TO AT
LEAST BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
IN SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS
PERCENTAGES MAY BE.
SMALLER BUT THE ACTUAL
ACHIEVEMENT.
IS SUPERB AND THAT OUGHT TO BE
WORDED RATHER THAN IN SOME
INSTANCES WHERE.
SOME PARENTS IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FEEL THAT THAT THERE'S
A PENALTY FOR IT SO THAT'S
THAT'S JUST A OBSERVATION FROM.
THE DISTRICTS IN OUR IN IN IN
WHERE I REPRESENT.
BUT I THINK IN YOU'VE DISCOVERED
ACROSS THE STATE THERE ARE A
WHOLE LOT OF DIFFERENT VARIABLES
THAT IMPACT.
STUDENT PERFORMANCE AND STUDENT
SUCCESS AND THAT'S A GOOD THING
THAT IT'S NOT JUST DEPENDENT
UPON THE MONEY THAT YOU GET BUT
MORE IMPORTANT SO IT DEPENDS
UPON THE PEOPLE IN THE CLASSROOM.
AND THE COMMITMENT OF THE
LEADERSHIP AT THAT SCHOOL TO
MAKE THINGS HAPPEN FOR KIDS SO
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THAT EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE GIVING MONEY.
IT WILL NOT.
MAKE A DIFFERENCE UNLESS IT IS
APPROPRIATELY USED AND IN THE
CLASSROOM FOR STUDENTS AND I
THINK WE'VE DISCOVERED THAT OVER
THE YEARS AS WE'VE SEEN MONEY
INCREASE.
WE NOT NECESSARILY SEEING THE
RESULTS BECAUSE IT WOULD DO SOME
THINGS BUT IT WON'T DO
EVERYTHING.
YOU KNOW AND AND SOMETIMES OF
SMALLER DISTRICT IS MORE
DESIRABLE BECAUSE OF THE ABILITY
TO ACTUALLY MEET THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS SOME LARGE DISTRICTS
STRUGGLE BECAUSE THEY ARE TOO
LARGE.
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT DON'T
FOCUS ON SOMETIMES THE ISSUES
THAT ARE IMPORTANT.
APPRECIATE THE CONCERN ABOUT AND
THANK YOU THE SALMON MOVED TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DEEP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF A
MISS OUR IN IN YOUR NINETEEN
YEARS AS A STATE AUDITOR OF WHAT
WAS THE LAST TIME.
YOU AUDIT OF THE LC FF AND E. L.
K. F. IS RELATIVELY NEW MR DEEP.
AS FAR AS WE HAVE AUDITED.
INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS AT
TIMES AS FAR AS THEIR FISCAL
FISCAL HEALTH THEIR USE OF FUNDS
BUT EL CFF IS ONLY A FEW YEARS
OLD AS FAR AS A A NEW PROGRAM OR
A NEW WAY OF DISTRIBUTING FUNDS.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
AS DOCTOR WEBER INDICATED --
IT IT HAS NEVER BEEN AUDITED SO
THIS WOULD BE A FIRST LOOK AT
HOW WELL HAS THIS PROGRAM THE
PROGRAM'S BEEN IN PLACE LONG
ENOUGH. FOR US TO TAKE A LOOK AT
IT -- BUT IT
WOULD BE THE FIRST LOOK AT LC FF
AND CERTAINLY THE USE OF EL CAPS
NOW SOME OTHER AUDITS THAT WE'VE
DONE WE HAVE LOOKED AT L. CAPS.
A PARTICULARLY IN AUDIT WE WE
MENTION IN.
THE ANALYSIS AS FAR AS OTHER
WORK WE LOOKED AT COLLEGE READY
NESS -- FOR
MISTER JONES SAWYER AS FAR AS
WHAT OUR SCHOOLS DOING IN MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND CERTAINLY IN HIGH
SCHOOL IN PREPARING THEM FOR
COLLEGE.
AND WE LOOKED AT EL CAPS IN THAT
PARTICULAR AUDIT WE DID HAVE
SOME CONCERNS WITH THE L. CAPS
WITH ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE THE PUBLIC IS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE PARENTS.
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE INVOLVED SO
WE WE HAVE A HAVE NOT DONE CON
EL CFS LOOK AT AT NEW FUND SOME
IS WORKING [inaudible]
YOU MENTIONED THE OTHER PROGRAM
HAS ONLY BEEN A HERE'S A FEW
YEARS IN WHICH WOULD YOU SAY THE
STARTER FIVE YEARS SAYING IS
THIRTY FISCAL YEAR THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN IS THE FIRST YEAR FOR
LCF APSOS BUT LIKE FIVE FIVE SIX
YEARS OF THE MOST RIGHT.
AND AND AND IS THERE HAVE BEEN
AUDIT BEFORE THIS WOULD BE THE
FIRST TIME WITH THE COMMITTEE
APPROACH.
THAT'S CORRECT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OKAY
THANK YOU.
ASK IF THERE'S ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM DíAS MEMBERS.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO A PUBLIC COMMENT LET
ME ASK IF THERE ARE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH TO
COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE.
HEARING AND SEEING THEN LET ME
ASK IF.
I HAVE A CLOSE ACTUALLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE OKAY PRECIADO
BRIEF.
CLOSING REMARK THE MOTION HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR ROTH
SECOND IN BY A SECOND WAS BURGER
HARBOR.
MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO APPROVE AUDIT
NUMBER TWENTY NINETEEN DASH ONE
OH ONE SCHOOL DISTRICTS LOCAL
CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS HI.
SALAS HI BOERNER HORVATH HI.
BOERNER HORVATH I DEEP I DEEP I
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WOULD.
WOOD HI SENATOR ROTH.
ROTH AYE FORGES.
BORDERS I DORADO.
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG I MONEY.
MONNING AYE MOORLACH
[inaudible]
WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
THE MOTION CARRIES WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
TAT ON THANK YOU.
AT THIS TIME WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
AGENDA ITEM.
NUMBER SEVEN TWO ZERO ONE NINE
DASH ONE ZERO EIGHT SACRAMENTO
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY.
IF YOU'LL PLEASE APPROACH XIN
BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE READY.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMITTEE FOR ENTERTAINING THIS
REQUEST I'M HERE TODAY TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
THAT THE COMMITTEE APPROVED A
FINANCE --
MY SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT OUR LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS IN A SEVERE A BUDGET
DEFICIT LIVE LITERALLY TEETERING
ON THE BREAK BRINK OF INSOLVENCY.
THE STATE TAKEOVER --
POTENTIALLY LOOMING.
THIS PAST FALL ARE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION REJECTED OUR
DISTRICTS BUDGET PLAN BECAUSE IT
WAS NOT SUFFICIENT TO RELATE TO
ON GOING DEFICIT SPENDING.
A FEW WEEKS LATER OUR STATE
FISCAL CRISIS MANAGEMENT TEAM
VIC MATT.
I REVIEWED THEIR DISTRICT
INCLUDES AN ALSO CONCLUDED THE
DISTRICT IS AT HIGH RISK --
FOR INSOLVENCY.
AND ESSENTIALLY THEY FOUND THAT --
THE DISTRICT AND IS GOING TO RUN
OUT OF CASH AND SO WE KNOW THAT
WE WE KNOW THE DISTRICT IS
ACTUALLY WORKING HARD TO ADDRESS
THAT AND I HAVE CONFIDENCE
THEY'RE GOING TO IN THE NEAR
FUTURE.
BUT THE BIGGER QUESTION REMAINS
IS IS HOW DO WE GET HERE WHAT
CAN WE DO TO PREVENT THIS
DISTRICT ANOTHER SIMILAR
DISTRICTS. FOR IT FROM THESE
ISSUES IN YOU KNOW FOCUS ON THE
BIG PICTURE HERE I THINK THE
ISSUE THAT REALLY MAKES MY
CONSTITUENTS AND ME FRANKLY AND
MY COLLEAGUES WHO REPRESENT THE
SECRETARY UP SCRATCHED HER HEAD.
IS THIS DISTRICT IS AT THE BRINK
OF INSOLVENCY AT A TIME WHEN
WE'VE INCREASED REVENUE FROM THE
STATE BY 50%. 250% MORE MONEY
FOR MY TAX DOLLARS GOING TO THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THEY'VE
NEVER BEEN MORE BROKE AND
USUALLY HAVE DISTRICTS WHO ARE
ABOUT TO GO BROKE WHEN WE'RE IN
A RECESSION.
WHEN THERE'S LESS MONEY GOING TO
A LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT BUT
RIGHT HERE --
THE IS IS REALLY --
AN OPPORTUNITY TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT HAPPENED AND HOW WE CAN
PREVENT THIS FROM.
EVER HAPPENING AGAIN.
AND I WILL STE A STATE THAT --
THIS IS NOT THE ONLY DISTRICT
THAT HAS GOING THROUGH TOUGH
TIMES. THIRTY SIX UP AND DOWN
CALIFORNIA NOT ME DISTRICTS ARE
AT THIS POINT WITH THICK MAT
LITERALLY ON THE ON THE VERGE OF
RUNNING OUT OF CASH AND SO --
YOU COULD PROBABLY HAVE THE SAME
DISCUSSIONS FOR QUITE A FEW
DISTRICTS AND SO WE DID LOOK AT
LOOKING AT MULTIPLE DISTRICTS WE
LOOK TALK TO THE AUDITOR STAFF
WE FIGURED.
HAVING A DEEP DIVE INTO ONE
DISTRICT WILL CERTAINLY HELP US
HERE IN SACRAMENTO HELP
LEADERSHIP HELP THE SCHOOL BOARD
HELP THE COMMUNITY UNDERSTAND
HOW WE GOT HERE.
AND TO PREVENT THIS FROM EVER
HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE.
I DID WANT TO KNOW TWO THERE
WERE SOME EARLY QUESTIONS ON
THIS AUDIT.
AS FAR AS OVERLAP WITH EXISTING --
FINANCIAL ANALYSIS WE DID WORK
WITH THE AUDIT TEAM AND WITH
THICK MAT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
AUDIT WOULD NOT.
DUPLICATE EXISTING WORK BUT TAKE
A DEEPER DIVE OF THREE TO FIVE
YEARS BACK TO LOOK AT I'D BUDGET
DECISIONS --
ACTIONS --
YOU KNOW FINANCIAL UNDERSTANDING
OF THE OF THE POINT TIME
DECISIONS ARE LAST THREE TO FIVE
YEARS TO TO REALLY TAKE A LOOK
AT THE FINANCES OF OUR
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
AND THEN THE SECOND THING IS A
DISTRICT IS TRYING TO ACT RIGHT
NOW IN THE CURRENT YEAR TO
ADDRESS SOME OTHER BUDGET ISSUES
SO I'M ASKING IF THE COMMITTEE
ADOPTS US TODAY.
THAT WE HAVE THE AUDIT START --
AFTER MAY FIRST TO ALLOW THEM TO
TO TO WORK ON THEIR CURRENT
BUDGET ISSUES AND NOT GETTING
AWAY WITH WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
DO WITH ADOPTING THEIR THEIR
BUDGET THIS --
THIS SPRING AND EARLY SUMMER --
SO WITH THAT THANK YOU FOR THE
CONSIDERATION AND I I GUESS FOR
ME TODAY TO SPEAK AS WELL PLEASE
PROCEED [inaudible]
OKAY.
WHAT GOOD DAY EVERYONE A MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS KATE VAN BUREN I SERVED ON
THE SACRAMENTO CITY EL CAP
COMMITTEE? FOR TWO TERMS --
I'M CURRENTLY SERVING AS AN ARTS
AND EDUCATION ADVISER TO THE
DISTRICT.
I'M HOMEOWNER A TAXPAYER.
A STOCK STATE GRADUATE.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY I'M A
PARENT OF THREE STUDENTS WHO
HAVE GONE THROUGH THE SACRAMENTO
CITY SCHOOL DISTRICT.
MY SERVICE AS AN EL CAP
REPRESENTATIVE.
WE SPENT HOURS TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE BUDGET.
AS AN ADVOCATE FOR ARTS AND
MUSIC EDUCATION I WAS
PARTICULARLY FOCUSED ON POTS OF
MONEY.
THAT WOULD BE USED TO HIRE AND
TRAIN TEACHERS TO INTEGRATE THE
ARTS INTO THEIR CURRICULUM.
WHAT I FOUND WAS A VERY
CONFUSING OPAQUE SYSTEM?
THAT SEEMED DESIGNED TO
OBFUSCATE ACTUAL REVENUE AND
SPENDING.
I HAVE REVIEWED THE FISCAL RISK
ANALYSIS PUBLISHED BY THE FISCAL
CRISIS MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE
TEAM ON DECEMBER TWELFTH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THREE ITEMS
POPPED OUT AT ME. ONE FEDERAL
DOLLARS WERE LEFT ON SPENT AND
WILL RETURN TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
WELL UNRESTRICTED MONEY RAN OUT
LEAVING A DEFICIT. TWO THERE IS
A SMALL GROUP IN THE BUSINESS
OFFICE.
OF THE DISTRICT TO ARE VIRTUALLY
UNDER --
MAKING SPENDING AND HIRING
DECISIONS WITHOUT CONSULTING A
LARGER GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS.
NUMBER.
THREE EMPLOYEES MADE FUTURE
BUDGETING DECISIONS BASED ON A
ONE TIME INFLUX OF FUNDS EVEN
THOUGH GOVERNOR BROWN INSTRUCTED
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT NOT TO DO SO.
THE DISTRICT WENT ON AN
ADMINISTRATIVE HIRING SPREE.
IT IS UNKNOWN OR IF OR HOW MUCH
OF THIS MONEY ACTUALLY WENT INTO
THE CLASSROOM.
I SUPPORT THE REQUEST OF AN
AUDIT STARTING MAY FIRST.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHO MAKES
THE DECISIONS REGARDINGWHICH
POTS OF MONEY TO SPEND.
ON STUDENTS AND PROGRAMS.
WHO MADE THE DECISION TO HIRE
NEW ADMINISTRATORS AND WHY?
WERE THESE HIRES NECESSARY WHAT
JOB CATEGORIES WERE NEWLY
CREATED FOR THEM.
WHO IMPROVE SALARY INCREASES ARE
BONUSES FOR ADMINISTRATORS?
WHAT QUALIFICATIONS AND TRAINING
TO CURRENT FISCAL DECISION
MAKERS ACTUALLY HAVE?
WILL THESE EMPLOYEES BE INVOLVED
IN FUTURE DECISION MAKING.
OUR SCHOOLS ARE IN TROUBLE.
I AM AN ADVOCATE OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION.
AND I DO NOT WANT TO SEE A
TAKEOVER.
OF OUR LOCAL SCHOOLS BY THE
UNDERSTANDING WHY WE LANDED IN
THE SITUATION.
IS TO UNDERGO A DETAILED BROAD
AUDIT.
OUTLINING WHO WHAT.
WHEN AND WHY?
WE MUST BE TRANSPARENT WE MUST
HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY.
TAXPAYERS WHO FUND OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS DESERVE TO KNOW HOW
THEIR TAXES ARE BEING SPENT.
AND FAMILIES DESERVE TO KNOW WHY
FEDERAL DOLLARS WERE LEFT ON
SPENT.
PLEASE UPPORT AND IMPLEMENT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY'S
REQUEST FOR AN AUDIT IMMEDIATELY
WE HAVE LIMITED TIME TO RIGHT
THE SHIP BUT I AM CONFIDENT WITH
THE CORRECT TEAM ON BOARD.
WE CAN RETAIN LOCAL CONTROL AND
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY TO THE
PUBLIC THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE --
MY NAME IS CRAIG POWELL AND I AM
THE PRESIDENT.
OF I ON SACRAMENTO WHICH IS A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WATCHDOG
ORGANIZATION AND POLICY ADVISORY
GROUP.
IT'S BEEN IN OPERATION
SACRAMENTO FOR ABOUT EIGHT YEARS
DRILLING DEEP AS WE CAN INTO.
INTO WHAT'S GOING ON AND UNITS
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND
SO FORTH --
WE'RE RECENTLY MADE THE DECISION
TO EXPAND AND CREATE A UNIT
CALLED AYE ON SACRAMENTO SCHOOLS --
AND THE AND THE REAL TRIGGER FOR
THAT HAS BEEN THIS FINANCIAL
CRISIS WITH THIS SEGMENT A CITY
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I'M A RETIRED CORPORATE LAWYER
I'M A FIFTH GENERATION
SACRAMENTO THE THIRD GENERATION
OF MY FAMILY SECOND GENERATION
OF MY FAMILY OUT OF THREE TO GO
THROUGH CITY SCHOOLS --
I ALSO SERVICE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE SACRAMENTO TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION.
AND I WANT TO APPLAUD --
MEMBER MCCARTY FOR MAKING THIS
REQUEST HE AND I HAVE NOT ALWAYS
SEEN EYE TO EYE ON ISSUES --
HOWEVER FROM TIME TO TIME AND
THIS IS CERTAINLY ONE OF THOSE
AND WE HAVE GREAT RESPECT --
FOR HIS PRINCIPLED APPROACH TO
TO LAW MAKING AND POLICY --
AND ALWAYS HAVE.
THIS IS A DISTRICT THAT IS IN
SEVERE CRISIS AND ITS
CONSTITUTES THE BIGGEST SINGLE
THREAT TO THE FUTURE OF
SACRAMENTO.
IS THE FAILURE OF THIS DISTRICT
LET ME REPEAT THAT THIS IS THE
SINGLE BIGGEST THREAT TO THE
FUTURE SACRAMENTO.
AND ITS CHILDREN.
SO THIS IS THE FIRE DRILL TIME
FOLKS I AM SHOCKED THIS HASN'T
BEEN DONE YEARS AGO --
AND AND REGULARLY DONE --
I'VE BEEN INVOLVED WITH ISSUES
AND THE SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR A
COUPLE OF DECADES NOW LET AN
EFFORT TO RECALL SCHOOL BOARD
ABOUT TWO DECADES AGO IN AN
EFFORT CO CHAIRED BY THEN.
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER --
THE LATE SAMPLE NOW --
THAT EFFORT FELL SHORT.
LED TO A A SLATE BEING PUT FORTH
BY VAN SACRAMENTO MAYOR JOE
SERNA AND AND PHIL ANGELIDES
WHICH SUCCESSFULLY.
TOSSED OUT A POORLY PERFORMING
SCHOOL SCHOOL BOARD WHICH DID
FRANKLY A VERY GOOD JOB FOR
ABOUT A DECADE.
AND THEN AND THEN THINGS WENT
BAD.
AND THEY'VE BEEN GETTING
PROGRESSIVELY WORSE --
PART OF THE PROBLEMS THE
COLLAPSE OF LOCAL MEDIA THE BEE
IS A SECOND TO BE IS A IS A
SHADOW OF ITS FORMER SELF NOT
ABLE.
TO STAFF --
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT WITH THREE
REPORTERS LIKE IT DID IT ONE
TIME -- SO
WE'LL FORM AN ORGANIZATION TO
TRY TO TRY THIS TO TO TO TO MAKE
FILL UP FOR THAT VACUUM BUT WE
DON'T HAVE SUBPOENA POWER.
WE DON'T HAVE THE POWERS OF
DISCOVERY WE DESPERATELY NEED --
AT A RESPECTED ORGANIZATION.
EXAMINER TO REVIEW THIS TO COME
UP WITH FINDINGS THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTRAST.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THE THAT THE
PARTIES IN PLAY HERE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE AND THE
TEACHERS UNION ARE LOBBING BOMBS
ON ONE ANOTHER AND NO ONE KNOWS
WHO TO TRUST.
THE STATE AUDITOR HAS A STRONG
REPUTATION REPUTATION OF BEING
TRUSTED.
SO WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT WHEN THE
FINDINGS OF THIS AUDIT COMES OUT.
WHO ARE RUNNING FOR SCHOOL BOARD
WILL BE ASK DO YOU SUPPORT THIS
FINDING --
THIS RECOMMENDATION OF THE STATE
AUDITOR OR PEOPLE WILL CREATE
CANDIDATES WILL CREATE PLATFORMS
WILL SAY WE ARE RUNNING ON A
PLATFORM TO IMPLEMENT THE THINGS
RECOMMENDED BY THE STATE AUDITOR.
AND TO REFRAIN FROM THE THINGS.
THAT SHE IDENTIFIED AS HAVING
BEEN THIS DISTRICT.
SO THIS IS THAT IMPORTANT THAT
WE SEE SO --
WE WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO TO
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT --
WE WE DO FEEL THAT THEY ARE A
LOT OF COMMON ISSUES BETWEEN
THIS GESTURE CAN A NUMBER AROUND
THE STATE.
MASSIVE VOEPEL BALL LIABILITIES
SEVEN HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN
OUR DISTRICT. TWELVE BILLION OR
WHATEVER THEN LA AND THEIR
NUMBER OF OTHERS AND THERE'S
SOME UNIQUE ISSUES BUT I DO
THINK THERE OBJECT LESSONS THAT
CAN BE TAKEN AWAY FROM THIS.
IN A DEEP DIVE BY THE HONOR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
MCCARTY BRING WITNESSES TODAY
THE SITE WILL MOVE TO
PRESENTATION BY THE STATE
AUDITOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AS MR
MCCARTY INDICATED THIS WILL BE
AN AUDIT OF SACRAMENTO CITY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND WE
DO HAVE THE FIGMENT REPORT AND
CERTAINLY WILL REVIEW THAT
REPORT.
WHAT MR MCCARTY INDICATED IS VIC
MATT'S MY UNDERSTANDING FITMENT
SICK MATT LOOKED AT ABOUT A
FOURTEEN MONTH WINDOW WHAT MR
MCCARTY IS ASKING US TO DO IS
LOOK AT A FULL FIVE YEAR WINDOW?
WHICH IS WHAT THE BUDGET OF THIS
PARTICULAR AUDIT IS BASED ON SO
WE WOULD LOOK AT REVENUES
EXPENDITURES THEIR BUDGET
PROJECT PROJECTIONS THEIR BUDGET
PREPARATION FOR THE LAST FIVE
YEARS. TO REALLY TRY TO
DETERMINE WHAT ACTIONS THAT TO
THE DISTRICT TOOK OVER THOSE
FIVE YEARS ORIN SOME CASES
FAILED TO TAKE.
A THAT WERE REALLY THE DRIVERS A
PRIMARY CAUSE OF THEIR CURRENT
FISCAL.
SITUATION --
AS AS HIS WITNESSES INDICATED WE
WOULD LOOK AT WHO MADE SOME OF
THOSE DECISIONS WHAT WAS THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR DECISIONS THAT
WERE MADE OVER THAT TIME FRAME
THAT AGAIN LED TO OUR
CONTRIBUTED.
TO THE SITUATION THAT THE
DISTRICT FINDS ITSELF
PROJECTIONS OF LOOKING AT THE
REASONABLENESS OF THEIR BUDGET
PROJECTIONS OVER THOSE FIVE
YEARS --
WHAT ACTIONS IS THE DISTRICT
TAKING OR INTENDING TO TAKE TO
TRY TO RESOLVE --
THEIR FINANCIAL SITUATION --
LOOKING AT AS I SAID THEIR
BUDGETING PRACTICES THEIR
FINANCIAL PRACTICES --
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THERE
ARE THINGS THAT THEY COULD
IMPROVE UPON --
AND DO A BETTER JOB OF
PROJECTING AND THEN CERTAINLY --
TRACKING THEIR THEIR FINANCES HE
SPECIFICALLY ASKED US TO LOOK AT
THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION HAS MADE MULTIPLE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE DISTRICT
MISS MCCARTY WANTS US.
TO RELIEF DRILL DOWN AND FIGURE
OUT OKAY WHICH OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED --
I HAVE THOSE ASSISTED IN
IMPROVING THE DISTRICT IF THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN IMPLEMENTED WHAT'S
THE RATIONALE WHY IS THE
DISTRICT NOT IMPLEMENTING THOSE
PARTICULAR RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND THEN THE LAST OBJECTIVE IS
REALLY LOOKING AT THE FOCUS OF
THE DISTRICT AND MINIMIZING THE
IMPACT ON STUDENTS OF THE
SITUATION AT THE DISTRICT FINDS
ITSELF AND SO WHAT ARE THEY
DOING. TO MITIGATE ANY ADVERSE
IMPACT ON STUDENTS AT SEX CITY
UNIFIED --
THIS AUDIT IS RELATIVELY SMALL --
IT'S ABOUT TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
HOURS -- SO
WE AND AGAIN IF IF THE THE
REQUESTED FOR US TO DELAY
STARTING THIS AUDIT UNTIL MAY
THAT'S EASILY DOABLE AS I SAID
IN MY OPENING STATEMENT.
WE HAVE STAFF THAT CAN START
AUDIT IN MARCH AND APRIL BUT
AGAIN THERE ARE AT LEAST ONE
AUDIT --
DOCTOR WEBBER'S AUDIT THAT WAS
APPROVED WHERE WE COULD PUT A
COUPLE OF TEAMS ON THAT
PARTICULAR AUDIT --
AND HOMELESSNESS AUDIT AS WELL
WHERE THAT'S A LARGE AUDIT WHERE
WE'VE ASKED.
BEEN ASKED TO GO TO A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT DISTRICTS SO I CAN
THROW A COUPLE OF TEAMS AT THAT
AS WELL.
AND THEN WHEN.
IF THE COMMITTEE APPROVES THIS
WE WILL HAVE STAFF AVAILABLE TO
STARTED IN MAY IF THAT'S THE
DESIRE OF THE COMMITTEE AS WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR
PRESERVATION OF THIS TIME LET'S
ASK IF THERE ARE ANY AFFECTED
AGENCIES I BELIEVE WE DO HAVE
ONE INDIVIDUAL THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY --
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE CONTRAST
HERE AT THE TABLE.
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS OKAY ELECT
SUPERINTENDENT SEXY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT --
GOOD MORNING --
CHAIRMAN SALAS AND MEMBERS OF
THIS JOINT COMMITTEE --
AND THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
THIS MORNING --
FOR OVER A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
YEARS OUR DISTRICT HAS BEEN
SERVING SACRAMENTO STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES WITH QUALITY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THAT PREPARE STUDENTS
FOR COLLEGE AND CAREER.
WE CURRENTLY SERVE OVER FORTY
TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS AND WHERE
THE THIRTEENTH LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE STATE.
WE'RE ALSO ONE OF THE LARGEST
EMPLOYERS IN THE AREA AND OVER
70% OF OUR STUDENTS ARE LOW
INCOME ELIGIBLE STUDENTS.
AS HAS BEEN REPORTED IN THE NEWS
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS HAD TO
DISAPPROVE BUDGETS AND IS
CURRENTLY AT RISK.
OF STATE TAKEOVER IF WE CANNOT
ACHIEVE THIRTY FIVE MILLION IN
CUTS BY JUNE TO BALANCE OUR
BUDGET.
AS YOU KNOW STATE TAKEOVER WOULD
HAVE MANY DIRE CONSEQUENCES FOR
SCHOOLS --
BUT I WANT TO GIVE A FEW
EXAMPLES.
SPECIFICALLY IT WOULD MEAN AMONG
OTHER THINGS THAT LESS MONEY
WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO SPEND ON
OUR STUDENTS BECAUSE WE WOULD
PAY MARKET RATE INTEREST ON A
STATE LAW ON THAT WOULD BE ISSUE
TO US.
AND APPOINTED ADMINISTRATOR
WOULD TAKE OVER AND LOCAL
CONTROL WOULD BE LOST.
I SHOWN ELSEWHERE IN THE STATE
IN OTHER EXAMPLES RECOVERY COULD
TAKE MORE THAN TEN YEARS.
AND OVERALL EXPERTS AGREE THAT A
STATE TAKEOVER IS BAD FOR
STUDENTS.
OVER THE PAST YEAR WE'VE
UNDERGONE FOR FINANCIAL REVIEWS
AND THESE HAVE BEEN HELPFUL IN
IDENTIFYING AREAS OF FOCUS FOR
US.
THEY INCLUDE LAST FALL THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION APPOINTED A FISCAL
ADVISER THAT IS IN OUR DISTRICT
CURRENTLY.
HAS BEEN STATION INSIDE AND IS
WORKING WITH DISTRICT OFFICES TO
REVIEW THE WORK OF OUR BUDGET
TEAM AND BUSINESS SERVICES
DEPARTMENT.
THANK MATT COMPLETED A FISCAL
HEALTH ANALYSIS AND ISSUED A
REPORT IN DECEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AN AUDITING
FIRM CHRO L. L. P. COMPLETED AND
PRESENTED AN INDEPENDENT AUDIT
OF OUR DISTRICT AND PRESENTED
THEIR FINDINGS IN DECEMBER OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION CONDUCTED A FEDERAL.
PROGRAM MONITORING REVIEW TO
ENSURE DISTRICT IS PROPERLY
SPENDING FEDERAL FUNDS.
NOW BASED ON THE WORK OF THESE
FOR INDEPENDENT ENTITIES WHO
CONDUCTED REVIEWS OF OUR
DISTRICT ALL THE EVIDENCE POINTS
TO OUR DISTRICTS BUDGET
CHALLENGES STEMMING FROM OUR
COSTS.
EXCEEDING OUR REVENUES.
AS THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE FOR OUR
DISTRICT MY CURRENT PRIORITY IS
TO ENSURE THAT IN THE COMING
MONTHS.
MY STAFF ARE 1100% DEDICATED TO
DOING THE WORK NECESSARY TO
AVOID A STATE TAKEOVER.
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT ANY
DISTRACTION TAKING US AWAY FROM
DOING THEWORK OF SAVING OUR
SCHOOLS PUTS US AT EVEN GREATER
RISK OF A TAKEOVER.
I UNDERSTAND THE INTENT OF THE
REQUESTED STATE AUDIT FOR
DISTRICT AND I DON'T OBJECT TO
THE INTENT.
BACK I WOULD ASK THAT THE REVIEW
OF THE OUGHT TO GO BEYOND THE
PROPOSED THREE TO FIVE YEAR
PERIODI'VE BEEN SUPERINTENDENT
FOR EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
BUT WHAT I'M HOPING IS THAT WE
CAN WORK TOGETHER WITH THIS
COMMITTEE ON THE TIMING OF THE
AUDIT.
AND I WOULD ASK THAT MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE.
WORK TO IDENTIFY A REASONABLE
TIME LYING TO CONDUCT THE AUDIT.
AND AT THAT TIME LINE INVOLVED
STARTING IT AT THE END OF JUNE
ONCE WE SUBMIT A BALANCED BUDGET
AND SAVE OUR DISTRICT.
I SAY THIS BECAUSE IN MY LAST
POST AT FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT I OVERSAW AN AUDIT BY
THE STATE AUDITOR AND CAN SPEAK
TO THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT WOULD
TAKE TO AFFECTED WE FOCUS ON OUR
CURRENT CHALLENGES. ONE CLOSE BY
SHARING THAT SAVING OUR SCHOOLS
IS DEEPLY PERSONAL TO ME OUTSIDE
OF HAVING THE HONOR OF SERVING A
SUPERINTENDENT I'M THE PARENT OF
FOUR CHILDREN AND SEXY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT RANGING.
FROM FOURTH GRADE ALL THE WAY TO
A TWELFTH GRADE.
AND MY EXPECTATION IS THAT WE
WILL SAVE OUR SCHOOLS AND THAT I
WILL SEE MY CURRENT FOURTH
GRADER GRADUATE WITH THE CLASS
OF TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN I'M
COMMITTED TO FINDING BUDGET
SOLUTIONS THAT SERVE OUR
STUDENTS TODAY AND FOR YEARS TO
COME AND ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
WORK WITH ME.
AND MY TEAM TO IDENTIFY A
REASONABLE TIME LINE FOR THIS
AUDIT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THOSE COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL STATE AGENCIES THAT
WOULD WISH TO COMMENT ON THIS
ITEM.
HEARING AND SEEING NINE LET ME
TURN IT BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE
DíAS FOR QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS
LET ME ASK A QUICK QUESTION OF
SOMEONE MEMBER MCCARTY.
I GIVE THE TESTIMONY I BELIEVE
YOU.
TO HAVING THE AUDIT REQUEST --
AFTER ME SO [inaudible]
THE CORRECT.
YEAH WELL THE THE REQUEST WAS TO
HAVE IT START IMMEDIATELY UPON
THE VOTE TODAY AND WE SAT DOWN
WITH THE AUDIT TEAM AND WITH THE
DISTRICT THIS WEEK AND WE
THOUGHT A FAIR.
MIDDLE GROUND WAS MAY FIRST --
THEY LOOTED THAT THE FIRST --
FEW WEEKS ARE GETTING SEA LEGS
GOING IN.
MAKING THE REQUEST BACK AND
FORTH MEETING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT SO --
IN REALITY MAY FIRST WHAT WE
BELIEVE --
ACHIEVE THE THE DESIRES OF THE
DISTRICTS TO NOT GET IN THE WAY
WHICH I DON'T WANT NOT --
TO DISMISS THEIR DEAR DOING
TOUGH WORK RIGHT NOW AND DOING
MADE YEAR CUTS TO MAKE SURE THEY
DON'T GO INTO RECEIVER SIT
RECEIVERSHIP SO.
I THINK THE MAY FIRST DATE WILL
ALLOW US TO TO TO GET TO THAT
POINT.
OKAY AS ONE OF THAT CLEAR
CLARITY FOR TACKLING A BIG ISSUE
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF THE
HEADLINES --
RECENTLY ABOUT SEC UNIFIED BUT
WE KNOW THAT THOSE CARRY ON
OTHER DISTRICTS AS WELL IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO HAVE A BALANCED
BUDGET WITH THAT IDEA WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS
OF THE DíAS.
SENATE ROTH DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION. FOR YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
ADDITIONAL ALL CENTER BOARD
JUST IN THE HOME OF TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON.
THANK YOU I I TO JUST WANTED
SOME CLARIFICATION I HAVE A REAL
SOFT SPOT FOR FOLKS THAT WANT TO
GET INFORMATION --
I THINK IS POLICY MAKERS --
WE SHOULD HAVE --
ACCESS TO AS MUCH INFORMATION AS
POSSIBLE --
BUT DID I HEAR YOU EARLIER
MENTIONED THAT --
IF THE DRUG DRASTIC CHANGES ARE
DONE THAT THAT --
THE DISTRICT GO BANKRUPT AND
WHAT MONTH WAS OUR OUR CURRENT
CASH FLOW --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS --
PREDICTING THAT WE WOULD BE
RUNNING OUT OF CASH IN NOVEMBER
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN OF
COURSE AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY JUST MENTIONED WE ARE
MAKING CUTS NOW WE'VE STARTED TO
MAKE CUTS ALL THIS PAST YEAR --
TO EXTEND THAT DEADLINE --
AND INTO THE BUDGET ADOPTION
ADOPTION PROCESS IN JUNE --
SO THAT ALL OF THOSE CHANGES
WILL REFLECT A DELAY.
IN THAT DATE SO ARE YOU
ANTICIPATING THAT IN AUDIT WOULD
YIELD INFORMATION THAT'S NOT
ALREADY PROVIDED BY THE FOR
ENTITIES WHO HAVE PROVIDED
OVERSIGHT ON THIS MATTER PRIOR.
WELL.
AS I SAID I SUPPORT THE INTENSE
WHICH IS TO LOOK DEEPER AT
BUSINESS PROCESS SEES IT CETERA
THAT MIGHT.
MAKE SURE THAT THIS DOESN'T
HAPPEN AGAIN.
I WAS SIMPLY STATING THAT OUR
FOCUS IS ON MAKING SURE THAT OUR
WORK RESULTS IN A BALANCED
BUDGET SO THAT WE DO NOT RUN OUT
OF CASH BY NOVEMBER --
AND WE WILL WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE STATE AUDITOR TO MAKE SURE
THAT ANY FINDINGS BEYOND THAT
FOR THE LONG TERM ARE
IMPLEMENTED.
PERHAPS WE COULD ASK THE AUTHOR
IN THE AUDITOR --
THE SCOPE OF THIS DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THIS AND WHAT THINK MATT
DATED MAYBE WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
DISCOVERS WE ANTICIPATE.
CHANTING WELL THERE IT THERE ARE
TWO HURDLES ONE WE NEED TO GET
RID OF THE THE EMERGENCY RIGHT
NOW.
BUT EVEN DO THAT THE WORD THE
MARGINS ARE SUPER STAND SO WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON THE DISTRICT
GOING FORWARD.
WHAT HAPPENED HOW YOU FOR THIS
IN THE FUTURE --
Là THEORIES OUT THERE --
ONGOING EXPENDITURES ONE TIME
MONEY TOO MUCH ADMINISTRATION
EMPLOYEE CONTRACTS WE COULDN'T
AFFORD LOT OF BLOAT FEDERAL
MONEY LEFT ON THE TABLE SO WE
DON'T REALLY KNOW ALL THESE
THINGS AND OF THE THE THE THICK
MAT THE EXISTING ON ITS FOCUS
WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
SO WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS LOOK
OVER A MULTI YEAR PERIOD A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD.
IT IS WE CAN TAKE A STEP BACK
AND SO THE SUPERINTENDENT THE
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS THE
COMMUNITY CAN REALLY HAVE A BUT
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING AS FAR AS
HOW WE GOT HERE BECAUSE THIS.
WATER LAS STRAP DISTRICTS THIS
IS ABNORMAL ALIVE DISTRICTS HAVE
THE SAME POPULATIONS THE SAME
DEMOGRAPHICS RIGHT AROUND THIS
AREA AND THEY ARE NOT ABOUT TO
RUN OUT OF CASH IN THE NEXT SIX
MONTHS AND SO.
YOU KNOW THIS HAS A SHORT TERM --
ISSUE THAT THEY'RE WORKING TO
ADDRESS BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
LONG TERM PICTURE AS WELL.
SO THIS IS SOMETHING DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE
WITHIN THE JURISDICTION OF THE
SUPERINTENDENTS.
AND COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION --
VIA.
YES IT WAS WE WROTE THE AUDIT
REQUEST WITH THAT ONE QUESTION
MARK WE DIDN'T WANT TO DUPLICATE
WORK AND SO THERE IS THIS OUT
GETTING IN THE WEEDS TOO MUCH.
THERE'S A COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN THIS GROUP CALLED
FIX MATT THE FINANCIAL CRISIS
MANAGEMENT TEAM KIND OF BY THE
STATE TO DEPARTMENT OF THAT.
WHICH HAS BEEN DOING SOME
ANALYSIS ON WHERE THEY'RE AT
TODAY LIKE THE CASTLE ISSUE WHAT
YOU NEED TO DO.
TODAY AND TOMORROW THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS AND SO WE DID WE DIDN'T
WANT TO DUPLICATE THAT SO THIS
AUDIT THAT WE CRAFTED.
GOES WELL BEYOND THAT
[inaudible]
GEN.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PATTERSON PLACE.
DO I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU SUPPORT
THE AUDIT IF THE DATE WAS MOVED
INTO JUNE OR AT THE END OF YOUR
BUDGET.
ACT AND YOU OPPOSE THE AUDIT IF
IT IS IN MAY.
WELL WHAT I WANT TO MAKE SURE IS
THAT I WORK WITH --
THE STATE AUDITOR --
SO THAT --
WE ARE EXCLUSIVELY ON PASSING A
BALANCED BUDGET AT THE END OF
JUNE -- SO
IF THAT REQUIRES --
BEGINNING TO DO SOME INTERACTION
SOME --
GATHERING OF INFORMATION.
I WOULD JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR
STAFF'S TIME IS DEDICATED TO THE
AUDIT AFTER WE PASS A BALANCED
BUDGET.
I MEAN I WOULD.
I AGAIN I I THINK I'M GONNA ECHO
THE SENTIMENTS OF UNDER BORDERS.
I REALLY THINK THAT THIS ORDER
IS FIRST RATE AND HAS A
FANTASTIC REPUTATION.
AND WHEN WE PLACE THESE KINDS OF
DIFFICULT MATTERS IN THE HANDS
OF THE AUDITOR.
HER TRACK RECORD HAS BEEN. TO
FIND OUT THE INFORMATION
NECESSARY AND TO REALLY GET
TRUSTWORTHY INFORMATION.
THAT YOU MENTIONED --
THAT I GUESS YOU HAD A PERIOD OF
TIME IT FRESNO UNIFIED AND OUT --
I WOULD JUST SUGGEST THAT --
GIVEN SOME OF THE CAN OF US IN.
FRESNO CALIFORNIA WITH RESPECT
FRESNO.
UNIFIED THAT THERE IS I THINK A
SIGNIFICANT QUESTION ABOUT.
THIS PARTICULAR SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND HOW IT GOT INTO THIS MESS.
AND IF THIS IS AN ADDITIONAL
OVERLAY.
WELL TOUGH --
SO I'M GOING TO I WAS INTENDING
TO EITHER NOT VOTE ON THIS.
BECAUSE OF THE DUPLICATION AND
BEAT BUT QUITE FRANKLY I THINK
YOU GOT TO GET DOWN TO TO TO HOW
DID THIS HAPPEN GO BACK DEEP
INTO IT --
IF IT GETS THAT IF IF IT GETS A
LITTLE BIT ON THE WAY FROM.
MAY I THINK THIS AUDITOR HAS THE
SENSITIVITY IN THE
PROFESSIONALISM --
TO MOVE IT FORWARD WITHOUT
GETTING IT IN THE WAY.
AND JUST A LITTLE.
POINT OF CONCERN HERE BASED ON
THE FRESNO EXPERIENCE.
WE REALLY WANT TO KNOW.
THE EXTENT TO WHICH THERE'S BEEN
A SIGNIFICANT FAILURE TO UTILIZE
FEDERAL MONEY THAT'S A BIG
QUESTION THAT THAT HAS TO HAVE
SOME ANSWERS NUMBER.
ONE AND NUMBER TWO YES THERE
WERE CONTRACTS I GUESS IN THE
THICK MAT THAT SAID QUOTE
UNQUOTE ON AFFORDABLE.
BUT I ALSO THINK WE NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT THE PROCESSES OF HIRING
ADMINISTRATORS BULKING UP THAT
THAT THE TOP END WHILE --
THE SCHOOL --
AT THE DESK IN FOR STUDENTS.
IT BEGINS TO BE UPSIDE DOWN SO
I'VE I'VE SENT TO CHANGE MY MIND
I'M GOING TO VOTE FOR THIS AUDIT
I DON'T THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
GET IN THE WAY.
AND I THINK YOU BETTER DO SOME
REAL SERIOUS WORK BETWEEN.
NOW AND I GUESS IN IN JUNE FOR
THE SAKE OF THE KIDS THAT YOU.
REPRESENT --
AND SO I'M GONNA BUT I ON THIS --
MORLOCK.
THANK YOU RICHARD I APOLOGIZE
FOR NOT LISTENING TO THE ENTIRE
PRESENTATION I'M ON ANOTHER
COMMITTEE THAT'S LOOKING AT THE
FUTURE THE STATE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION SO WE APPRECIATE
THE TIME YOU ARE HERE THANK ARE
NOT PLEASE PROCEED.
MISTER CHAIR I SERVED ON THE FOR
THE BY PRIOR YEARS SAID THIS
ROLE ON THE SENATE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW. TWENTY SEVEN ONE WHICH
OVERSEES EDUCATION.
AND SO I SPENT SOME TIME.
YOU KNOW GETTING INTO THIS ROLE --
BUT LAST YEAR WE DECIDED TO GET.
ALL THE KAFIRS THE COMPREHENSIVE
ANNUAL FINANCIAL REPORTS FOR ALL
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND JUST SEE WHAT WE COULD FIND
THEY'RE NOT EASY TO GET MISTER
CHAIR THE NOT ALWAYS ON THE
WEBSITE SO IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING BUT IN OUR ROLE AS
LEGISLATORS WE NEED.
TO LOOK AT DETAILS LIKE THIS
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T MANAGE
SOMETHING IF YOU DON'T MEASURE
IT.
SO WE TOOK ALL THE COMPREHENSIVE
IN YOUR MIND ONE NUMBER THAT WAS
THAN.
THE NET UNRESTRICTED POSITION IT
SHOULD BE NET ASSETS BUT FOR TWO
THIRDS IT WAS.
NET DEFICIT.
AND SO -- WE
HAVE.
SOME SERIOUS ISSUES FACING.
THIS LEGISLATURE I BELIEVE IN
THE FUTURE.
AND AND AND IF THE OUT OF THE
NINE HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
SACRAMENTO CITY PLACED --
EIGHT HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN IT'S
IT'S NEAR THE BOTTOM.
THAT'S BY TAKING THEIR
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT AND
DIVIDING IT BY THEIR POPULATION.
WE DID THE DID THAT FOR ALL THE
DISTRICT INCLUDING LA UNIFIED
PRESS TRY TO SEE WERE BEING
EVERYONE IS BUT IF YOU LOOK AT
SACRAMENTO CITY.
AND YOU JUST LOOK AT THE SIZE OF
THAT OF THE UNRESTRICTED THAT
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS.
PLACE THEM SIX FROM THE BOTTOM
THEY'RE JUST ABOVE FRESNO.
L. A. U. S. D. SAN DIEGO U. S.
D. SAN FRANCISCO UST AND LONG
BEACH UST.
SO WE HAVE A DISTRICT LIKE LA
UNIFIED WHICH JUST CAME OUT WITH
THEIR COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL
FINANCIAL REPORT FOR JUNE.
THIRTY EIGHTEEN THEY HAD TO PUT
ON THEIR BALANCE SHEET FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS [inaudible]
OF UNFUNDED RETIREE MEDICAL
BENEFITS.
THAT'S MORE THAN TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER STUDENT.
SO WE'VE GOT SOME SERIOUS ISSUES
WE CAN LOOK.
AT ONE DISTRICT AND IT'S ALREADY
BEEN LOOKED AT BY VIC MATT.
OBVIOUSLY BUT BUT WE HAVE A
SYSTEMIC ISSUE THAT WILL BE
FACING ALL OF US.
AS IF FIX MATT HAS TO MAKE LOANS
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND WE'RE TALKING LA UNIFIED IF
WE HAVE TO MAKE THEM A TEN
BILLION DOLLAR LOAN.
I DON'T KNOW OR WE FIND THAT
MONEY.
WE JUST KIND OF WIPED OUT
ALREADY THE BAND AND UNDER PROP
NINETY EIGHT WE HAVEN'T EVEN SET
ASIDE A DOLLAR FOR THE READY
THEY FUND FOR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OF OUT MISTER CHAIR I
I I WOULD HOPE THIS IS A
POSITIVE THING THAT IS IN A
STALLING THING --
BECAUSE THESE ISSUES ARE VERY
CRITICAL AND AND THEY WILL BE
KNOCKING AT YOUR BECAUSE THE
CAPPERS FOR JUNE THIRD.
INCLUDED IN AND SOME OF THESE
NUMBERS.
WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN THEM YET IT'S
IT'S IT'S MARCH.
AND WE'VE GOT CPA'S PROBABLY
WAITING FOR ACTUARIAL REPORTS
BUT BUSH SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE
IN DECEMBER SO WE'RE WE'RE
FINDING.
REAL ON DELAYS IN IN THIS
INFORMATION BUT I THINK THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT ITEM IN BUT IT BUT
WE CAN'T JUST LOOK AT ONE WE GOT
NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN.
PROVIDERS ARE VAST --
BALLS ON ON TO THE OTHERS TO
HELP US HELP THEM.
THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU SIR MORE LIKE FOR
SHOULD THOSE COMMENTS WE KNOW
THAT -- THIS
AUDIT REQUEST EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
LOOKING ONLY AT SACRAMENTO
UNIFIED --
DOES HAVE IMPLICATIONS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS UP AND DOWN THE
ENTIRE STATE AND SO --
WILL BE LOOKING FOR TO THE
RESULTS SHOULD DECIDE TO MOVE
FORWARD BUT DEFINITELY.
YOUR NOTE SIR ARE WELL TAKEN.
OKAY AT THIS TIME WE ASK IF
THERE'S ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
FROM THE DíAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THIS HOW.
IF THIS AUDIT IS IS APPROVED --
DOES IT IN ANY WAY --
STOP OR HINDER.
THE STATE.
FROM TAKING OVER THIS LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT IF BY NOVEMBER
OF OF THIS YEAR THE OUT OF MONEY
MEANING.
IF IF THE SUPERINTENDENT CANNOT
MAKE ENOUGH CUT.
BYE BY NOVEMBER AND IT GOES INTO
INSOLVENCY WILL YOUR AUDIT AT
THAT TIME --
HINDER THE STATE AND THINKING
THIS OVER.
NO OUR AUDIT WOULDN'T HINDER ANY
CALIFORNIANS CERTAINLY
LEGISLATURE --
DECIDES WITH RESPECT TO SEX CITY
UNIFIED WE WOULD BE ABLE --
TO IF WE IF IT'S APPROVED AND
WHERE.
WITH A MAY FIRST START DATE --
WE WILL BE SENSITIVE AS WE HAVE
BEEN IN THE PAST TWO ENTITIES
THAT ARE IN THE MIDST OF TRYING
TO DEAL WITH THEIR BUDGET.
SITUATION AND TRYING TO MAKE
CUTS AND ONE THING THAT MY
OFFICE CAN DO IS AS MR MCCARTY
INDICATED HE'S ASKED US TO LOOK
AT FIVE YEARS.
SO WE CAN START BY LOOKING FIVE
YEARS AGO GIVE US YOUR BUDGET
YOUR KAFIRS FROM A FEW YEARS AGO
AND STAFF CAN BE DOING ANALYSIS
ON THAT WORK.
AND NOT REALLY FOCUSING ON THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR THAT THE
DISTRICT IS TRYING TO DEAL WITH
SO WE WOULD BE ABLE TO STAGE OUR
WORK SO TO SPEAK --
TO AVOID ANY INTERFERENCE WITH
WHAT THE DISTRICT IS ATTEMPTING
TO DO AT THIS TIME --
BUT MR DEEP THERE.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING OUR AUDITS
WOULD NOT HAVE ANY --
NEGATIVE IMPLICATIONS ON ANY
FUTURE DECISIONS RELATED TO THE
DISTRICT AS FAR AS THE DISTRICT
BEING TAKEN OVER IF IT IN FACT
ENDS UP BEING INSOLVENT LATER
THIS YEAR.
EARLIER YOU HAD MENTIONED THAT --
IT WOULD.
HOW LONG IS THAT IN TERMS OF
LIKE WEEKS AND MONTHS A TWENTY
FOUR HUNDRED OUR AUDIT WILL TAKE
US ABOUT SIX MONTHS TO COMPLETE?
BASED ON A A TYPICAL AUDIT TEAM
NOW ONE THING WE WILL DO AND THE
SENATE OR BOARD JUST ASK THE
QUESTION.
SOME OF THE AUDITS THAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT REFERRED --
TO OUR AUDITS OF PROBABLY THE
MOST RECENT FISCAL YEAR SO FOR
EXAMPLE I THINK HE MENTIONED
CROW THEY'RE ISSUING AN AUDIT --
OR AN OPINION ESSENTIALLY ON THE
DISTRICTS FINANCIAL STATEMENTS --
FOR SIX SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THEY
ISSUED THAT THAT OUGHT SO THAT'S
A ONE YEAR LOOK THE FEDERAL
COMPLIANCE WORK THAT HE REFERRED
TO THAT'S TYPICALLY LOOKING AT
THE MOST RECENT YEAR.
USE OF FEDERAL FUNDS AND MAKING
SURE THAT THE THE USE OF THOSE
FUNDS IS IN ACCORDANCE WITH
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS IT WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY LOOK AT WHY WAS
THERE FEDERAL MONEY LEFT ON THE
TABLE WHY WAS THERE FEDERAL
MONEY RESEARCH RETURN BACK TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
SO THERE ARE ASPECTS OF THE WORK
THAT MR MCCARTY IS ASKING US TO
DO THAT ARE VERY SEPARATE AND
DISTINCT FROM WHAT HAS CURRENTLY
BEEN DONE.
BY SOME OF THE ENTITIES A
SUPERINTENDENT MENTIONED AND I
THINK ONE OF THE KEY ISSUES IS
LOOKING AT A FIVE YEAR WINDOW
AND AGAIN WE WILL DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO ALLOW THE DISTRICT TO
CONDUCT.
THE WORK IT NEEDS TO DO TRY TO
RIGHT THE SHIP IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS --
AND WE CAN START BY LOOKING AT
PRIOR YEARS --
SO THAT WE WE DO ALLOW THE THEY
NEED TO MAKE.
HOPEFULLY THAT ANSWERS QUESTIONS
MEMBERS HAD THANK YOU THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE THAT APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SENSITIVITY
AROUND --
THE MAY FIRST JUNE BUDGET --
DEADLINE DISCUSSIONS INSIDE
THAT'S TIME WE ASK THERE'S
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE ON
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
HEARING AND SEEING NONE WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT IF
YOU COULD PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO TWO MINUTES OR LESS
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT.
PLEASE BEGIN BY STATING YOUR
NAME.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
BROWN BUT HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION --
I WOULD JUST SAY --
BRIEFLY THE THE SUPERINTENDENT
MENTIONED THAT THERE WERE CUTS
THAT HAD BEEN --
UNDERTAKEN IN SEX CITY THIS YEAR
I'M NOT WERE AWARE OF ANY CUTS
THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN IN SAC CITY
THIS YEAR AND WHAT ARE YOUR
SUPPORT --
TO BRING SOME SUNSHINE TO WHAT'S
BEEN HAPPENING OVER THE PAST
FIVE YEARS AND SEXY UNIFIED
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS DAVID FISHER --
PRESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO CITY
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION ALSO A
PARENT OF TWO CHILDREN THE
DISTRICT AND A SECOND GRADE
TEACHER FOR ALMOST TWENTY YEARS
AND ON BEHALF OF THE ALMOST
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED MEMBERS OF
THE SECOND CITY TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION FOR THIS YOU AND
WE STRONGLY URGE --
AT A IS SUPPORT THIS AUDIT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS PER A NON I
WILL RETURN BACK --
TO MEMBERS ON THE DíAS AND ASK.
MR MCCARTY IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE JERRY I I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE THE DISCUSSION
HERE THAT YOU KNOW THE STAKES
ARE REALLY HIGH FOR THIS ISSUE
THIS IS.
OUR KIDS OUR FUTURE IT'S ABOUT
PROTECTING OUR CLASSROOMS WE
DON'T DO ANYTHING THAT ADVERSELY
IMPACTS THE CLASSROOMS WERE.
MY KIDS GO TO SCHOOL FORTY
THOUSAND SACRAMENTO KIDS GO TO
SCHOOL IN THIS DISTRICT AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION.
GOING FORWARD FOR THE DECISION
MAKERS TO MAKE SOUND POLICY
DECISIONS THERE'S A LOT OF
DISTRUST AS FAR AS THE
INFORMATION TO DATE AS NOTED.
OUR AUDITOR HAS A STERLING
REPUTATION SO I THINK THIS WILL
HELP IN FUTURE BUDGET DID
DECISIONS FROM THIS.
A SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE SCHOOL
BOARD --
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
MOVE AND WORK WITH THE
SUPERINTENDENT AND SCHOOL BOARD
EVERY ENTITY INVOLVED. TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE DOING THE BEST FOR
THE STUDENTS --
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT GOING
TO BE AN ISOLATED DOWN THE
ENTIRE STATE THAT ARE DEALING IN
GRAPPLING WITH SOME OF THESE
ISSUES AS WELL WITH THAT I'M
RECOMMENDING AND I MISTER
SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL --
LOTION.
SLASH MY WRISTS PATTERSON SECOND
MY MISTER ROTH.
MISTER SECRETARY KALRA.
THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE AUDIT
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
DASH ONE OH EIGHT SACRAMENTO
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS HI.
SALAS HI BOERNER HORVATH HI
BOERNER HORVATH I DEEP
[inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WOULD.
WOULD I SENATOR ROBB.
SENATOR ROTH AYE FORGES.
FORGES I DORADO.
DORADO AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE MONNING.
MOORLACH.
MOORLACH I WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
OKAY THAT.
THAT MOTION CARRIES AND THAT'S
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS
WILL BEGIN AFTER MAY FIRST
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY AT THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA
MOVE.
TO LIVE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
NOW.
SO BELIEVE WE'RE GONNA START
WITH.
THERE IS SIR WITH ASSEMBLY WOMAN --
RUBIO THIS IS AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
FOUR TWO ZERO ONE NINE DASH.
ONE ZERO TWO DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS QUALIFIED
MEDICAL EVALUATOR PROGRAM --
THIS RUBIO WHEN YOU ARE READY TO
BEGIN PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER TERM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT THIS AUDIT HERE TODAY.
I AM --
PROPOSING DECIDED BECAUSE THERE
IS CLEAR AND CONVINCING EVIDENCE
THAT THE DIVISION OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION THE D. WC.
HAS MISMANAGED A VITAL QUALIFIED
MEDICALLY GRAHAM.
THIS MISMANAGEMENT HAS CAUSED
HARM TO CALIFORNIA'S INJURED
WORKERS EMPLOYERS AND PHYSICIANS.
THE PLUMMETING NUMBER OF Q.
ENEMIES IN THE FACE OF SURGING
DEMAND HAS RESULTED IN
UNACCEPTABLE DELAYS IN INJURED
WORKERS BEING SEEN BY TWO I MEAN.
Q. M. E. PHYSICIANS THIS MEANS
LONGER WAITS FOR INJURED WORKERS
ODD TO HAVE THEIR CLAIMS
ADJUDICATED RESULTING IN MORE
COST AND INCREASE PRODUCTIVITY
FOR EMPLOYERS AND INEFFICIENCIES.
FOR THE WORKERS COMPENSATION
SYSTEM AS A WHOLE.
A D. W. C.'S MISMANAGEMENT HAS
OCCURRED IN TWO CRITICAL WAYS
BUT BEFORE WE GET INTO THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
THE LACK OF FUNDING FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS I WAS A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER AND OUR WORKERS
COMPENSATION --
WAS ABOUT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR AND HAVING THESE DELAYS
ALSO AFFECTS.
EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS MORNING BUT
THE FIRST THE FIRST THING I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT IS D. W. C. HAS
FAILED TO REVISE THE FEE
SCHEDULE UNDER WHICH YOU ARE ME
PHYSICIANS ARE REIMBURSED FOR
OVER THIRTEEN YEARS.
THE WC IS REQUIRED UNDER LABOR
CODE FIVE THREE ZERO SEVEN POINT
SIX TWO REGULARLY REVISED SECURE
ME FEE SCHEDULE YET THAT HAS NOT
DONE SO SINCE THE IPHONE WAS
INVENTED.
THE LAST TIME THE FEE SCHEDULE
WAS REVISED WAS TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX JEREMY DOCTORS HAVE.
BEEN LEAVING THE SYSTEM FOR
YEARS AS THEY ARE NOT INTERESTED
IN WORKING FOR TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX WAGES.
D. W. C.'S FAILURE TO REGULARLY
REVISED TWO ENEMIES.
REIMBURSEMENTS AND ITS
IMPLEMENTATION HAS DECIMATED THE
QUEUE IN A SYSTEM WHEREAS THERE
WERE OVER FOUR THOUSAND Q. AMY
PHYSICIANS PERFORMING THESE
IMPORTANT EVALUATIONS WHEN THE
PROGRAM BEGAN IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SIX THERE ARE NOW
APPROXIMATELY ONLY.
TWO THOUSAND SO WE WENT FROM
FOUR THOUSAND DOWN TO TWO
THOUSAND DURING THE TIME DURING
THIS TIME FRAME THE DEMAND FOR
CURING ME PHYSICIANS HAS MORE
THAN DOUBLED FROM --
SIXTY THOUSAND PANEL REQUESTS IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SIX TO OVER A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN ADDITION
BEGINNING IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN D. W. C.
BEGAN TO IMPLEMENT UNDERGROUND
REGULATIONS WHICH RESULTED IN
TWC'S THIS MISSING HUNDREDS OF
CURE ME PHYSICIANS FROM THE
PROGRAM ON THE BASIS OF DO D. W.
C.'S FALSE ALLEGATIONS.
OF OVERBILLING AND THE REASON
ARE IN THE RESULT IN LITIGATION
A SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE IN LOS
ANGELES FOUND THE D. WC WAS
ENGAGING IN UNDERGROUND
REGULATIONS AND WAS DEPRIVING Q.
AMY PHYSICIANS OF THEIR DUE
PROCESS.
RIGHT TO A HEARING SINCE THE
LAWSUIT D. W. C. HAS CONTINUED
TO ENGAGE IN FURTHER UNDERGROUND
REGULATIONS IN ORDER TO CONTINUE.
TO MANUFACTURE FALLS FINDINGS OF
OVERBUILDING AGAINST YOU AND ME
PHYSICIANS.
THIS AUDIT THIS AUDIT IS TIMELY
AND VALUABLE BECAUSE THEY WILL
IDENTIFY THE ROOT CAUSES OF ON
GOING BECAUSE OF D. W. C.'S
MISMANAGEMENT OF THE KI<c.cyan> JOIN</c>
ME PROGRAM.
I HOPE TO LEARN WHERE THINGS
HAVE GONE WRONG FOR SO LONG WITH
THE Q. AMY PROGRAM SO THAT WE
CAN QUICKLY IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS
THESE ROOT CAUSES.
FIXING THE QUEUE ANY PROGRAM
WILL PROVIDE RAPID BENEFIT FOR
ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S WORKERS
COMPENSATION SYSTEM [inaudible]
THANK AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
RIGHT SOMEONE EVER AGREED YOU
HAVE WITNESSES.
AT THIS TIME WE MOVED HERE
WITNESSES AND AND SUPPORT THANKS --
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU --
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
NECKLACE ROXBOROUGH AND I'M WITH
THE LAW FIRM OF ROCKS FOR
APARTMENTS NINE AGE RUNNING LOS
ANGELES.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO MENTIONED.
THE LAWSUIT --
THAT OCCURRED THEY WERE IN FACT
TO RETURN MAN DAMOS WHICH ARE
HIGHLY TECHNICAL LEGAL PLEADINGS.
THEY AROSE BECAUSE MY OFFICE
RECEIVED NUMEROUS CALLS FROM
HIGHLY.
HIGHLY QUALIFIED Q. ARMIES I'M
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO WERE.
SHARES.
OF ORTHOPEDICS CHAIR CHAIRS OF
THE HEART SURGERY ORGANIZATIONS
AFFAIRS HOSPITALS WHO ARE BEING
THREATENED.
BY FOLKS OF THE D. W. SAY.
AND WE LOOKED INTO THAT.
AND AFTER A COUPLE MONTHS
DETERMINED THAT THE HEY THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT
HAD BEEN VIOLATED [inaudible]
REGULATIONS.
HAVE BEEN PASSED WITH OUT GOING
THROUGH THE NORMAL PROCESS.
I MET WITH THE D. WC I MET WITH
THE D. I. R..
OR ATTEMPTED TO MEET AND TALK TO
THEM AND I SAID YOU FOLKS FOR
ENGAGE IN UNDERGROUND
REGULATIONS.
THEY SAID THEY DIDN'T BELIEVE SO
SO LAWSUITS WERE FILED.
AND WE PREVAILED.
AND WE PREVAILED ON TWO VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUES WHICH IS WHY
THIS AUDIT IS SO IMPORTANT.
THE Q. ARMIES ARE SORT OF THE
THAT THE THE SPOKE IN THE WHEEL
OF WORKERS COMP.
WHEN INJURED WORKERS THERE'S A
DISPUTE AS TO THE NATURE EXTENT
OF THEIR INJURY YOU GET
QUALIFIED MEDICAL EXAMINERS TO
DETERMINE A CONTESTED ISSUE?
WITH Q. ARMIES LEAVING THE
SYSTEM WHICH IS WHAT I WAS TOLD
WAS GOING ON WITH ORTHOPEDICS
LEAVING THE SYSTEM AND SO ON WE
ARE ASKED TO BRING AN INJECTION
BECAUSE WHAT THE CUBANS WERE
APPLYING FOR RE APPOINTMENTS
THEY WERE BEING DENIED HEARINGS.
I READ THE ADMINISTRATIVE
DIRECTORS MARCH FIRST LETTER TO
THE CHAIR.
AND MR PIERCE SOTO WHO IS NOW
THE ADMINISTRATIVE DIRECTOR --
IDENTIFIED AN APPEAL PROCESS IN
THAT LETTER.
JUDGE CHAO FAN OUT IN A FEBRUARY
SIXTH AND I HAVE RECORDS OF THE
COMMITTEE WOULD WANT.
THE TRANSCRIPTS FROM THE
FEBRUARY SIXTH HEARING OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HE SAID TO THE
WC I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
BUT YOU CANNOT MAKE QUALIFIED
MEDICAL EXAMINERS WAIT SIX AND
EIGHT MONTHS WHICH HAVE BEEN THE
CASE.
THEN NOT GIVE MANY HEARING DATES.
THEN SAY IT'S GONNA TAKE FORM
MORE MONTHS TO GET A HEARING AND
WHO KNOWS WHEN YOU'RE ACTUALLY
GOING TO GET A RULING.
AND SO HE ORDERED THEM TO GIVE
US HEARINGS.
AT THE SAME TIME IT WASN'T JUST
THE OPINION OF OUR LAW FIRM BUT
WAS THE OPINION OF JUDGE CHAO
FOUGHT. ONE OF THE PREMIUM --
JUDGES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ON RENTS WHO SAID IN
MY OPINION THESE ARE UNDERGROUND
REGULATIONS AND YOU FOLKS ARE IN
TROUBLE.
IT WAS AFTER THAT OCCURRED THAT
THE D. WC MATT.
WE HIRED A MEDIATOR AND WE
SETTLE.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO TELL YOU
FOLKS THAT.
THE Q. AMIS.
AT A GERMAN FROM HARPER
[inaudible]
UCLA.
THEY HAD TO HIRE ME AND PAY ME A
FORTUNE TO DEFEND.
AND ALSO PREVENT BEING TURNED
OVER FOR THE MEDICAL LICENSING
BOARD BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T
FOLLOWING WHAT TURNED OUT TO BE.
UNDERGROUND BILLING REGULATIONS.
AND SO THIS AUDIT IS NECESSARY
IN ORDER SORT OF BACK THE
CURTAIN BUT THE D. W. C..
AND FIND OUT WHO'S REALLY BEEN
PULLING STRINGS BECAUSE THE
UNDERGROUND RIGHT REGULATIONS.
CONTINUE TO THIS DAY.
SHORTLY AFTER THE UNDERGROUND
REGULATIONS WERE WITHDRAWN THE
D. W. C. WITHIN A WEEK CAME OUT
WITH NEW REGULATIONS. FIVE
HUNDRED PAGES. FIVE HUNDRED
PAGES OF OPPOSITION WERE FILE.
AND THEY WERE WITHDRAWN.
THE ADMINISTRATIVE DIRECTOR WHO
I DON'T BELIEVE WAS THE MYSTERY
DIRECTOR AT THE TIME APPEARED IN
FRONT SHE SAID AND WAS.
WAS TOLD BY AND SHE WAIT TO HAVE
STAKEHOLDER MEETS AND COME UP
WITH.
REGULATIONS THAT ARE FAIR AND
EQUITABLE TO THE INJURED WORKER
IN THE QUEUE AMIS.
WE STILL DON'T HAVE THAT.
BUT ONE THING THAT THAT I WAS
HAPPY TO NOTICE THERE'S NO
DISPUTE AS TO WHY THIS AUDIT
SHOULD TAKE PLACE AND THERE'S NO
DISPUTE.
THAT AN AUDIT SHOULD TAKE PLACE
BECAUSE THE ADMINISTRATIVE
DIRECTOR AT THE END OF HIS
LETTER HAS SAID.
HE WILL FULLY COMPLY AND COOPER
AND ANY REVIEW AND THE ONLY
THING HE ****.
IF THIS COMMITTEE WOULD ALSO
RECOMMEND THAT THE AUDITOR.
LOOK AT FRAUD ON THE QB'S PART
WHICH PERSONALLY.
NO OBJECTION TO BECAUSE IF THERE
IS FRAUD AND CUMAE SYSTEM.
ABSOLUTELY THAT CAN BE PART OF
THE AUDIT.
BUT IT IS UNDERSTOOD IT IS
UNCONTESTED.
BY EVEN ADMINISTRATIVE DIRECTOR
BECAUSE HE SAYS HE WILL FULLY
COOPERATE.
SO LET'S GET THIS AUDIT LET'S
FIND OUT WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON
BECAUSE I SERVE PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT REQUEST.
I HARDLY GOT ANYTHING AND NOW I
SEE IN THE IN THE LETTER OF
MARCH FIRST THAT THERE WERE
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
EMAILS.
LASTLY VERY QUICKLY.
WHEN THE BILLING?
DEMANDS WERE MADE OF MY CLIENTS
THE DOCTORS.
MY DOCTORS HAVE A CHOICE PAY
ROCKS WERE A BUNCH OF MONEY.
OR CUT A DEAL MOST SOMEONE
DECIDE TO CUT A DEAL DO YOU KNOW
WHERE THAT MONEY GOES.
IT DOESN'T GO TO THE D. WC OR
THE AGENCY THE COAST FOR THE
CARRIERS.
SO THE D. WC WHO BY THE WAY
HIRED INTERNALLY AND PUT SIX
LAWYERS ON THE CASE AGAINST MY
CURE THE DOCTOR SIX LAWYERS.
THEY'RE DOING THE COLLECTION
WORK FOR THE CARRIER INDUSTRY
WHO BY THE WAY PAID THE BILLS
WITHOUT ANY QUESTION.
SO THE AUDIT WOULD REALLY HELP
GET SOME TRANSPARENCY IN SOME --
SOME CLARITY HELP BRING REALLY
GOOD ORTHOPEDIC DOCTORS BACK
INTO THE SYSTEM WE HAVE NO
DESIRE TO BE HARASSED.
AUDITED.
AND CHASTISE.
FOR NOT DOING SOMETHING
TECHNICALLY CORRECT WHEN THEY
CAN BE IN THE PRIVATE FIELD AND
THE INJURED WORKERS DEFINITELY
DEFINITELY NEED THEM SO THANK
YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND I ASK.
THAT THE OUGHT TO BE APPROVED
AND I THINK THE SYMBOL LINK FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AT THIS TIME
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
AFFECTED AGENCIES I'M SORRY
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO THE STATE
AUDITOR'S PRESENTATION AND WILL
MOVE TO THE AGENCY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'LL KEEP IT
BRIEF.
AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO
INDICATED CHRIS COMPENSATION
LOOKING AT THE QUALIFIED MEDICAL
EVALUATOR PROGRAM AND BASICALLY
SHE'S ASKED US TO LOOK AT A FIVE
YEAR WINDOW IDENTIFY HOW MANY Q.
AMIS HAVE BEEN.
REGISTERED THROUGH THE DIVISION
OF WORKERS COMPENSATION AND HOW
WHAT IS THAT TREND LOOK LIKE
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS --
AND COMPARE THAT TO THE NUMBER
OF REQUESTS FOR THESE CALL.
HE'S QUALIFIED MEDICAL EXAMINERS
TO CONDUCT ANALYSES --
OF INJURED WORKERS AND THEN
IDENTIFY IF THERE HAS BEEN A
DECREASE WHICH IT APPEARS THERE
HAS BEEN BASED ON SOME OF THE
INFORMATION WE'VE SEEN WHAT IS A
DIVISION DOING. TO TRY TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF Q. EMMYS
AVAILABLE TO CONDUCT THESE TYPES
OF ANALYSES AND THEN TO
PARTICULAR AREAS LOOKING UP THE
PROCESS FOR APPOINTING OR RE
APPOINTING AN INDIVIDUAL AS A
CUE I ME.
THERE'S AN INITIAL APPOINTMENT
AND THEN THEY HAVE TO RENEW AND
GET REAPPOINTED I THINK IT'S
AFTER A COUPLE OF YEARS BUT BUT
THE MEMBER IS ASKING US TO LOOK
AT THAT PROCESS TO MAKE SURE IT
COMPLIES WITH LAWS.
REGULATIONS AT CENTER AND THEN
IN THE EVENT AN INDIVIDUAL'S
DENIED APPOINTMENT A
REAPPOINTMENT ASKING US TO LOOK
AT THE APPEALS PROCESS AND ARE
THE QUEUE A MAYES OR THE
CANDIDATES --
BEING GIVEN DUE PROCESS AS FAR
AS IS THE DIVISION COMPLYING
AGAIN WITH LAWS AND REGULATIONS
RELATED TO AN APPEAL OR A
COMPLAINT FILED BY.
BY A QUEUE IN ME SO ASKING US TO
LOOK AT A SAMPLE OF APPEALS.
ALSO AS SHE INDICATED SHE WANTS
US TO LOOK AT THE FEE SCHEDULE
WHEN WAS THE FEE SCHEDULE FIRST
ESTABLISHED HAS IT BEEN UPDATED
HOT WHAT PROCESS DO THEY GO
THROUGH TO DETERMINE THEY BEING
THE DIVISION.
GO THROUGH TO DETERMINE WHAT
WOULD BE THE END AND A PRO
QUALIFIED MEDICAL EXAMINER FOR
THEIR SERVICES --
AND THEN ALSO ASKING US TO LOOK
AT THE DIVISION IS THE DIVISION
IS CONDUCTING AUDITS OF Q. AMIS --
POWER THEY PRIORITIZING THEIR
DECISION MAKING AS FAR AS WHICH
AUDITS TO CONDUCT WHICH
INDIVIDUALS TO AUDIT WHAT WHAT
CLAIMS TO TAKE A LOOK AT AND
THEN AS MAYES RUBIO AND AND HER
WITNESS INDICATED LOOKING AT
SOME OF THE COLLECTIONS.
THAT THE DIVISION HAS MADE --
ASSERTIVELY ARE ALLEGEDLY ON
BEHALF OF THE INSURANCE CARRIER
SO LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
FUNDING A RELATED --
TO THE QUEUE AT MAYES AND THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY THE AUDIT IS
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED HOURS
IT WOULD TAKE US ABOUT SIX
MONTHS TO COMPLETE THE WORK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU THIS TIME --
MOVED TO THE AFFECTED STATE
AGENCIES I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
COUPLE HERE TODAY.
SO VEGAS CAN APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE IDENTIFY YOURSELVES
WHICH AGENCY OR WITH WE
APPRECIATE THAT [inaudible]
PLEASE BEGIN.
CHECK MY WATCH GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GEORGE
PEREZ SAID ON THE ADMINISTRATIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
WORKERS COMPENSATION.
I CAN'T SAY THAT I'VE ARGUED A
CASE IN COURT IN QUITE AWHILE --
AND WHILE I DISAGREE WITH MANY
OF THE ASSERTIONS THAT WERE JUST
MADE I WILL SAY I DO AGREE.
THAT WE SHOULD GO FORWARD AND
CONDUCT THIS AUDIT AND WE WILL
COME WILL COOPERATE CERTAINLY
COOPERATE WITH ANY DECISION YOU
MAKE REGARDING THIS REQUEST AND
WE ARE PREPARED TO ANSWER.
ANY QUESTIONS THERE MAY BE OR
SHARING ANY DOG GUARDING THE
QUEUE IN THE PROGRAM I BELIEVE
THE DIVISION HAS ADMINISTERED
THIS PROGRAM IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THE MANDATES OF THE LEGISLATURE.
IT CERTAINLY IS WORTH LOOKING AT
THE NUMBER OF Q. IN THESE THAT
WE HAVE IN OUR SYSTEM TO TRY TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THEY CAN
ADEQUATELY SERVE OUR INJURED
WORKERS.
AND WE NEED TO IDENTIFY THE
REASONS FOR THESE DECLINING
NUMBERS I THINK IT'S REALLY EASY
TO SAY THAT OUR ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS HAS RESULTED IN THE
CLAIM NUMBERS A Q. ENEMIES.
BUT WE DO NEED TO CONSERVE GIVE
CONSIDERATION OTHERFACTORS NO
STATEWIDE SHORTAGE OF PHYSICIANS
AND MAYBE YOU'VE SEEN REPORTS IN
THE MEDIA LATELY ABOUT THAT.
IN THIS SHIFT IN THE WAY
MEDICINE IS PRACTICED MANY
PHYSICIANS ARE NOW WORKING FOR
LARGER HEALTH CARE GROUPS THAT
DO NOT ALLOW THEIR PHYSICIANS.
TO TO CONDUCT Q. IN THE
EVALUATIONS SOME ONLY LIMIT
THEIR PHYSICIANS TO ABOUT TWENTY
MINUTES PER PATIENT AND THAT'S
TOTALLY INADEQUATE FOR OUR
SYSTEM.
WE ALSO HAVE TO LOOK AT THE FACT
THAT A LARGE NUMBER OF OUR
PHYSICIANS IN Q. INCLUDING OUR
Q. IN THESE ARE REACHING
RETIREMENT AGE AND JUST LEAVING
THE SYSTEM.
THERE ARE MANY FACTORS WE NEED
TO TAKE THAT ALL INTO
CONSIDERATION AND I WILL SAY
INCLUDING OUR ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS AND A FOR Q. ME HAS LEFT
OUR SYSTEM BECAUSE OF THE FEAR
THAT THEY WILL BE IDENTIFIED AS
AS AS ABUSING OUR BILLING
PRACTICE AND THEY HAVE AND
THEY'VE LEFT.
THE SYSTEM OF AND I THINK THAT'S
FINE. ONE THING IS CERTAIN OUR
Q. ENEMIES HVE MORE AND MORE
WORK THE NUMBER OF HANDLE
REQUESTS THAT WE'VE RECEIVED FOR
Q. IN THE EVALUATIONS HAVE GONE
UP.
SUBSTANTIALLY FROM ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PER YEAR IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN TO ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND LAST
YEAR.
IN THIS.
EXIST DESPITE THE FACT THAT
SENATE BILL EIGHT SIXTY THREE
WHICH CAME INTO EFFECT IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN IT REMOVED
MEDICAL TREATMENT DISPUTES FROM
THE CUE I MEANS FROM AN AREA OF
Q. AMIS REVIEW.
THIS INCREASED LITIGATION IN OUR
SYSTEM MAY BE AT THE HEART OF
THIS PROBLEM REGARDLESS AS I SAY
ALL THESE FACTORS NEED TO BE
CONSIDERED WE WILL CERTAINLY A
SYSTEM EXAMINING THIS MATTER.
THE TAUGHT THERE IS TALK OF THE
FEE SCHEDULE THE DIVISION IS
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
REVISING THE MEDICAL LEGAL FEE
SCHEDULE.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE
WHAT IS REASONABLE AND WHAT IS
NOT GIVEN ALL OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE SYSTEM BUT
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF DOING
THAT WE HELD STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS LAST OCTOBER.
WE RECEIVED PROPOSALS FROM STAY
CALL THE SCHEDULE IN DECEMBER
AND WE ANTICIPATE IN THE NEXT
MONTH WE'LL CONDUCTING
ADDITIONAL MEETINGS SO THAT WE
CAN REACH THAT REASONABLE
REASONABLE COMPENSATION FOR THE
PHYSICIANS IN OUR SYSTEM WHO DO
THESE EVALUATIONS.
THE RAND CORPORATION HAS
REVIEWED OUR FEE SCHEDULE AND
FOUND IT TO BE ADEQUATE AND IN
LINE WITH OTHER STATES.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WHATEVER WE
DO MOVING FORWARD IN THIS AREA
THAT THE RULES ARE CLEAR AND THE
TYPES OF MEDICAL REPORTS THAT
NEED TO BE SUBMITTED.
IS VERY VERY OBVIOUS TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE INVOLVED IN THE
PROCESS.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY VERY
IMPORTANTLY --
PHYSICIANS GET PAID FOR THE WORK
THEY DO.
I LOOK FORWARD TO INITIATING
FORMAL RULE MAKING ON THIS
PROCESS IN THE YEAR AND HAVING
THIS INEFFECTIVE FAIRLY SOON.
WHILE I CAN'T SAY I CERTAINLY
CAN'T SAY THAT I AGREE WITH
SEVERAL THE ASSERTIONS MADE IN
THIS AUDIT REPORT IN THIS AUDIT
REQUEST ESPECIALLY THE FACT THAT
SOME OF OUR THAT THE THAT WE MAY
BE SOMEHOW CONSPIRING WITH THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT DEBATING
THESE POINTS WILL TAKE US TO THE
SOLUTIONS ARE SYSTEM NEEDS. TO
THAT END THE STATE AUDITOR IF
THIS AUDIT IS CONDUCTED CAN LOOK
AT WHAT WE HAVE AND CERTAINLY
REACH THEIR OWN CONCLUSIONS
ABOUT THE MANNER IN WHICH WE
ADMINISTER THIS PROCESS THANK
YOU AS WITH AUDITS WE HOPE
THERE'S CLARITY.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT --
TESTIMONY PLACE HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
MY NAME IS AMY WILSON ON THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY OF THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
JUST A FEW ADDITIONAL COOLEY IS
THE COMPLETE BRIEFING AT SIZE WE
APPRECIATE ABSOLUTELY --
JUST BEGIN BY SAYING THAT SHOULD
THE COMMITTEE BE ASSURED THAT
LABOR AGENCY AND THE DIVISION
ARE PREPARED TO COOPERATE AND
SUPPORT THE AUDITOR IN ITS
FULFILLMENT --
IN IN THAT SPIRIT YOU KNOW THE
DIVISION HAS SOUGHT TO BE
FORTHCOMING IN ITS RESPONSE THAT
IT SUBMITTED LAST WEEK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
ADDRESSING THE ITEMS --
IDENTIFIED IN THE AUDIT REQUEST
LETTER --
AND WE FURTHER ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONSIDER THE ADDITIONAL
INCLUSION --
OF THE ITEM WE NOTED IN THE
LETTER OF THE REVIEW OF THE
QUEUE ANY REPORTS AND
CORRESPONDING BILLINGS --
WE BELIEVE THIS AREA OF INQUIRY
WOULD SUPPORT THE MEMBERS INTENT
TO IDENTIFY PATTERNS OF
POTENTIAL ABUSE IN THE SYSTEM
FOR THE OVERALL GOAL OF ENSURING
APPROPRIATE AND TIMELY TREATMENT
OF INJURED WORKERS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL --
TESTIMONY OR COMMENTS FROM ANY
AFFECTED AGENCIES I WISH TO
SPEAK AT THIS TIME.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE I WILL
TURN IT BACK TO MEMBERS ON THE
DíAS FOR QUESTIONS WE WILL
BEGIN WITH SENATOR TO BURKE.
DON'T YOU YOU SAID THAT YOU
WOULD WELCOME THE AUDIT WHICH IS
GOOD I A QUESTION I HAVE IS.
WOULD YOU AGREE OR DISAGREE WITH
THE ASSERTIONS MADE.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY I WAS SHE
SAID YOU'RE STARTING A PROCESS
THAT YOU'VE GOT A NUMBER OF
FACTORS AT PLAY --
BUT CLEARLY YOU KNOW HAVING THE
BACKLOG WITH RESPECT TO WORKERS
COMP IT'S ALREADY TOUGH ENOUGH
AS IT IS IS NOT A GOOD THING.
IN YOUR JUDGMENT DO YOU THINK
THIS AUDIT COULD HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO HELP THAT.
IS YOU HELP GIVE US GUIDANCE AND
ALLEGE OR TO GET RID OF SOME OF
THAT BACK ON GAINES POSSIBLE
THAT COULD HAPPEN.
I THINK IT'S VERY POSSIBLE COULD
HAPPEN -- I
THINK TAKING A LOOK AT THE
SYSTEM -- IT
IS VERY TIMELY IT HAS BEEN IN
PLACE FOR A LONG TIME BUT OF
COURSE OUR SYSTEM YOUR SYSTEM IS
CHANGING.
THE PRACTICE OF MEDICINE IS
CHANGING THE NATURE OF THE
DISPUTES IN WORKERS COMPENSATION
YOU HAVE BEEN CHANGING OVER THE
YEARS AND SO I THINK IT'S I
THINK IT'S ALWAYS HEALTHY TO
LOOK AT THE PROCESSES WE HAVE.
AND SEE WHAT KIND OF
RECOMMENDATIONS WHAT
OBSERVATIONS CAN BE MADE BY A
NEUTRAL OBSERVER --
MAYBE MAYBE THAT WILL TAKE US TO
A GOOD PLACE OKAY THANKS.
CARE.
SENATOR ROTH PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU
ARE CORRECT WITH RESPECT TO THE
CHANGING NATURE OF THE PRACTICE
OF MEDICINE.
AND PHYSICIANS WHO WERE COMING
OUT OF RESIDENCY PROGRAMS.
TEND TO MIGRATE TO THE LARGER
GROUP PRACTICES.
AND NOT TO THE SMALL A GROUP
PRACTICES THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
PAST.
SO GIVEN THAT IF IF I'M RIGHT
AND IF YOU'RE RIGHT AND I THINK
WE BOTH ARE.
OF WHAT.
WHAT IS YOUR DIVISION WHAT IS
THE THE AGENCY DOING --
TO TO THINK AHEAD AND PLAN --
FOR MEDICAL EVALUATION.
UNDER THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES --
THAT'S ONE THING I WILL SAY IS
THAT THE DIVISION HAS NEVER
REALLY CONDUCTED OUTREACH IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO BRING CUBIES
INTO OUR SYSTEM.
NO WE HAVE PUT OUT AT THE
ESSENTIALLY NEWS L<c.cyan>G SAYING</c>
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A QUEUE IN
THE EXAM.
PEOPLE SHOW UP AND TAKE THE EXAM
AND I MUST SAY I KNOW I WILL
CERTAINLY SAY THE QUEUE IT MEANS
THAT WE HAVE IN OUR SYSTEM --
ARE ARE EXCELLENT PHYSICIANS --
BUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS WE
NEED TO START LOOK GOOD GOING
BEYOND THAT --
WE NEED TO START GOING TO THESE
LARGER MEDICAL GROUPS AND SEEING
HOW WE CAN INCORPORATE THEM INTO
OUR SYSTEM.
I'M I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE A
VALUABLE STEP FORWARD AND I AND
I REALLY WANT TO WORK IN THAT
DIRECTION --
THANK YOU MISTER I LOOK FORWARD --
TO SEEING WHAT THE STATE AUDITOR
FINDS ASSUMING THIS REQUEST IS
APPROVED.
THANK YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I APPRECIATE --
SALOON RUBIO WORKING WITH OUR
STAFF AND THE SCOPE IN CRAFTING
OF THE LETTER --
DELVING INTO SOME OF THESE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
BY THE AGENCIES AS WELL WE'VE
KNOW THAT Q. AND ME'S.
AT ONE POINT WE HAD --
A LARGE NUMBER OF THEM SWITCH
MEANT WORKERS WERE ABLE TO SEE A
QUALIFIED MEDICAL EXAMINER.
WE KNOW THOSE NUMBERS OF DIDN'T
DECREASED I BELIEVE AN AUDIT
WILL SHED SOME LIGHT AS TO WHAT
CAN BE DONE TO MAKE SURE THAT
INJURED WORKERS AREN'T WAITING.
UNNECESSARILY LONGER THAN THEY
NEED TO BE --
AND MAYBE WE COULD IDENTIFY SOME
BEST PRACTICES MOVING FORWARD TO
INFORM THE LEGISLATURE AS WE
BEGIN OUR BUDGET DISCUSSIONS AND
SUCH FORTH --
MOVING FORWARD WITH THAT LET ME
ASK ASSEMBLY WOMAN REVIEW IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE THIS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
AUDIT ALRIGHT LET ME ASK IF
THERE'S ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
THIS ISSUE BEFORE WE MOVE TO A
VOTE.
HEARING AND SEEING NANA HOW
RETURN IT BACK TO THE DíAS ASK
FOR IS THERE A MOTION ON THIS
ITEM.
THE MOTION BY MISTER WORD
SECONDED BY MISTER HERTZBERG --
THE STRUCTURE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO APPROVE AUDIT
REQUEST NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN DASH ONE OH TWO
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS QUALIFIED MEDICAL
EVALUATOR PROGRAM BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS HI.
SALAS I BOERNER HORVATH
[inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE WHAT [inaudible]
WHAT I?
CENTER ROTH I ROTH AYE FORGES
[inaudible]
DORADO.
DORADO AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG I MONEY [inaudible]
MOORLACH.
MOORLACH I WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
THE MOTION CARRIES ONLY THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS SAT
ON WITH THAT WILL NOW MOVE TO
AGENDA ITEM.
NUMBER SIX TWO ZERO ONE NINE
DASH ONE ZERO SIX STATE AGENCIES.
MANAGEMENT OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION PROGRAMS BY SENATOR
MORLOCK.
CONSIDER MORE LIKE WHEN YOU ARE
READY TO PROCEED PLEASE DO SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'LL.
DO THAT TIME I WILL KEEP THIS
BRIEF --
THIS IS NOT --
ANOTHER REQUEST AS A RESULT OF
ANYTHING I FOUND THAT --
IS OF OF OF SUPER --
IS YOUR CONCERN OTHER THAN OF MY
MOTHER WOULD ALWAYS SAY WHEN I
WAS GROWING UP YOU NEED TO SPEND
A DIME TO MAKE A QUARTER AND WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY IN ORANGE
COUNTY.
TO DO THAT WORKERS COMPENSATION
RESOLUTIONS COMBINED LARGE
AMOUNTS IN RESTRICTED BANK
ACCOUNTS TO COVER ANTICIPATED
FUTURE COSTS.
AND WE HAVE TO ASK OUR THOSE
RESERVES ADEQUATE ARE THEY TO
HIRE THE TOO LOW.
AND CAN SETTLEMENT TO BE
NEGOTIATED TO PROVIDE COVERAGE
THAT IS NECESSARY FOR THOSE THAT
ARE --
DEALING WITH ONGOING MEDICAL
ISSUES FROM WORKERS COMP RELATED --
EVENTS.
OUR OUR OUR OUR OUR DEPARTMENTS
ARE ARE IS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA UTILIZING THE BEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES.
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE RETAIN THE
LEGAL FIRM BY. THREE NEW TO ME
TO REVIEW THE STATUS OF THE
RESERVES OVERSEEN.
BY ITS RISK MANAGEMENT
DEPARTMENT.
IN AFTER IT WAS DONE OVER A
PERIOD TIME IN REDUCE RESERVES
BY FORTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
BY LEGITIMATE FAIR AND
PROFESSIONAL.
REARRANGEMENTS TO CLOSE CASES
ORANGE COUNTY'S ANNUAL BUDGET IS
ABOUT FIVE POINT FIVE BILLION SO
FORTY TWO MILLION MAY NOT BE A
LARGE AMOUNT BUT IT COMPARED TO
A STATE.
BUDGET LIKE OURS WE COULD
PROBABLY LOOK AT SAVINGS NEAR
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
OR WE FIND OUT THAT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE GREAT WORKERS COMP --
SETTLEMENT.
I ISSUES --
INSIDE THE COUNTY AND SEARCH
GIVEN BY THE STATE I I HAVE
WORKED WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA THEIR REPRESENTATIVES
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY RIVERS AND LIVES ON
THEIR RESERVES.
AND THEIR STAFF IS ASSURED ME
THAT THERE ARE --
DOING QUITE WELL BUT PERHAPS THE
STATE AUDITOR CAN USE THEM AS
BENCHMARKS OR MODELS FOR OTHERS.
AND THE STATE WORKERS
COMPENSATION --
FIND AT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE BY
THE THE APPLICANTS THOSE THAT
ARE RECEIVING THE BENEFITS AND
THE TAXPAYERS.
SO THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY MISTER
CHAIR FOR VALUE ADDING TO OUR
EFFORTS HERE AT THE STATE TO
COLLABORATE PERHAPS WITH THE
COUNTY TO SEE.
HOW IT UP HOW IT WAS A
SUCCESSFUL SO I ALSO APPRECIATE
THE AUDITOR'S BID A PROJECTED
HOURS ON THIS ASSIGNMENT HAVING
BEEN A AUDITOR MYSELF AND DOING --
TIME BUDGETS --
IT MIGHT BE A LITTLE ON THE HIGH
SIDE A BUT I BELIEVE THAT.
SHE'LL AND HER STAFF WILL FIND
OPPORTUNITIES TO GOAL IS TO FIND
OPPORTUNITIES WHERE WE CAN
BENEFIT WITH THAT COST SAVINGS
AND WE WILL HOPEFULLY FIND THAT
WE DO SPEND A DIME TO MAKE A
QUARTER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
HAVE NO WITNESSES.
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME WILL MOVE
TO THE STATE WATER PRESENTATION
ON THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AS AS CENTER MORE LUCK
INDICATED THIS IS AN AUDIT OF
WORKERS COMPENSATION CLAIMS HE
ASKED US TO SPECIFIC
SPECIFICALLY LOOK AT THE STATE
COMPENSATION INSURANCE FUND.
AND FOR DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS
THAT THE THE AND FUND OR THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATORS A SYSTEM
THAT'S FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION --
CALTRANS DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL AND REALLY LOOKING AT
THEIR PROCESSES FOR
ADMINISTERING WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS LOOKING AT
THEIR POLICIES AND PRACTICES FOR
HANDLING THOSE CLAIMS ARE THEY
COMPLYING WITH LAWS REGULATIONS
ETCETERA.
HOW EFFECTIVE ARE THOSE --
PROCESSES AND AND REALLY
HANDLING THOSE WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE AND AS EFFICIENTLY
AS POSSIBLE.
IN ADDITION OTHER SENATORS ASKED
US TO LOW AND DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT THERE ARE SOME BEST
PRACTICES OUT THERE AS FAR AS
SETTING THE RESERVE AMOUNTS.
OF FOR PAYMENT OF FUTURE CLAIMS
AND THEN HE'S ASKED US TO LOOK
AT A SAMPLE OF CLAIMS AT THE
DEPARTMENTS AND CERTAINLY AT
STATE FUND --
TO ASSESS THEIR PROCESS --
FOR HANDLING THOSE WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS FOR
PROCESSING THEM HOW TIMELY ARE
THERE HOW APPROPRIATE IS IT AND
REALLY TRYING TO IDENTIFY --
AN AVERAGE INCOME POTENTIALLY
COMPARING THAT TO INDUSTRY
STANDARDS TO SEE IF THERE ARE.
WAYS THAT THE STATE CAN BE MORE
EFFICIENT AND THESE PER AGENCIES
IN PARTICULAR CAN BE MORE
EFFICIENT IN PROCESSING WORKERS
COMPENSATION CLAIMS AND GET THE
GETTING THE PAYMENTS TO THE
INJURED WORKERS.
AND THEN THE LAST OBJECTIVE IS
ASKING US TO LOOK AT LOS RUN
REPORTS --
AND LOOKING AT THOSE REPORTS
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
TOTAL COST INCURRED THE TOTAL
BENEFITS THAT HAVE BEEN PAID ANY
OUTSTANDING RESERVES THAT HAVE
BEEN SET ASIDE FOR OPEN CLAIMS.
SOME AGING OUR REPORT SIMILAR
LOS RUN REPORTS THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN EXCEEDED A YEAR AND THOSE
THAT HAVE EXCEEDED TWO YEARS.
SO TRYING TO CAPTURE SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AGAIN
SPECIFICALLY TO THE FOUR
DEPARTMENTS THAT I MENTION OUR
BUDGET IS OUT ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED HOURS AND AS A CENTRE
INDICATED WE WILL DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN IF IT'S APPROVED. TO BE
AS EFFICIENT AS WE POSSIBLY CAN
THAT'S OUR BEST GUESS AS FAR AS
IN A BUDGET AT THIS POINT IN
TIME THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTATION AT THIS TIME WILL
MOVE TO AFFECTED AGENCIES.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A COUPLE WITH
US TODAY IF THEY'D LIKE TO JOIN
US HERE AT THE TABLE.
IF YOU CAN MAKE YOUR COMMENTS
BRIEF AND CONCISE WE APPRECIATE
THAT.
PLEASE BEGIN BY STATING YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AGENCY.
GOOD AFTERNOON UP I'LL KEEP THIS
REALLY BRIEF MY NAME IS SHONDA
ASSISTANT CHIEF FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL ON THE
US SPECIAL REPRESENTATIVE TO THE
LEGISLATURE'S COULD BE WITH YOU
TODAY.
ON THE C. H. P.'S PHILOSOPHY ON
INJURY KNOWN AS CASE MANAGEMENT
IS VERY SIMPLE PROVIDE TIMELY.
AND ACCURATE PROVISION OF
BENEFITS STORE INJURED EMPLOYEES.
AS A STATE EMPLOYER WE HAVE
INVESTED SIGNIFICANT TIME AND
ENERGY INTO DEVELOPING SOME
POLICIES PROCEDURES AND TRAINING.
TO ENSURE THAT WE ASSIST OUR
EMPLOYEES IN.
PROVIDE TIMELY MEDICAL TREATMENT
AND THEN CONDUCT ONGOING INJURY
NO IN THIS CASE MANAGEMENT. TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS WE WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE STATE FONT AND MONITOR
CLAIMS WE TAKE A PROACTIVE
WORKING ROLE WITH CASE ADJUSTERS
TO PROVIDE.
INPUT INTO PROPER CLAIM
RESOLUTION.
AT THE C. H. P. WE'RE CONSTANTLY
STRIVING TO IMPROVE DEPARTMENT --
EFFICIENCIES WE WELCOME NEW
IDEAS AND METHODS THAT WOULD
IMPROVE FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY
WITHOUT SACRIFICING THOSE
EMPLOYEE BENEFITS.
IF THE AUDIT IS APPROVED WE WILL
FULLY COOPERATE WITH THE
AUDITOR'S TEAM --
I HAVE WITH ME THE PROGRAM
MANAGER OF THAT PROGRAMMER
INJURING ON THIS CASE MANAGEMENT
HAS THIRTY YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS BUT WHICH IS CLOSE
WITH THAT.
THANK YOU NATIONAL TESTIMONY.
HI GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I AM MICHELLE TUCKER THE
CALTRANS DIVISION CHIEF FOR
HUMAN RESOURCES I'M WITH ME IS
DENNY YOST OUR ASSISTANT DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS.
SAFETY IS CALTRANS IS NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY CALTRANS IS COMMITTED
TO PREVENTING INJURY AND ILLNESS
THROUGH EVER BUSTS SAFETY
CULTURE.
CONSISTING OF POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES TRAINING STAND AT
MEETINGS AND REGULAR SAFETY
MEETINGS.
UNFORTUNATELY HIGHWAY WORK IS
ONE OF THE MOST DANGEROUS
PROFESSIONS IN THE UNITED STATES
ALWAYS STRIVE TO REDUCE INJURIES
AND FATALITIES WE ALSO CARE FOR
OUR EMPLOYEES.
WHO DO SUFFER TRAUMA AND INJURY
ON THE JOB WE PROVIDE INJURED
EMPLOYEES WITH THE RETURN TO
WORK CORD METER IT TO CONTACT
FOR QUESTIONS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
TO THEM WHILE THERE ARE OFFERED
STATUS?
WE ACCOMMODATE EMPLOYEES THROUGH
MODIFIED OR ALTERNATE DUTIES AS
NEEDED AND MEDICALLY POSSIBLE OR
DISABILITY RETIREMENT AND WE'RE
COMMITTED TO THE TIMELY PAYMENT
OF BENEFITS.
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH STATE FUNDS
TO ASSIST RECORDED WITH STATE
FUNDS TO CLOSE OUTSTANDING
CLAIMS IN BATCHES AND I'VE HAD
MUCH SUCCESS WITH THIS STRATEGY.
WE'RE ALWAYS LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
BECOME MORE EFFICIENT SB ONE
REQUIRES CALTRANS TO FIND ONE
HUNDRED MILLION INEFFICIENCIES
EVERY YEAR.
AS SUCH WE WELCOME NEW IDEAS AND
METHODS THAT WOULD IMPROVE
FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY WITHOUT
SACRIFICING EMPLOYEE BENEFITS IF
THE AUDIT IS APPROVED WE WILL
FULLY COOPERATE WITH THE AUDIT
TEAM.
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
WE ASK AT THIS TIME ADDITIONAL
AGENCIES
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS RANDY THRASH IN ON THE
MANAGER CALPERS OCCUPATIONAL
HEALTH AND WELLNESS PROGRAM.
I HAVE OVER FIFTEEN YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN THIS FIELD.
THE OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH AND
WELLNESS PROGRAM STRIDES IMPROVE
THE HEALTH WELL BEING AND
QUALITY LIFE F THOSE WE SERVE
THROUGH THE PROVISION OF
PROFESSIONAL AND PATHETIC
SUPPORT AND GUIDANCE --
OCCUPATIONAL THE ONE THIS
PROGRAM PROVIDES STATEWIDE
EXPERTISE OVERSIGHT AND
FUNCTIONAL GUIDANCE TO OUR
REGIONAL MISS RATE OF OFFICERS
AND RETURNED WORK CORNERS.
GOVERNOR MINISTERS ITS STATE --
STATEWIDE WORKER'S COMP IN
STATION PROGRAM WITH ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES DELEGATED TO
PERSONNEL AT THE UNIT REGION AND
HEADQUARTERS LEVEL.
CALVET WORKS COLLABORATIVELY
WITH STATE FUN WHEN DEVELOPING
AN ANNUAL PROGRAM GOALS
INCLUDING TARGETED INVENTORY
REDUCTION GOALS.
THE STATE FROM PROVIDES
CUSTOMIZE MONTHLY REPORTS THE
CALIFORNIA REPORTING ON OPEN AND
CLOSE CLOSED IN THE TORY
FINALIZATION ENDS AND TOTAL NEW
REPORTS.
PROVIDING YEAR OVER YEAR
COMPARISONS.
DESPITE CALIFORNIA'S DRASTICALLY
WORSE IN FIRE SEASONS CAL FIRE
WORKING IN COOPERATION WITH
STATE FUND HAS.
REALIZE A NET REDUCTION AND
DISABILITY CASE IN THE TORY OVER
THE PAST TWO YEARS --
CALPERS AGGRESSIVE STE
SETTLEMENT STRATEGY RESULTED IN
RECORD BREAKING NUMBERS SETTLE
CLAIMS DURING THE SCHOOLS YEARS
SEVENTEEN AND EIGHTEEN EXCEEDING
RECORD SET THE PREVIOUS TWO
YEARS BY TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY
FIVE AND 32% RESPECTIVELY.
FROM DECEMBER 200-016-22000
EIGHTEEN TO ON THE TORY HAS BEEN
REDUCED BY FOURTEEN POINT 6%
WILL SETTLE MAINTENANCE
INVENTORIES INCREASED. TWELVE
POINT 75%.
APPROXIMATELY 37% OF CALIFORNIA
IS OPEN IN THE TORY CONSISTS TO
OPEN MAINTENANCE CLAIMS WERE
CASES HAVE BEEN FINALIZED BUT
ONGOING BENEFITS OR DO.
LOOKING FORWARD.
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH AND WELLNESS
IS WORKING WITH STATE FUND ON A
MAINTENANCE IN THE TORY PROJECT
TARGETING CASES WERE FUTURE
LIABILITY OBLIGATIONS EXIST.
AND POTENTIALLY CAN BE SETTLED.
ALLOWING FOR REDUCTION IN COST
SAVINGS TO THE DEPARTMENT.
WE ARE CONSTANTLY LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO IMPROVE OUR PROGRAM.
WE'RE INTERESTED IN OPEN
DIALOGUE AND CONTINUES TO SERVE
THAT DISCUSSIONS REGARDING NEW
IDEAS TO IMPROVE FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY WITHOUT
SACRIFICING EMPLOYEE BENEFITS.
FOR NOT IT IS APPROVAL FULLY
COOPERATE WITH AUDITORS TEAM.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AROUND THE MYERS WHAT
STATE COMPENSATION INSURANCE
FUND AS YOU KNOW STATE FUNDED
MINISTERS THE WORKERS
COMPENSATION PROGRAM FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
STATE FUND IS NEUTRAL ON THIS
AUTO REQUEST AND WE ARE PREPARED
TO COMPLY IF NECESSARY.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY FROM.
THE FACT IS STATE AGENCIES.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE WE WILL
RETURN IT BACK --
TO QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
DIE ON THE DíAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL PLEASE.
MORE OF A QUICK EDUCATIONAL
STATEMENT --
I SUPPORT THIS STRONGLY --
HAVING BEEN IN THE INSURANCE
BUSINESS FOR MANY YEARS.
WHAT I FIND INTERESTING ABOUT
THE STATE FUND IS AT ONE TIME IN
200-022-0004 THEY HAD OVER 50%
OF THE MARKET IN CALIFORNIA?
SIMPLY BECAUSE MANY CARRIERS
LEFT THE STATE.
SO THEY WERE THE NIGHT.
ON THE SHINING ARMOR TO SAVE A
LOT OF EMPLOYERS.
THIS IS A VERY DIFFICULT FOUGHT
IT FOR YOU BAD --
BECAUSE THIS IS LIKE A GIANT
GARRIDO YOU SQUEEZE ONE IN WHICH
IS COST.
IN A POPS UP THE OTHER END WHICH
IS KEY JAMES HOW.
LONG IT TAKES YOU TO PAY SO THIS
IS A TOUGH [inaudible]
ONE I AM.
POINT OUT THAT.
THEY INSURE OVER A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND POLICY HOLDERS
IN CALIFORNIA THERE WERE THE
THIRTEENTH LARGEST OF THE TOP.
TWENTY FIVE NOW WHERE MY GOING
WITH THIS IN THE NEXT THIRTY
SECONDS I'M REMINDED EVERYONE.
THAT [inaudible]
THEY THIS ORGANIZATION IS ALSO A
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR.
ADJUSTING CLAIMS FOR ALL STATE
AGENCIES ALL RIGHT.
I AM VERY HAPPY THAT THEY'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO BEING AUDITED
BECAUSE IT A BIT TO BE A GREAT.
CHECK IN A GREAT INVESTMENT OF
OUR MONEY TO MAKE SURE.
THE RIGHT HAND IS WORKING WITH
THE LEFT HAND EFFICIENTLY
BECAUSE THERE'S NO INSURANCE
COMPANY I'M WITH WHERE OF THAT
WILL BE.
IN THE WORKERS COMP AREA A THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR ADJUSTING
ALL THE CLAIMS.
AND RUNNING THE PREMIUMS AND THE
BENEFITS AND ALSO ALL THE
BENEFIT LEVELS SO THIS IS.
BUT ACTUALLY A WONDERFUL WAY TO
JUST MAKE SURE THEY'RE DOING
BUSINESS WELL.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER VOEPEL AND I
KNOW THAT THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
ISSUES OF WE LOOKED AT ALSO AN
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO SAM.
REQUEST ALSO [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD A SECOND
BY MISTER ROTH AND BEFORE WE
MOVED TO A FINAL VOTE ON THE ASK --
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IF THERE'S
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS AUDIT
REQUEST.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE WE WILL
MOVE TO A VOTE THE THOUGHT IT
WAS MOVED BY MISTER WOOD SECOND
BY MISTER ROTH.
IT ENJOYS A I RECOGNITION FROM
THE CHAIR MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO APPROVE WATER
CLOSE NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN DASH ONE OH SIX STATE
AGENCIES MANAGEMENT OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION PROGRAMS BY SENATOR
MOORLACH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS AYE SALAS
AYE BURGER WERE BACK
[inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WOULD [inaudible]
WHAT I [inaudible]
SENATOR ROTH.
ROTH AYE FORGES [inaudible]
DORADO.
DORADO AYE HERTZBERG
[inaudible]
MONNING.
MONNING AYE MOORLACH.
WELL LIKE I WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE.
OKAY THAT MOTION HAS IS
SUFFICIENT VOTES TO MOVE FORWARD
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS AT A THANK
YOU MISTER I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO A GREAT REPORT.
WITH HIGHER AYE COMMENTS FOR
EVERYBODY.
ALL RIGHT SHE THAT APPRECIATE
YOUR EXPERTISE IN THIS AREA
BRING US TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME WILL MOVE
TO AGENDA NUMBER ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT TWO ZERO ONE NINE DASH ONE
OH NINE CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
BOARD.
CLIMATE IN THE MISSION CONTROL I
WILL HAND THE GAVEL OVER --
TO THE VICE CHAIR.
MISTER ROTH AS I BEGIN
PRESENTATION ON THIS ITEM
[inaudible]
THE PEOPLE.
MISTER CHAIR YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ON THIS
ITEM -- BUT
SURE MEMBERS AS YOU KNOW THIS IS
AN ITEM THAT I AM.
DEEPLY PASSIONATE ABOUT ITS IS
AN ITEM THAT I'VE BEEN WORKING
ON FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
AND IT'S ALL ABOUT THE EFFECTS
THAT.
THERE BE POLICIES OF HAD ON THE
MOST --
COMMUNITIES UP AND DOWN THE
ENTIRE STATE --
WITH THAT SAID YOU KNOW I AM
PREPARED TO RESUBMIT --
THE AUDIT REQUEST BASED OFF THE
ANSWERS FROM THE AGENCY AND
DISCUSSIONS I'VE HAD WITH
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AS WELL.
WHERE TO BEGIN?
I FEEL LIKE MY PASSION IS IS
OVERWHELMING ME JUST A BIT.
JUST BECAUSE OF I KEEP THINKING
OF THOSE FAMILIES THAT ARE.
THAT ARE SUFFERING THE MOST UP
AND DOWN THE ENTIRE YET I KNOW
THEY DON'T EXIST ONLY IN MY
COMMUNITIES WITH THE EXISTING
COMMUNITIES.
PROBABLY FOR EVERYONE SITTING
AROUND THE DíAS --
IT IS FOR THAT REASON WHY FOUGHT
SO HARD WITH MY COLLEAGUES --
TO ENSURE THAT THERE WERE
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES AND SOME
OF THE LEGISLATION THAT WE HAVE
PASSED ONE OF THOSE MEASURE
MEASURES WAS ASSEMBLY BILL --
THREE NINETY EIGHT BACK IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHICH I BELIEVE --
SUPERMAJORITY OF MEMBERS VOTED
FOR NOT ONLY IN THE ASSEMBLY BUT
ALSO IN THE SENATE AS WELL.
AND IN THAT WE FOUGHT VERY HARD
TO BE THE MEASURES --
TO ENSURE THAT THE POLICIES
GOING FORWARD ACTUALLY.
MADE A DIFFERENCE IN SOME OF
THESE COMMUNITIES AND WHAT WERE
THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS.
AND SO --
THREE MONTHS AGO THE ELIO
BECAUSE OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE IN ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
NINETY EIGHT ISSUED A REPORT IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT
IDENTIFIED SEVERAL ISSUES WHEN
LOOKING AT THE OVERALL ECONOMIC
IMPACTS AND BENEFITS --
LOOKING AT GHQ PROGRAMS AND A
LARGE NUMBER OF TRANSPORTATION
ADMISSION POLICIES A CARB.
LET ME STATE FOR THE RECORD --
THE COMMITMENT AND CONTINUING
EFFORT BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THEIR RESOURCES BOARD
TO IMPROVING AIR QUALITY AND
REDUCING.
GAS EMISSIONS ANOTHER CREATURE
YOUR PLANS TO IMPROVE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND MITIGATE OUR
CONTRIBUTION TO CLIMATE CHANGE
IS COMMENDABLE.
AND A LOT OF ALL GOAL.
AND IT IS WELL DESERVING OF OUR
ATTENTION AND RECOGNITION WELL
WE HAVE MADE GREAT PROGRESS
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF WORK TO
BE DONE.
THE EFFECTS OF POOR QUALITY AND
CLIMATE CHANGE OF DRAMATIC AND
LONG LASTING EFFECTS ON PUBLIC
HEALTH.
AND ON THE AND AND IN THE
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH WE LIVE.
AND AND WE KNOW THAT THESE
ACTIONS WILL NOT ONLY.
HAVE AN IMPACT ON OUR LIVES BUT
TO OUR KIDS AND SUBSEQUENT
GENERATIONS AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
CARB DESIGNATED.
FORTY FIVE OUT OF FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE AS
NON ATTAINMENT JONES TO SAY THAT
AGAIN. FORTY FIVE OUT OF THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN THE
ENTIRE STATE.
OUR IN NON ATTAINMENT.
THESE COUNTIES MAKE UP ABOUT 75%
OF THE STATE INCLUDE THOSE IN
SACRAMENTO VALLEY THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY.
THE INLAND EMPIRE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA --
AND EVEN --
SOME COUNTIES CLOSE THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA AND SOME OF
THE COASTAL REGIONS AS WELL.
AIR QUALITY THAT EXIST IN OUR
STATE RESULTS IN REAL AND
SERIOUS HEALTH RISKS TO OUR
STATE AND IN PARTICULAR TO THE
DISTRICTS AND CONSTITUENTS --
THAT I REPRESENT IN THAT MANY OF
YOU REPRESENT AS WELL.
SOME OF THESE RISKS BUT
CALIFORNIA'S AT RISK FOR
PREMATURE DEATH AND OTHER
SERIOUS HEALTH EFFECTS SUCH AS
ASTHMA.
AND LUNG CANCER.
AREAS IN A THE CENTRAL VALLEY
ARE CONSISTENTLY RANKED AS
HAVING THE WORST AIR QUALITY IN
THE STATE AND EVEN THE NATION.
KERN IN KINGS COUNTY OR
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED AS EXTREME.
pACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION THE CITY OF BIGGER
STILL RANKS WORST SECOND WORST
AND THIRD WORST IN THE NATION
FOR THREE CATEGORIES OF OUR
QUALITY.
LIVING IN POVERTY ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY EXPOSED TO
AIR POLLUTION.
HOUSEHOLDS EARNING LESS THAN
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
AND PEOPLE WHO DO NOT OWN CAR
SUFFER VEHICLE POLLUTION LEVELS.
20% HIGHER THAN THE STATE
AVERAGE.
CENTRAL BAKERSFIELD IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY HAVE THE HIGHEST
CONCENTRATION OF PARTICULATE
MATTER POLLUTION FROM VEHICLES.
OWING IN PART TO GEOGRAPHIC AND
WHETHER DIFFERENCES.
THAT RETAIN POLLUTION IN THESE
AREAS.
ROUGHLY SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ABOUT 19% OF THE
STATE POPULATION LIVE IN POVERTY.
THE SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC AND
GEOGRAPHIC FACTORS THAT
INFLUENCE OUR QUALITY AND
EMISSIONS MUST BE FACTORED INTO
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS THAT OUR
STATE HAS IMPLEMENTED TO APPROVE
AIR QUALITY.
AND ACHIEVING AIR QUALITY GOALS
FOR THE FUTURE.
THOSE WHO LIVE IN THE POOREST
REGIONS OF THE STATE AND IN
AREAS WITH THE WORST AIR QUALITY
ARE DIRECTLY LINKED.
AS WE MAKE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN ADDRESSING AIR
QUALITY IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE
EXAMINE AND UNDERSTAND THE MOST
EFFICIENT.
AND COST EFFECTIVE WAYS TO
ACHIEVE OUR THAT IS WHY I AM
REQUESTING. FOR US TO LOOK AT AN
AUDIENCE.
ON THE TRANSPORTATION POLICIES
OF THE PROGRAMS OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
SO THAT WE CAN BE WELL INFORMED.
ABOUT THE MOST EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMS AND HELPING TO IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF HEALTH OUTCOMES OF
THE AREAS WHO ARE MOST IN NEED.
I WOULD LIKE TO MEANT TO COMMAND
CARP FOR BEING HERE TODAY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS RELATED TO THIS
AUDIT.
AND FOR OUR SHARED COMMITMENT TO
PROVIDING INCENTIVES AND
PROGRAMS TO THE MOST
ECONOMICALLY AND ENVIRONMENTALLY
DISADVANTAGED.
AREAS OF OUR STATE.
CARVERS MADE A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS HELP ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES FOR INSTANCE IN 20171880%
OF THE FUNDING.
UP FOR FUNDING AGRICULTURE
REPLACE MEASURES FOR MISSIONS
REDUCE REDUCTION WAS ALLOCATED
TO THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT.
HOWEVER THERE ARE UNCERTAINTIES
AND UNKNOWN COSTS AND BENEFITS
BOTH DIRECT AND INDIRECT. TO
MANY OF THE POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE
AND ENSURING THAT WE INVEST
HEAVILY.
IN THE MOST POLLUTED AND POOREST
AREAS OF OUR STATE. FOR EXAMPLE
I JON MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES
FROM RULE CAN COUNTIES INVOICING
OUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE LACK OF
INVESTMENT.
IN ELECTRICAL VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS FOR RURAL AREAS.
AND ON A SIDE NOTE ALL.
THERE WAS A SENATOR ONE OF OUR
SENATE COLLEAGUES WHO ACTUALLY
CAME TO THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY --
TO TO TO HOST A HEARING WHICH WE
HOSTED TOGETHER.
HAD A VERY VERY DIFFICULT TIME
FINDING A PLACE. TO PLUG IN HIS
OWN VEHICLE.
OF THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
PROPOSED IN THE VOLKSWAGON CYCLE
TO Z. E. V. INVESTMENT PLAN.
ONLY TWO MILLION OR 1% OF THAT
MONEY IS PROPOSED FOR RULE
CHARGING STATIONS.
THIS IS REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT NEED TO BE LOOKED
AT AND ADDRESSED MOVING FORWARD
AS WE INVEST IN POLICIES AND
PLANS TO IMPROVE OUR QUALITY IT
IS CRITICAL THAT WE UNDERSTAND.
THE IMPACT THAT THESE WILL HAVE
ON OUR STATE WHICH IS WHAT THE
OUT A REQUEST WOULD HELP TO
ACHIEVE.
I AM PROUD TO VOTED FOR LAST
YEAR'S EXTENSION.
OF THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
MAYBE THREE NINETY EIGHT CAN YOU
TO BE AN ENVIRONMENTAL LEADER
FOR THE NATION IN THE WORLD.
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
REPORT RELEASED A REPORT THAT
WAS REQUIRED THAT WAS REQUIRED
AS PART OF AB THREE NINETY EIGHT
THERE.
RAISES A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS AND
I KNOW COSTS ABOUT THE POLICIES
AND PROGRAMS WE HAVE IN PLACE.
THE LA --
REPORT ALSO CALLED FOR GREATER
USE OF INDEPENDENT REVIEWERS TO
ASSESS POLICY AFFECTS.
AS ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERS IN THE
NATION AND THE WORLD.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO ACT BOLDLY
[inaudible]
NOT BLINDLY.
IT IS THE HOPE OF THIS REQUEST
THAT WE REVIEW AND ASSESS THE
EFFECTS AN OPPORTUNITY COST OF
THESE POLICIES ON THE MOST
ENVIRONMENTALLY AND ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN OUR
STATE.
THIS CRITICAL THAT WE HAVE THE
RIGHT TOOLS TO ASSESS THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF POLICIES MOVING
FORWARD [inaudible]
AND THE INTEREST OF TIME I'M
JUST GOING TO GO TO MY CLOSING
REMARKS MISTER CHAIR.
IN CONCLUSION I BELIEVE NO
AGENCY SHOULD BE ABOVE REPROACH.
NO AGENCY SHOULD BE ABOVE
REPROACH AND IT IS OUR DUTY AS
LEGISLATORS WHO ARE STEWARDS OF
THE TAX.
PAYER DOLLAR TO DOLLAR TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO ENSURE THAT GOVERNMENT IS
EFFICIENT.
AND RESPONSIVE TO CALIFORNIA'S
NEEDS IT IS MY INTENTION TO
CONTINUE TO EXAMINE AND REVIEW
CARBON OTHERS TO ENSURE WE ARE
GETTING THE MOST EFFICIENT AND
RESPONSIBLE USE OF OUR TAXPAYER
DOLLARS.
I AM HOPEFUL THAT THE GOVERNOR
AND HIS ADMINISTRATION ARE TRUE
TO THE GOVERNOR'S WORDS --
THAT HE SAID DURING HIS STATE OF
THE STATE.
WHERE HE CALLED FOR MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY?
WE NEED TO STAND UP AND TAKE AN
ANALYTICAL HAVING IN OUR MOST
POLLUTED COMMUNITIES UP AND DOWN
THE STATE.
AND AUDIT CAN HELP PROVIDE THE
NUMBERS WE NEED TO DETERMINE
WHICH PROGRAMS ARE WORKING.
AND WHICH ONES ARE NOT ARE WE
GETTING THE DESIRED REDUCTIONS
IN OUR MOST POLLUTED AREAS WHERE
OUR FAMILIES ARE SUFFERING.
THANK YOU MISTER GIVE ME
WITNESSES.
AND I BELIEVE WE'RE MOVING TO
THE STATE.
MINIMUM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
AS AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
INDICATED IT WOULD BE AN AUDIT
OF THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD ONE
SET OF OBJECTIVES IS LOOKING AT
EXISTING POLICIES AND THIS IS.
WITH RESPECT TO TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS --
AND LOOKING AT A SELECTION OF
THOSE PROGRAMS AND DETERMINING
WHETHER OR NOT THOSE PROGRAMS
HAVE HAD A POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE
IMPACT --
AND PARTICULARLY IF THERE'S
INTERACTIONS WITH VARIOUS
PROGRAMS AS WELL BUT LOOKING AT
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF A SELECTION
OF SOME OF THE POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS THAT WERE INTENDED TO
REDUCE OVERALL EMISSIONS AND AND
BE COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS --
HE'S ALSO ASKED US TO LOOK AT
THE VARIOUS REGIONS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA CLEANING THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY.
AS FAR AS ASSESSMENT OF THE
EFFECTS AND BENEFITS OF SOME OF
THESE POLICIES AND PROGRAMS ON
REGIONS OF THE STATE.
PARTICULARLY INCLUDING SAN
JOAQUIN THEN ANOTHER OBJECTIVE
IS ASKING US TO LOOK AT WHAT
THEY ARE BE HAS DONE TO EVALUATE
NEW POLICIES OR PROGRAMS THEY
HOPE TO IMPLEMENT.
AND WHAT FACTORS DID ON THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD CONSIDER WHEN
CONDUCTING THOSE ANALYSES SO WE
WOULD BE EXPECTING TO SEE THEM
LOOKING AT AFFECTS AND BENEFITS
TO AIR QUALITY EFFECTS ON THE
ENVIRONMENT.
REGIONAL AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENTS TO SIT THEIR
ANALYSIS AND WHAT FACTORS DID
THEY INCLUDE IN CONDUCTING THAT
ANALYSIS.
ALSO LOOKING AT THESE ANALYSES
TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT A
ARE BE CONSIDERED AN ANALYZED
AGAIN INTERACTION BETWEEN A NEW
PROGRAM AND AN EXISTING PROGRAM.
TO THE EXTENT THERE MAY BE
DETRIMENTAL.
OUTCOMES WITH RESPECT TO THAT
ALSO LOOKING AT WHETHER OR NOT A
R. B. AGAIN IN CONDUCTING THESE
ANALYSES CONSIDERED.
MEASURABLE OUTCOME SO THAT THEY
COULD CONTINUE TO MONITOR
IMPROVEMENTS AS A RESULT OF A
PARTICULAR PROGRAM --
AND THEN THE LAST OBJECTIVE OUR
KEY OBJECTIVE IS REALLY LOOKING
AT A ARBY'S PROCESS FOR
EVALUATING THE EFFECTIVENESS AND
EFFICIENCY OF THESE
TRANSPORTATION POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS.
AGAIN ARE THEY CONSIDERING THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN PARTICULAR
PROGRAMS ARE THERE WAYS A. R. B.
COULD IMPROVE HOW IT MEASURES
THE EFFECTS AND BENEFITS OF
VARIOUS PROGRAMS --
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN
THE STATE.
AND THEN --
IDENTIFYING PROGRAMS THAT ARE
BOTH EFFICIENT EFFECTIVE IN
REDUCING GAS EMISSIONS BUT
PERHAPS THOSE THAT ARE NOT SO
THE STATE COULD MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS AS TO WHICH PROGRAMS
TO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN.
AND THOSE PERHAPS THAT ARE NOT
AS BENEFICIAL AS ORIGINALLY
INTENDED --
THE BUDGET FOR THIS PARTICULAR
AUDIT IS ABOUT THIRTY FOUR
HUNDRED HOURS WE THINK SOME OF
THE ANALYSES WILL BE RELATIVELY
COMPLEX WE ALSO AS I SAID SOME
OF THE OBJECTIVES ARE REALLY
LOOKING AT THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AND WHAT ANALYSES HAVE
THEY COMPLETED.
OF EXISTING PROGRAMS AND
CERTAINLY ANY PROGRAMS THAT THEY
HOPE -- TO
IMPLEMENT IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU MISTER [inaudible]
AMANDA MARKETERS --
OR ANY OTHER AFFECTED AGENCY --
WHEN YOU HAVE A CHANCE PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD?
THANK YOU VICE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON IT RICHARD
CORY MAKE SECOND OF OFFICER THE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO AND SPEAK WITH YOU.
THE FEW REMARKS I'D LIKE TO MAKE
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SO.
AS YOU ARE AWARE.
MANY OF CARBS PROGRAMS ACHIEVE A
TRIPLE.
BANG FOR THE BUCK REDUCING
CRITERION TOXIC EMISSIONS THAT
DIRECTLY IMPACT COMMUNITY HEALTH.
AS WELL AS REDUCING GHG
EMISSIONS AFFECT CLIMATE CHANGE.
THIS IS OUR GOAL WE'RE
DEVELOPING POLICY OUR PACKAGE OF
POLICIES REGULATORY AND
INCENTIVES ARE DRIVEN BY STATE
LEGISLATIVE MANDATES.
AND APPROPRIATIONS AS WELL AS A
REQUIREMENT TO ACHIEVE FEDERAL.
HEALTH PROTECTIVE AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS OVER THE LAST FIFTY
YEARS.
DUE TO LOCAL AND STATE
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS
INCENTIVES AND INITIATIVES
EMISSIONS HAVE BEEN TRENDING
DOWN ACROSS THE BOARD.
THIS PROGRESSES WHY
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE WORLD
COPY CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM.
IS REGULATIONS RANGE FROM
SETTING VEHICLE EMISSION
STANDARDS REQUIREMENTS FOR
CLEANER FUELS DEVELOPING CLEANER
FORMULATIONS FOR CONSUMER
PRODUCTS.
A FEW EXAMPLES OF OUR PROGRESS
TODAY DIESEL PARTICULATE MATTER
EMISSIONS WHICH HAVE SERIOUS
LOCAL COMMUNITY HEALTH
IMPLICATIONS HAVE DECREASED
APPROXIMATELY 80% SINCE 199080%.
IN RESPONSE TO A SERIES
REGULATIONS VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS
AND SENATE BASED PROGRAMS CARBON
PLUMMETED.
OVER THE LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS
STATE WIDE EMISSIONS AND
ASSOCIATED HEALTH IMPACTS FROM
AIR TOXICS EXPOSURE HAVE BEEN
REDUCED BY ABOUT 75%.
AS AN EXAMPLE IN RIVERSIDE THE
SIDE OF OUR FUTURE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA MOTOR VEHICLE TESTING
FACILITY.
THE SKIES ARE VISIBLY CLEARER
AND THE NUMBER OF ON HEALTHY
DAIS.
IS ONE THIRD WHAT IT WAS IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
EMISSIONS FROM A NEW CAR ARE 99%
CLEANER.
THAN A CAR FROM THE NINETEEN
SEVENTY SANDERS ESTABLISHED IN
CALIFORNIA THIS PROGRESSES IN
RESPONSE THAT WORK AND FOLLOWED
NATIONALLY.
AS I MENTIONED THE STANDARDS SET
HERE COPY THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
IN THE WORLD.
THUS PEOPLE WELL BEYOND OUR
BORDERS.
BENEFIT FROM CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP ON CLEAN AIR.
LET ME BE CLEAR ON THIS POINT
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER.
WE FULLY RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S
MORE WORK AHEAD OF US
APPROXIMATELY ONE THIRD OF
CALIFORNIANS NEARLY FORTY
MILLION RESIDENTS STILL LIVING
COMMUNITIES THAT EXCEED.
THE FEDERALLY HEALTH PROTECTIVE
STANDARDS EXPOSURE TO DIESEL
PARTICULATES.
IS TOO HIGH ESPECIALLY IN
COMMUNITIES NEAR FREIGHT
FACILITIES [inaudible]
PORTS RAILYARDS DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS.
AND TO THE MAIN POINTS RAISED IN
LA -- THIS
REPORT.
THE REPORT WAS DRIVEN BY
SPECIFIC LEGISLATION IS NOTED AB
THREE NINETY EIGHT WHICH
DIRECTED LA --
TO LOOK AT THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS
AND BENEFITS OF CALIFORNIANS GHG
GOALS.
REPORT USES GHG REDUCTION LANDS.
DOES NOT CONSIDER THE OTHER
STATE GRAMS THE FOCUS ON
REDUCING OTHER FORMS OF
POLLUTION OZONE PARTICULATE
MATTER. TO CHEAP AIR QUALITY
REDUCTIONS AND METER HEALTH
BASED AIR QUALITY STANDARDS IN
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING THE SOUTH
COAST IN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
BY APPROACHING THE REPORT FROM A
PURE GHG FOCUS THE LA --
REPORT CONCLUDES THAT THE STATE
SHOULD BE RELYING MORE ON CAP
AND TRADE FOR CHEATING GHG GOALS.
THIS APPROACH MISSIONS MISSES
THE OTHER KEY DRIVERS REGARDING
OUR TRANSPORTATION STRATEGIES
THE NEED TO REDUCE KNOCKS
EMISSIONS.
AND TOXIC POLLUTANTS IN SHORT.
THE FOCUS FOR PROGRAMS IS MUCH
MORE DIVERSE.
AND THE PACKAGE OF POLICIES THAT
WE PUT TOGETHER IS BASED ON AN
ANALYSIS OF THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO REDUCE.
EMISSIONS TO CHEAPER FEDERAL
MANDATES STATE REQUIRED
STATUTORY PROGRAMS ENERGY THE
STATE'S GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
GOALS.
FURTHER.
THE PLANS ARE HOLISTICALLY
PRESENTED IN THE STATE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
AS WELL AS THE SCOPING PLAN.
ANOTHER KEY POINT IS TO
UNDERSCORE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR TO MEETING
OUR AIR QUALITY AND CLIMATE
GOALS SPECIFICALLY.
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IN
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS 40% OF OUR
GHG EMISSIONS. 80% OF OUR KNOCKS
EMISSIONS.
AND ABOUT 95% OF OUR DIESEL PM
EMISSIONS THE SECTOR CONSISTS OF
OVER THIRTY MILLION CARS TRUCKS.
CARGO HANDLING EQUIPMENT MARINE
VESSELS BUSES MOTORCYCLES IN THE
LIST GOES ON THE STRATEGIES FOR
ACHIEVING EMISSION REDUCTIONS
MUST CONSIDER.
THE COSTS AS WELL AS THE
FEASIBILITY.
IN SHORT THERE'S NO SINGLE
SOLUTION WE CANNOT ACHIEVE
HEALTHIER QUALITY. TO REACH OUR
CLARA CLIMATE GOALS WITHOUT THE
MULTI PART AIR QUALITY GOALS
WITHOUT A MULTI PRONGED APPROACH
FURTHER.
DISTRESS OLDEST MISTER GORE.
THIS --
FORTUNATELY AS A TWO MINUTE RULE
ON PRESENTATIONS AND I TEND TO
BE PRETTY LIBERAL THAT. FOR
EVERYBODY SO BUT HAVING SAID
THAT I I WOULD I THINK I NEED TO
ASK YOU.
TO GET CLOSE TO WRAPPING UP I
WOULD EL DO THAT AND THIRTY
SECONDS.
AS CHAIR SO WITH IN MY REMARKS.
RESPOND TO EACH OF THE QUICK
QUESTIONS THAT WAS RAISED IN THE
J. LACKS LETTER TO US.
IN MY POINT IS.
THIS QUESTIONS WERE REASONABLE
APPROPRIATE.
NO DEBATE ON THAT.
MY POINT IS.
THE RESPONSE TO THOSE QUESTIONS
IN TERMS OF THE PROCESS TO
DEVELOP REX THE PROGRESS THAT
WE'VE MADE WE POST THIS
INFORMATION THIS INFORMATION IS
AVAILABLE IN FACT.
BECAUSE OF FITNESS INFORMATION
FOR THE CAP AND TRADE PROCEEDS
IS SUBMITTED ANNUALLY. TO
LEGISLATURE. TO MY POINT IS BY
VIRTUE OF FORCE THE LEGISLATURE
BY VIRTUE OF DOCUMENTS THAT WE
ANALYZE AND TRACK EMISSIONS.
COMPLIANCE WE DO MANUAL
COMPLIANCE REPORT COMPLIANCE
INSPECTIONS MY POINT IS THE
RESPONSE I BELIEVE THOSE
QUESTIONS.
IS ALREADY AVAILABLE AND I WOULD
LOOK FORWARD OPPORTUNITY TO SIT
DOWN WITH STAFF AND WALK THROUGH
THAT WHICH I DIDN'T HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY UNTIL.
I TO TODAY SO IN CLOSING.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S
THERE'S A LOT HERE WHAT I JUST
SAID.
BUT IN FACT THE SCOPE OF THE
AUDIT WOULD ACCOMPLISH OVER
THIRTY PROGRAMS.
BUT AGAIN MY MAIN POINT IS I
BELIEVE THE F. MATERIALS.
WE ALONG WITH MY TEAM --
OPEN THE MEETING WITH MEMBERS OR
YOUR RESPECTIVE STAFF TO DISCUSS
MATERIALS AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
WERE ALSO OPEN TO DISCUSSING HOW
TO BETTER DISSEMINATE
INFORMATION WITHOUT I'LL
CONCLUDE.
THANK YOU WELL BEFORE I TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR A
QUESTIONS --
LET ME JUST MAKE A COMMENT AND
ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS MYSELF TO
SORT OF SET THE STAGE --
FOR OTHER QUESTIONS THAT MAY
FOLLOW --
MISS CHAIRS YOU KNOW I HAVE BEEN
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FOR SINCE I
READ THIS REQUEST ABOUT THE
BREADTH OF THE REQUEST.
FRANKLY IT APPEARS TO ME BASED
ON THE THE QUESTIONS AND THE
ISSUES TO BE STUDIED.
BY THE STATE AUDITOR TO BE ABOVE
STATEWIDE PROGRAMMATIC REVIEW OF
THE YEAR RESOURCES BOARDS.
GRAMS WHICH MAY BE APPROPRIATE --
AT SOME POINT BUT PERHAPS NOT AT
THIS TIME AND PERHAPS NOT IN
THIS.
IN THIS FORM OF THIS WAY.
BASED ON YOUR OPENING.
AND YOUR CLOSING I GUESS IT
APPEARS THAT YOUR PRIMARY
CONCERN WHICH IS A JUSTIFIABLE.
ONE IS EQUITY FUNDING IN THIS
OTHER AREAS --
IN THE STATE THAT HAVE BEEN
DESIGNATED AS NON ATTAINMENT
AREAS IS THAT.
IS THAT A FAIR STATEMENT.
THAT THAT'S THE FIRST I'VE BEEN
MISTER --
MISTER CHAIR MISTER VICE CHAIR
MISTER ROTH ECONOMY LIKE.
HELLO SO HAVING SAID THAT LET ME
JUST AS THE ME JUST ASK.
OF SOME FOLKS IN QUESTIONS I'M
WONDERING IF WE CAN GET AT LEAST
INITIALLY GET AT SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION --
IN ANOTHER WAY --
SCORE YOU'VE HEARD.
THE COMMITTEE CHAIR.
SOMEONE OVER SALAS EXPRESS
CONCERNS ABOUT EQUITY FUNDING --
IN THE STATE NOT ONLY IN THE
AREA THAT HE REPRESENTS BUT
PERHAPS OTHERS BUT CERTAINLY WE
NEED TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT HIS
AREA BECAUSE THAT'S THE YEAR HE
REPRESENTS.
HE'S ASK FOR THE STATE AUDITOR
TO JUMP IN HERE AND DO AN AUDIT
BECAUSE HE'S HAVING DIFFICULTY
GETTING INFORMATION FROM
APPARENTLY FROM ME --
RESOURCES BOARD AND HE'D LIKE
THE INFORMATION TO DELIVER TO BE
DELIVERED IN SOME.
WRITTEN FORMAT --
NOW ARE YOU.
OR IS HE A ARE BE ABLE TO AND
WILLING TO WORK WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TO GET HIM THE INFORMATION THAT
HE HAS REQUESTED WITH RESPECT IN
PARTICULAR TO EQUITY FUNDING IN
THE NON ATTAINMENT AREAS WITH
PARTICULAR EMPHASIS ON THE ONE
THAT HE REPRESENTS.
ABSOLUTELY.
AND WHAT TIMELINE WOULD YOU NEED
TO DO TO HAVE IN ORDER TO DO
THAT.
BEFORE WE DECIDE IF HE'S WILLING
TO DO SO --
TO REVISIT THIS REQUEST.
THE FIRST STEP IS HE'LL HAVE A
REPORT BY THE END OF THIS WEEK
THAT DOCUMENTS G. G. R. F. CAP
AND TRADE EXPENDITURES.
BY BASED ON LEGISLATIVE
APPROPRIATIONS THAT ALSO TRACKS
AB FIFTY YOU KNOW FIVE WHICH IS
HOW MUCH OF THOSE DOLLARS IS
GOING AND DISADVANTAGED AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES.
SO LET THIS WEEK FIRST REPORT.
FIRST WELL AND AND AND I'M
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN.
IN A OR B. RESPONDING DIRECTLY
TO REMEMBER TO THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE ON HIS SPECIFIC
REQUESTS SO WHAT ADDITIONAL TIME
WE YOU NEED IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THOSE.
I I'D LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SIT DOWN.
WITH THE HIS STAFF NEXT WEEK WE
CAN TALK ABOUT THE AD FUNDING
THERE THE INFORMATION THAT WAS
DESCRIBED IS ALREADY AVAILABLE I
DON'T NEED TO PULL I'VE JUST
WILL DRAW FROM WHAT WE ALREADY
HAVE.
BECAUSE IT EXPLAINS
APPROPRIATIONS WHERE THOSE
DOLLARS HAVE GONE HOW MUCH OF
GOING INTO THE VALLEY SO I'M
READY TO SIT DOWN.
NOW.
WELL MISTER CHAIR ONE APPROACH
YOU MIGHT.
CONSIDER TAKING HERE IS.
TO TAKE UP THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD ON ITS OFFER TO PROVIDE TO
NOT ONLY SIT DOWN WITH YOU BUT
MY INTENT WOULD BE TO HAVE THEM
PROVIDE YOU WAS WRITTEN.
RESPONSES TO YOUR INQUIRY AND IF
YOU DEEM THOSE RESPONSES TO BE
SATISFACTORY --
I GUESS THAT COULD BE THE END OF
IT IF YOU DEEM THE RESPONSES TO
BE TO NOT BE SATISFACTORY.
YOU COULD --
REVISIT YOUR AUDIT REQUEST WITH
YOUR COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
APPRECIATE YOUR DIPLOMACY AND
ALL THE THE HOURS OF DISCUSSION
WE'VE HAD ON THIS ITEM --
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
I STILL WANTED TO PROCEED AT
LEAST.
WITH PRESENTING TODAY'S AUDIT IS
TO GET THINGS ON THE RECORD --
LIKE I STATED IN MY OPENING I DO
CARE ABOUT THOSE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AREAS OF THE STATE THAT ARE
SUFFERING THE MOST NOT ONLY IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BUT UP AND
DOWN THE ENTIRE STATES WHETHER
YOU'RE LOOKING AT A COMMUNITY
OFF THE FOUR OH FIVE FREEWAY.
DOWN AT THE BORDER OR EVEN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WHERE THEY
DON'T HAVE ELECTRIC CHARGING
STATIONS YOU KNOW I CARE ABOUT
THOSE COMMUNITIES WHERE THOSE
FAMILIES ARE LIVING.
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
IN POOR AIR QUALITY STANDARDS
HAVE HIGHER RATES OF PM TWO
POINT FIVE ARE PM.
TEN WE KNOW THAT.
PREMATURE DEATHS --
THOSE FACTORS LEAD TO PREMATURE
DEATH SLIGHTLY TO A NUMBER OF
HEALTH OUTCOMES --
THOSE ARE THE QUESTIONS I'VE
BEEN TRYING TO GET I FEEL LIKE
WE'VE BEEN.
FIGHTING AND ARGUING FOR FOR FOR
SEVERAL YEARS AND WHICH IS WHY.
WHEN WE POSSIBLY BILL THREE
NINETY EIGHT WE FOUGHT SO HARD
TO INCLUDE SOME OF THE
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES IN THAT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION AND
SUBSEQUENT LEGISLATION SINCE
THEN -- BUT
FOR THE RECORD --
MISTER CHAIR OF I CAN'T PERHAPS
SO WE CAN --
SPEED THIS ALONG WHAT I WOULD
LIKE TO DO IS READ A LIST OF
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE FOR THEIR
BE SO THAT WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME
PAGE.
IN TERMS OF THE ANSWERS AND AND
ME COMING BACK TO THIS COMMITTEE --
WITH THE RESUBMIT ALL DEPENDING
ON FROM THE AGENCY.
SO I WILL PROCEED AND HOPEFULLY
SAVE A LOT OF TIME BY DOING SO.
SO HERE ARE SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT I THAT I HAVE FOR
THE AGENCIES.
AND ESPECIALLY WITH MY PASSION
FOR FOR STANDING UP FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT SUFFERED THE
MOST -- ONE
WHAT IS THE OVERALL BUDGET OF
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD --
WHAT YEAR WAS THAT WAS CARP
FOUNDED HOW MANY AUDITS HOW MANY
COMPREHENSIVE AUDITS HAVE TAKEN
HAVE BEEN UNDERTAKEN TO REVIEW
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF ITS
PROGRAMS IN THAT TIME?
HOW MANY TRANSPORTATION POLICIES
AND PROGRAMS WE HAVE IN PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT FALL UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF CARP?
WHAT WAS A BUDGET AMOUNT OF
INVESTMENTS THAT CARVE ALLOCATED
TO THE STATE FOR INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS OVER THE LAST DECADE
WHAT IS THE AMOUNT OF
INVESTMENTS THAT WILL BE MADE IN
THIS BUDGET YEAR?
NUMBER FIVE DO YOU HAVE
AVAILABLE DATA AND HOW THAT
SPENDING WILL BE MADE BY REGION
AND WHAT.
THE ESTIMATED REDUCTIONS IN
EMISSIONS WILL BE OVERALL AND IN
EACH REGION OF THE STATE
ESPECIALLY.
THOSE MOST POLLUTED COMMUNITIES
UP AND DOWN THE ENTIRE STATE
WHAT ARE THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS OF YOUR MAJOR GHQ PROGRAMS --
IN A NUMBER SEVEN IN ASSESSING
THE OVERALL EFFECTS OF OUR
STATES POLICIES DO YOU HAVE A
WAY TO PAUL QUANTIFY ALL
VARIABLES.
AND FACTORS THAT AFFECT
EMISSIONS SUCH AS ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS NUMBER EIGHT WHAT ARE
YOUR MOST HIGH PRIORITY PROGRAMS
NUMBER NINE WHAT TARGETED
POLICIES YOU HAVE IN PLACE TO
HELP LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS DEAL
WITH SOME OF THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CURRENT
TRANSPORTATION.
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES NUMBER TEN
DO YOU HAVE AIMED AT SUPPORTING
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATIONS SUCH
AS INCENTIVES FOR PILOTS AND
DEMONSTRATIONS OF NEW
TECHNOLOGIES.
DO YOU HAVE IN PLACE.
A NUMBER ELEVEN WITH RESPECT TO
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM AND
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM.
DO YOU HAVE AVAILABLE DATA ON
WHAT THE AVERAGE INCOME LEVEL IS
FOR THOSE WHO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE PROGRAM.
OF THE TOTAL FIVE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE MILLION IN REBATES
TO CUSTOMER SINCE TWENTY TEN DO
YOU HAVE SPECIFIC DATA TO WHICH
REGIONS OF THE STATE HAVE
PROPORTIONATELY RECEIVE THESE
REBATES.
NUMBER.
TWELVE OF THE ONE BILLION THAT
HAS BEEN SPENT OR IS PLANNED TO
BE SPENT ON THE Z. V.
INFRASTRUCTURE WHAT PERCENTAGES
PLAN.
CHOOSE TO BE SPENT IN EACH
REGION OF THE STATE BY
PERCENTAGE.
NUMBER THIRTEEN ACCORDING TO THE
RESEARCH FOR THE CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY.
WHICH ADMINISTERS A CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM FOR
CARBON MORE THAN HALF OF THE
CONSUMERS WHO HAVE RECEIVED A
REBATE REPORTED THAT.
THEY WOULD HAVE PURCHASED A CV
Z. E. V..
EVEN IF THE PROGRAM DID NOT
EXIST.
DO YOU HAVE A PLAN TO TARGET
THIS PROGRAM MORE TOWARDS PEOPLE
WHO WOULD NOT PURCHASES EVEY --
VEHICLE WITHOUT THE REBATE ARE
THERE WAYS TO REDUCE THE FREE
RIDER PROBLEM --
FREE RIDERS ARE THOSE WHO WOULD
HAVE PURCHASED THESE --
Z. EVEY WITHOUT THE REBATE --
NUMBER FOURTEEN THE LA --
REPORT --
STATES THAT THESE PROGRAMS COST
AND BENEFITS WOULD BETTER ASSIST
THE LEGISLATURE IN POLICY MAKING
DECISIONS REGARDING HOW TO
ALLOCATE LIMITED LIMITED
RESOURCES DO YOU HAVE A PLAN. TO
DO SO.
NUMBER FIFTEEN WHICH OF THE
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE PROGRAMS ARE
MOST LIKELY TO ENCOURAGE
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION WHICH
PROGRAMS ARE MOST LIKELY TO
ACHIEVE THE GREATEST REDUCTIONS
AND CO POLLUTANTS.
NUMBER SIXTEEN IS THERE A WAY TO
CONSOLIDATE HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ADMINISTERED
BY DIFFERENT AGENCIES TO IMPROVE
COORDINATION AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
ON THE LC OFFENSE.
A QUESTION SEVENTEEN THE LA --
AND OTHER RESEARCHERS ASSERT
DETERMINED THAT THE LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD HAS MUCH HIGHER
ECONOMIC COSTS AND THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM.
DO YOU HAVE A WAY TO DETERMINE
WHAT THE COSTS ARE TO THE LOWEST
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
ARE THERE WAYS TO MITIGATE THOSE
COSTS TO THE LOWEST INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS.
NUMBER EIGHTEEN THE LA OBEYED
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
LEGISLATURE --
ENSURE THAT THE L. CFS THE
CHIEFS OF SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS
THAT HAPPENED TRADE DOES NOT.
THAT THESE BENEFITS OUTWEIGH
HIGHER PROGRAM COSTS IS THERE A
PLAN IN PLACE TO ACHIEVE THIS
GOAL.
NUMBER NINETEEN IS THERE A PLAN
OR REVIEW PROCESS THAT CARP IS
LOOKING AT TO MAKE DESIGN
CHANGES TO THE LC FS.
THAT BETTER TARGET THE PROGRAM
TOWARD INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES
[inaudible]
NUMBER.
TWENTY HOW MUCH FUNDING IS
ALLOCATED TOWARD RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES RELATED
TO LOW CARBON FUELS TWENTY ONE
THE LEGISLATURE HAS NO STATUTORY
DISCRETION. FOR THE REBATES AND
INCENTIVES PROVIDED THROUGH THE
LC FS CAN YOU PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THESE REBATES.
AND INCENTIVES AND HOW THEY HAVE
BEEN ALLOCATED BY REGION. TWENTY
TWO HAS CARP LOOKED AT OR
CONSIDERED ESTABLISHING HARD
PRICE CEILING FOR THE L. CFS
SIMILAR TO THE CAP AND TRADE
PRICE SELLING.
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED BY ASSEMBLY
BILL.
THREE NINETY EIGHT NUMBER TWENTY
THREE HAS CARP IDENTIFIED THE
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE HIT HARDEST
BY AIR POLLUTION. TWENTY FOUR
HAVE WE MONITORED THE POOR AIR
QUALITY COMMUNITIES TO DETERMINE
HOW PARTICULATE MATTER AND G. H.
D. LEVELS.
HAVE INCREASED OR DECREASED
SINCE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB.
THIRTY TWO AND QUESTION.
TWENTY FIVE WHAT INVEST IN THIS
COMMUNITIES AND WHAT MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES HAVE COME ABOUT.
AND THIS GOES TO MY OTHER
STATEMENT WHICH WAS ON LIFE
EXPECTANCY --
GHETTO DOES LIFE EXPECTANCY DROP
FOR THESE COMMUNITIES WERE
GREATLY IN ADVERSELY AFFECTED BY.
POOR AIR QUALITY WHAT PROGRAMS
HAS CARP IMPLEMENTED IN THESE
COMMUNITIES TO HELP.
THESE FAMILIES THAT ARE
SUFFERING THE MOST FROM
POLLUTION UP AND DOWN THE ENTIRE
STATE.
MISTER CHAIR I ASSUME --
THAT YOU WILL PROVIDE A COPY OF
THOSE I NOTICED THAT THEY WERE
TAKING NOTES FURIOUSLY BUT THAT
YOU WILL PROVIDE A COPY OF THOSE.
QUESTIONS TO THE A. R. B.
REPRESENTATIVES.
SO THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE ANSWERS
MISSED COR YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ASKING.
I DO YOU MAY NEED TO REVISE YOUR
TIME ASIDE UPWARD I WILL INDEED --
THIS COMMITTEE MEETS
PERIODICALLY IN THE NEXT MEETING
IS.
IS IN JUNE.
WELL THE BILL WOULD REACT CLOSE
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR YES.
WE'LL GET TO A SHOPPING LIST.
TO A MISTER CHAIR SO YOU'LL YOU
HAVE THE ROLE OF THE COMMITTEE
SCHEDULE SO I ASSUME IT WILL BE
A MONTH OR SO BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE MEETS AGAIN AT LEAST.
SO I'M SURE YOU'LL HAVE THAT
PERIOD OF TIME COULD COMPILE TO
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS QUESTIONS I
WILL NEED SEVERAL WEEKS TO WRITE
PREPARE WRITTEN RESPONSE THE
MATERIAL EXIST BUT WE NEED TO
PUT IT ALL IN ONE PLACE AT LEAST
A MONTH.
REAL RECTIFIED AND I APPRECIATE
MISTER CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE --
THE TESTIMONY GIVEN THAT.
THAT THE AUTO REQUEST THAT WE
DID SO THAT WAS A REASONABLE AND
APPROPRIATE BUT PERHAPS THESE
QUESTIONS WILL PROVIDE SOME
CLARITY NOT ONLY FOR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE BUT AS WE LOOK TO
MOVE FORWARD AND POSSIBLY --
RESUBMITTED NOT A REQUEST --
BY LEASE WE HAVE EVERYTHING ON
THE RECORD THAT SOMETHING THAT I
DID WANT TO AT LEAST ACCOMPLISH
HERE TODAY SO --
MISSED YOUR JUST TO MAKE MAKE
SURE I'M CLEAR IN THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ARE CLEAR.
GIVEN THE AIR BEES COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESS YOUR QUESTIONS YOU WILL
WITHDRAW YOUR REQUEST TODAY
SUBJECT TO THE ABILITY TO
RESUBMIT THE AUDIT REQUEST IF
THE RESPONSES ARE NOT ACCEPTABLE
TO YOU.
THAT IS CORRECT AND IT'S UNDER I
BELIEVE OUR PURVIEW --
ALSO CALLED SPECIAL HEARING IF
WE IF NEED BE ABSOLUTELY.
NOW I THINK OF SOME OF YOUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS OF FIRST CENTER
HERTZBERG.
THE DOCUMENT THAT YOU SUBMITTED
MISTER CHAIRMAN TO THIS
COMMITTEE ON JANUARY TWENTY
EIGHT SETS FORCE. FIVE QUESTIONS
THE FIRST ONE HAS THREE SUB
PARTS THE SECOND ONE FOR THE
THIRD TO IN THE LAST TWO DON'T.
THOSE QUESTIONS MAY BE HAMMERED
INTO THE LIST YOU JUST READ OF
TWENTY FIVE QUESTIONS MANY OF
WHICH HAD MANY SUBPART --
I'M JUST TELLING YOU AS A
STUDENT OF THIS INSTITUTION I
DON'T LIKE WHAT HAPPENED HERE
TODAY.
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
ASKING ANY AGES MARK AND TO
REALLY DO THEIR HOMEWORK AND ASK
THE QUESTIONS BUT WHAT I FEEL
HERE TODAY IS THAT YOU WENT AND
SUBMITTED A REQUEST YOU HAVE THE
AUTHOR OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA COME INTO THIS BODY.
YOUR OF CHAIRMAN OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND THAT YOU THEN HAD
HER PREPARE REPORT WITH RESPECT
TO THE FRAMEWORK IN PER VIEW AND
TIME LINES NECESSARY.
AND YOU CLEARLY HAVE HAD A VERY
DETAILED LIST PREPARED BEFORE
YOU SAT DOWN TODAY IN WHAT WAS
BEFORE US TODAY ALL OF WHICH MAY
BE LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS BUT ALL
MANY OF WHICH ARE OUTSIDE THE
PURVIEW OF THE OF WHAT YOU ASKED
HERE TODAY.
WITH RESPECT TO WHAT THE AUDIT
WAS THOSE QUESTIONS MAY OR MAY
NOT BE INCLUDED THE ART I WOULD
SUSPECT A LOT OF THEM WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN INCLUDED IN THE AUDIT.
I CAN GO BACK TO AND READ THE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THAT YOU ASK
ON PAGE TWO OF YOUR TWO PAGE
LETTER.
WHICH IS BASICALLY A HALF LITTLE
BIT MORE THAN A HALF A PAGE AND
WHAT YOU JUST READ WAS VERY MUCH
DIFFERENT.
SO I I I WELL I HAVE DIFFERENCE
TO THE VICE CHAIR AND TO YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
WITH RESPECT TO THIS I THINK
FROM THE PROCESS STANDPOINT WELL
THERE HAS BEEN I THINK DIPLOMACY
ON THE PART OF THE ACTING CHAIR
THE VICE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE.
TO RESPECT YOUR WISHES IT AND TO
BRING THE CAR THE PEOPLE FROM
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE.
I'M A LITTLE --
DISTRAUGHT ABOUT HOW THIS THING
CAME ABOUT THEY WANT TO ANSWER
THESE QUESTIONS THAT'S FINE BUT
I'M VOTE NO ONE THIS AUDIT B.
FOR NO OTHER I WAS GOING TO VOTE
NO BEFORE A BILL NO AGAIN
BECAUSE I THINK THE PROCESS HERE
TODAY.
IS NOT CONSISTENT WITH HOW WE
SHOULD COMPORT OURSELVES IN THIS
LEGISLATURE AND CERTAINLY YOU
COULD HAVE GIVEN THIS
INFORMATION NOT TAKEN THAT THAT
TAX PAYERS MONEY TO WRITE UP A
REPORT IF THIS WAS GOING TO BE
THE CASE.
THANK YOU.
ADD IF I COULD ADDRESS THAT
THANK YOU SAID HERTZBERG I
APPRECIATE YOUR POINT OF VIEW --
OBVIOUSLY WE HAD SUBMITTED THIS
THE QUESTIONS THAT WE FRAMED IN
THE AUDIT WE'RE HOPING TO GET TO
ALL THE ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE
QUEST ONCE WE HAVE THIS
INFORMATION.
I THOUGHT IT WOULD INFORMED THE
REST OF THE OTHER QUESTIONS THAT
I HAD WHICH IS TO IDENTIFY WHAT
ARE THE POLICIES THE MOST
EFFECTIVE POLICIES.
MOVING FORWARD TO US IS
LEGISLATORS WOULD HAVE THE DATA
AVAILABLE. TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS TO MAKE SURE
COMMUNITIES ARE SUFFERING THE
MOST DON'T CONTINUE TO SUFFER
THE MOST BECAUSE OUR POLICIES
THAT I'VE SEEN WHERE.
THEY SAY THE BENEFITS ARE GOING
TO BE BENEFITS THAT WE SEE UNTIL
TEN TWENTY THIRTY YEARS FROM NOW
MEANWHILE FAMILIES LIVING IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES ARE SUFFERING
NOW.
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO
GET AT THE HEART THAT WATER
THOSE POLICIES.
THAT WE SHOULD BE IMPLEMENTING
NOW AN EXPANDING ON TO HELP
THOSE FAMILIES TODAY AND I KNOW
THAT THERE WAS --
SOME DISCOMFORT FOR MEMBERS ON
THE COMMITTEE --
IN THE SENTENCE SO I WANTED TO
ALLOW NOT ONLY US TO CONTINUE TO
PROCEED DILIGENTLY ON THESE
EFFORTS.
BUT TO GIVE SOME TIME FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES ALSO
FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH THE
DIRECTION IN WHICH WE WERE GOING.
AND LET ME JUST SAY I APPRECIATE --
THE WAY YOU'RE HANDLING THIS --
MISTER CHAIR APPRECIATE THAT --
CENTER.
I THINK --
THE THE MAKER OF THIS ITEM NOW
THAT YOU HAVE WITHDRAWN ON THE
PROPOSED AGENDA ITEM --
PENDING THE OUTCOME OF A
RESPONSE FROM --
THEY ARE BE I THINK I POINTS
MOOD.
EXCEPT FOR THE FACT THAT --
SINCE YOU'RE HAPPY MOVING
FORWARD WITH THIS AND HOPEFULLY
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE --
RESPONSIVE PARTNERS RESPONSE THE
DEPARTMENT --
AND IF THIS MATTER NEEDS TO COME
BACK YOU KNOW I'M ALL EARS I'D
LOVE TO HEAR WHAT YOUR FINDINGS
ARE.
THE IDEA OF AN AUDIT TYPICALLY
AT LEAST IN MY OPINION.
IS WHEN INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NOT
MOST KNOWLEDGEABLE.
ARE UNABLE TO ACCESS INFORMATION
FROM THOSE WHO ARE MOST
KNOWLEDGEABLE HAVE TO RELY UPON.
AN EXPERT AND IN HER TEAM TO
COME OVER AND MAKE CERTAIN THAT --
ALL THE STONES ARE TURNED OVER
BUT I THINK IN FROM YOUR
STANDPOINT IT'S NOT THERE YET
BUT IT MIGHT BE MOVING FORWARD
SO I RESPECT.
YOUR WISHES AND WILL ADDRESSES
THAT.
FUTURE TIME NOW.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
FIRST SENATOR RATHER THAN THEIR
MONEY.
YES -- I
APPRECIATE --
SO CHAIR --
TO RAISE ISSUES TODAY --
I COME FROM LA.
WE HAVE THE DIRTIEST AIR IN THE
U. S..
MY DISTRICT IN PARTICULAR IS HIT
ESPECIALLY HARD [inaudible]
ALL.
WERE FAMOUS FOR THE EXCITED.
UP UP PROBLEMS.
AS WAS TRIGGERED BY THE
PARTICULAR LET OUT SPEED BY THE
TRUCKS.
THEY'RE PROBABLY FIVE SIX SEVEN
FREEWAYS THAT CRISS CROSSED TO
THROW MY DISTRICT.
AND KIDS NORMALLY HAVE TO GO TO
THE EMERGENCY OBAMA TO TREAT
THEIR RESPECT RESPIRATORY
ILLNESSES --
SO I KNOW WHAT.
IT IS TO REPRESENT A DISTRICT
THAT NEEDS THE ATTENTION.
NOW -- I
WOULD OF LIKED THAT BECAUSE
YOU'RE RAISING THAT AS WHAT IS.
PERSONALLY ARE IMPORTANT TO YOU
I WOULD HAVE LIKED A MUCH MORE.
FOCUSED.
ATTENTION BECAUSE I THINK A
REPORT THAT ENCOMPASSES SO MANY
ISSUES AS YOU HAVE REYES AND MAY
NOT GET.
TO BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO COVER
SO MUCH GROUND MAY NOT GET.
TO WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
FOCUS SO.
I WOULD HOPE YOU.
WOULD CONSIDER RECONSIDER SOME
OF THOSE SO THAT WE GIVE THE
PROPER FOCUS AND ATTENTION IN A
WAY THAT WE COULD REALLY GRAPPLE
WITH IT.
AND MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THAT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO PARTNERING IT WITH
YOU ON SOME OF THOSE ISSUES LIKE
I SAID THEY AFFECT COMMUNITIES
UP AND DOWN THE ENTIRE STATE.
WHETHER IT'S NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CENTRAL OR SOUTHERN --
AND MY INTENTION IS ONCE WE
RECEIVE ANSWERS FOR ALL THESE
QUESTIONS AND THE ONES POSE
NODDED AS WELL FROM.
THEY ARE BE THAT I'LL SHARE THAT
WITH EVERY MEMBER THANK YOU
SENATOR US OF SOME MONEY.
THANK YOU.
MISTER ACTING CHAIR MISTER CHAIR --
YOU ANSWERED MY QUESTION JUST
THEN I WOULD APPRECIATE COPIES
OF RESPONSES YOU RECEIVED FROM
CAR --
TAKING IN.
THE BIG PICTURE HERE --
THE WORK OF CAR IS TO CONTINUE
TO PUSH. FOR PUBLIC HEALTH.
IN THE BROADER ISSUE IS CLIMATE
CHANGE AFFECTING THE PLANET.
CALIFORNIA'S PROVEN TO BE A
LEADER.
IN SETTING GREENHOUSE --
GAS EMISSION REDUCTION.
TIME TABLES AND YET WE KNOW THE
IMPACTS IN CHANCES ARE DIFFERENT
IN DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES --
BUT AS PART OF THE ONGOING WORK
OF CARB --
THE RESPONSE TO THE EARLIER --
LA -- REPORT
AND RECOMMENDATIONS.
I THINK THE SOLUTION TODAY IN
AGAIN CONTINGENT UPON.
THE THOROUGHNESS OF THOSE
RESPONSES.
BUT I THINK IT ACTUALLY.
HAS THE POTENTIAL OF EXPEDITING
GETTING THIS INFORMATION TO YOU
AND TO THE COMMITTEE --
IT SOUNDS LIKE FROM MISTER COREY
MUCH OF THIS INFORMATION.
IS.
EXISTENCE AND IT'S A MATTER OF
COMPILATION AND MAKING SURE IT'S
IN IN THE MANNER THAT ADDRESSES
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
YOU'VE RAISED.
BUT WE HAVE THE POTENTIAL HERE I
THINK OF A WIN WIN OF NOT HAVING.
TO ABSORB THE COST OF AN ON IT
THE AUDITOR'S SET UP TO DO THIS
WORK BUT AS WE KNOW EVERY ON IT
IS VERY EXPENSIVE AND IT TAKES
TIME.
SO WITH THE COOPERATION OF CARB --
IT'S MY HOPE THAT WE GET THE
RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTIONS THAT
YOU SEEK IN CAN ACTUALLY GET
THAT POTENTIALLY IN A MORE
EXPEDITIOUS MANNER --
AND I DO APPRECIATE YOUR OFFER
TO SHARE THE RESPONSES THE
RECEIVE WITH THIS AND THANK YOU
MISTER A VICE CHAIR ACTING CHAIR
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
RESOLUTION OF THIS.
THANKS IN MINING COLLEAGUES ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS FOLLOW UP DID
YOU PRESENT THIS LIST AND JUST
TRY TO UNDERSTAND BEFORE WE HAVE
FOUR AND FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR REQUEST FOR NOT IT.
WAS THIS LIST THAT YOU JUST READ
PRESENTED TO THE BOARD AND
REJECTED THEY WOULDN'T PROVIDE
THE INFORMATION OR JUST THE
FIRST AND THE HEARING IT SO THIS
IS --
QUESTIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN ASKING
A WORKING POLLUTED AIR FAMILIES
MOST WHAT PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED.
TO LOOK AT THOSE AREAS BUT YOU
KNOW THE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS TO
IS ARE WE EVEN MONITORING THOSE
AREAS.
HAVE WE SEEN A GROWTH OR REGRESS
IN THESE AREAS FOR THE MOST
POLLUTED AREAS THESE ARE
QUESTIONS I CAME UP WITH --
THIS MORNING AS I WAS --
CONTEMPLATING IT LAST NIGHT
TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO MOVE
FORWARD.
ON THE AUDIT REQUESTS SPEAKING
WITH MISTER VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
SO WE WILL BE SUBMITTING THOSE
BUT BUT YOU KNOW HOW TO JAN
OFTEN SUBMITTED TO THEM IS MY
QUESTION WHETHER I I APPRECIATE
THAT THIS IS A CRITICAL ISSUE IS
ALL THE MEMBERS AGREE.
BECAUSE I READ THE QUESTIONS
YEARS ONLY ONE QUESTION EVEN
RELATES TO THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY THE OTHERS JUST SIMPLY --
BROAD QUESTIONS THAT RELATE TO
THE PROGRAM IN ITS ENTIRETY
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT WAS YOUR
OBJECTIVE MY ONLY SENSES THE
SWITCH TO THIS AND DID THESE THE
FOLKS.
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY AND A WE
HEAR BECAUSE THEY SAID WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GIVE THIS TO YOU AND
YOU NEED TO GET IN ON IT OR HAD
THIS THE FIRST INSTANCE WHERE
THEY'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SEE THESE QUESTIONS RIGHT.
SO LET ME HELP FRAME THIS OF THE
AUDIT WE KNOW A LOT OF THE
POLLUTION THAT OCCURS IN THE GHG.
THAT OCCURS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND PROPS AROUND THE WORLD IS
BECAUSE OF TRANSPORTATION.
RIGHT IT IS LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES
THESE QUESTIONS IN THE AUDIT
REPORT WERE DESIGNED AT THE
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES BECAUSE
THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT AFFECT.
NOT ONLY THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
BUT SOUTH COAST LOS ANGELES.
EVERY DISTRICT FOR EVERY MEMBER
THAT'S REPRESENTED HERE TODAY.
THE QUESTIONS LIKE I SAID I CAME
UP WITH THIS MORNING I FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE NOT NEW QUESTIONS OR
QUESTIONS WE'VE BEEN ASKING. FOR
FOR YEARS BUT IF WE NEED TO PUT
IT IN A LETTER FORMAT I'M
PREPARED TO DO THAT AND SUBMIT
THAT AND GIVE THE RESULTS TO
THIS COMMITTEE INTO EVERY MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE AS WELL AS WE
MOVE FORWARD.
AND IT ON THE ON THE COMMENTS
ABOUT THE EXPENSE OF THE AUDIT
THIS IS NOT THE MOST EXPENSIVE
AUDIT.
THAT THE COMMITTEE ACTUALLY
APPROVED TODAY [inaudible]
SIR.
THANK YOU MAY A VICE CHAIR ROTH
I'M LIKE SEVERAL COUPLE
QUESTIONS FOR THE THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE UP THE AIR WAS
JUST MORE.
OF A SUPPORT.
I WANT TO A TO ASK YOU --
I KNOW THAT --
MRS ALICE IS GOING TO SIT.
AND THAT YOU ARE GOING TO TRY
YOUR BEST TO EASE RESPOND TO HIM --
IN WRITING --
SHOULD FOR WHATEVER REASON HE'S.
NOT SATISFY WITH THOSE --
THOSE RESPONSE AND HE BRINGS
THIS REQUEST --
BACK INTO THIS COMMITTEE HEARING
AT A LATER DATE --
FROM YOUR POSITION AS AN AGENCY
A WOULD YOU BE OPPOSED.
TO THE STATE AUDITOR --
REVIEW YOUR A YOUR AGENCY.
I THINK IT WOULD REALLY.
IF IF THIS SCENARIO YOU JUST
DESCRIBED PLAYED OUT AND WE WERE
NOT RESPONSIVE.
MAY THAT'S THE COMES BACK THIS
COMMITTEE I WILL SIT ON THE
SIDELINES BUT I BELIEVE WE'RE
SPONSORED TO EACH OF THESE
QUESTIONS.
WERE -- I SO
SO I WAS TOLD THAT AND AND AND
AND AND NO I'M THE NEWEST KID ON
IN THIS THIS GROUP [inaudible]
YOUR BUT WE'LL GIVE YOU A
SOMETIME --
AS AS A LET'S LIVE OF BODY WE DO
HAVE -- OUR
LET'S LIVE OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY AND IS NOT THAT
WE DON'T --
TRUSTS --
WHAT YOU WHAT YOU SAY --
WHAT GET THE REPORT BACK BUT IT
IS GOOD FOR THE PUBLIC AND FOR
AND -- FOR
THE REPUBLIC TO AT LEAST HAVE A
DIFFERENT SET OF ICE LOOK AT ALL
THE PROGRAMS THAT --
YOU'VE BEEN DOING AND I
ACKNOWLEDGE ALL THE GREAT WORK
THAT A CAR HAS BEEN DOING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE CLEAN AIR
TO BREATHE.
BUT WHAT'S WRONG WITH THE
LEADING THE YOUR PROGRAM IF OF
THE MEAL IF IF EVERYTHING IS
HUNKY DORY.
I UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION I
GUESS MY FIRST RESPONSE WAS THAT
AS I LOOKED AT THE QUESTION THE
NATIONAL QUESTIONS I SAW NOT
THESE ARE NEW ONES BUT I BELIEVE
WE CAN BE EQUALLY RESPONSIVE TO
THEM.
MY RESPONSE WAS IF ONE
CONSIDERED THE DATA THAT'S
ALREADY OUT THERE THROUGH A
SERIES OF LEGISLATIVE REPORTS
ACTUALLY SO MIDDLE SOME OF WHICH
ARE ANNUAL AS WELL AS THE PUBLIC
PROCESS WE GO THROUGH.
THAT WAS MY MAIN POINT WAS.
THE INFORMATION'S IN THERE SO I
COULDN'T HELP BUT ASK WHAT IS
THE OBJECTIVE OF THE AUDIT GOT
IT.
AND AND AND AND ASK YOU THAT
BECAUSE THIS IS ITEM NUMBER --
EIGHT IN IN A VERY LONG --
HEARING AND THIS COMMITTEE
PRETTY MUCH APPROVE.
EVERY REQUEST THAT CAME BEFORE
US -- TODAY
ON AND AND I DON'T I DON'T
REMEMBER A MEMBERS.
OF RAISING COSTS AS AS A ISSUES
AND AND I THINK THAT ALL THESE
REQUESTS ARE PRETTY BIPARTISAN
WHERE I EVEN EVEN MEMBERS ON THE
MAJORITY SO I BELIEVE THAT --
EXECUTIVE AGENCY A ONCE OVER
REVIEW MONEY EVEN IF --
EASY EVEN IF THEY IF IF NOTHING
IS.
A BILL IF IF IF.
EVEN IF YOU'RE NOT.
ON THE HEADLINE.
AND A AND I HOPE THAT OF YOU IN
THIS HOUSE CAN WORK THIS OUT AND
THAT HE WILL BE SATISFIED WITH.
A YOUR RESPONSE --
BUT I I ALSO WISH THAT --
IF FOR WHATEVER REASON --
THIS.
REQUEST COME BACK OF BEFORE US
THAT A YOU WOULD BE AT LEAST
MORE.
RECEPTIVE TO THE IDEA OF HAVING
THIS HELLO A TAKE US.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT IT IS THAT
YOU GUYS ARE DOING I UNDERSTAND.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS GOOD --
MISTER CHAIRMAN COREY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO WORK TOGETHER I LOOK FORWARD
TO A DETAILED RESPONSE TO THOSE
QUESTIONS AND I I AM HOPEFUL
THAT THE CHAIR WILL BE IN THAT
WE WON'T HAVE TO HEAR THIS
MATTER AGAIN BUT IF WE DO WE DO.
MISTER CHAIR AND CLOSING REMARKS
BEFORE YOU I TURN THE GAVEL BACK
TO YOU.
KNOW I JUST APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S --
WILLINGNESS TO WORK TOGETHER ON
THIS -- I
DIDN'T THINK I DID HEAR FROM
CARVE THE THOUGHT IT WAS
REASONABLE --
THE ORIGINAL REQUEST AND LOOK
FORWARD.
I DON'T I THINK I HEARD THAT YOU
WEREN'T.
HE WOULD NOT OPPOSE AN
INDEPENDENT LOOK AT THE AUDIT SO
I I APPRECIATE IT.
I APPRECIATE THAT IF THAT'S
CORRECT --
BUT I REALLY CARE ABOUT THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE SUFFERING THE
MOST AND I REALLY WANT TO HAVE
PROGRAMS DESIGNED AT IMPROVING
THE HEALTH OUTCOMES AND
REMINDING SAID.
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS IN THOSE
MOST AFFECTED COMMUNITIES UP AND
DOWN THE ENTIRE STATE AND
PRECIADO AT YOUR TIME AND YOUR
DIPLOMACY INTELLIGENCE AND
MOVING THIS FORWARD AND IF WE DO
HAVE TO REVISIT THIS MISTER
CHAIR OF FROM THE SENATE SIDE I
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
NARROWING.
THE REQUESTS AND TAILORING AND
MORE THE INDEMNIFIED WANTING
THANK YOU
.
OKAY AT THIS TIME WE'RE GOING TO
OPEN THE ROLE FOR ADD ONS WE'RE
GOING TO START